and Kaiser, a couple other decks there,
and then everything else is like 4% cuz
people are playing for those best of
cards. We did have the meta breakdown a
little bit earlier in the day. We will
be tracking as many of the stories for
the 28 legends here looking at those
best of cards. And uh some of the decks
we've seen are somewhat uh low
representation so far today. As you
said, um that Victor has been higher
representation, but we had the pleasure
of casting this Fortune game earlier
today. I know that Medic and Amy just
cast a Lee Sin game. So plenty of plenty
of different champions going on here.
>> I mean Lein is also so nice. It has
really really good domains. So it is
really calm and body oriented, you know.
So there is good combo tricks in there.
You can have some decent ramp. There is
good. There's so much good of
everything. You have challenge, you have
strike down in the decks that really do
have equipments, but also you have a
card that some decks struggle to deal
with and that is the ruin runner. cards
or abilities. That can actually put
quite some decks in a tough time.
>> And luckily, unlike Lechanically
any better than your opponents in order
to play, you're just playing cards. It's
all good. I don't need to learn how to
dragons rage people while ward hopping.
But those of you that don't actually
play League of Legends won't know
exactly how difficult that is for an old
man with uh with broken thumbs to do.
But no le in this matchup, I believe, as
we get into it. Um, this is going to be
an interesting matchup that we haven't
seen. I haven't seen too much from
today. I'm just trying to remember
exactly which one we've got uh coming
up. It's the set matchup.
>> Yep. Set. And the other deck, I'm not
going to spoiler quite yet. We're going
to take a look at this deck list first.
This is quite buff heavy and it's a fade
dragon as well. It's a unit that I would
really like to pet. It's so adorable. It
is very very very cute artwork. Uh so
set obviously saw a lot of play in
Origins. Um people felt like it was
particularly good into the Kaiser match
up because you could kind of just like
survive through things. Uh one card I
think that makes Set really difficult to
deal with is Punch First. We've talked
it about it earlier today in in other
matchups and how how prevalent it can be
how difficult it can be to play around.
>> You know what I think even in the Kaiso
matchup especially there is another card
that makes it even tougher. You know
that set of course can spend a bit of
power to dodge. There we go. It is
actually Kaiser matchup. So quite tough
there for the Kaisa player. But as soon
as you have your units buffed and they
die, you can just pay a power to recall
them.
>> Mhm.
>> Warmox. Warmox against the newest
iteration of this Kaiser deck. You can
see it. There is so few units in there.
There is no big
>> Darius shenanigans. No helpful. So you
actually get to play so many of these
units. your early drops with the Warmox
into the battlefields, you get them
buffed and then already immediately your
two drops become such a big hurdle to
overcome for the Kai'Sa player. And
Kai'Sa is a deck that didn't receive too
many tools at first from Spirit Forge.
People weren't necessarily looking at at
what was added. They're like, "Ah,
Kai'Sa, she's good enough. Doesn't get
extra." And then people thought, well,
Ferris 4Runner is very good uh as a as a
card. You pay six and then you basically
get 12 might worth over a set of units.
And then people have started mixing in
get excited um to discard high cost
spells and then deal a lot of damage to
it. So a Jinx card that is being brought
in to Kaiser. We'll see how that goes
for our first game of round five. And I
think the addition of get excited. You
know in a draw heavy value deck. You
wouldn't normally see cards like this
that just discard your cards in hand
just to get rid of something else. That
sounds like a bad trade-off actually.
You're always going negative one. But
this card gives you a lot of tempo if
you discard high cost cards and you can
afford to do that because of the
absolutely lovely progress day. A card
that has been finding its way into many
deck list that draws you four cards.
>> I'm glad you mentioned that because
progress day is a card that people have
been citing in or or bringing into
lists, sorry, into their main board to
try and just like out greed Draven where
you're like, well, Draven will draw
cards. I'll just draw more cards. It'll
be fine. Um, but then decks like set, I
wonder whether they can kind of go over
the top or underneath the Kaiser. And as
you said, you've kind of got that
reduction of units. You don't play quite
so many. So, I wonder whether set can
just bully around the game while Kais is
trying to be greedy. And Kai'Sa might
not be able to to to hold the
battlefields as well. Honestly, I will
not try to rule anyone out of this game,
but as a Kaiser player, I would have no
idea on how to tackle this situation
versus said the boss because already
that sea monkey is it's already hard to
remove. You know, your your units,
that's a watchful sentry. What's it
going to do?
>> Yeah, just sit there and and die and
give you a card basically is uh is what
is going to go in at least this watchful
sentry's uh future.
>> But also, I really like you were
mentioning the Draven match up for the
Kaiser. You know, I'm a passionate
Kaiser player, so I love just talking
general matchups.
>> Your deck for the weekend.
>> You have cut so many units from the deck
>> in most of these lists. Like there are
still some of these list that run Darius
that run the Noxus, but this deck
actually you're trying to outstaff the
Draven player, right? Draven will not
win combats against your units when you
just sit there and go progress day and
I'm going to draw so many cards. I'm
getting value after value after value
while you get no cards drawn. That's a
fade dragon. That is not a rune. That
happens quite a lot here actually.
>> Uh yeah, I will say the playmat is uh at
times the deck is in a different place.
So players have different um play styles
for whether you have your deck on the
right, on the left, and the way it's set
up is a little bit backwards at times.
There is a I believe a challenge I saw
in hand, which this is always risky when
you you play Kaiser out and don't get
the value from it yet. U because it's
just sitting there and you're like, "Oh,
please don't have uh a way to take it
out." There is um the blade attaching to
the sea monkey going to be able to take
out the washable sentry and then the
choice is do you want a challenge on the
back end of that? Do you want to to
punish this Kaiser? I feel like that is
uh
>> you do
>> normally a pretty good option. I think
you do. And also as the Kaiser player I
mean this is always the one I think you
cannot really play Kai'Sa on curve
against you know body decks because
you're going to get bodied by challenge
or strike down. All of those cards
really punish you for that and but you
also don't really want to accelerate it
because those are the match up those
really tough matchups. They are won by
your time warps.
>> Wo that is not is there zero units in
hand. I've seen bellow's breath retreat
time warp hexray piercing light. I think
there's no unit in hand.
>> Yeah. Well then especially I think it's
uh even more important that you actually
keep your Kaiser around. If you're
having cards like retreat, you really
want to have the option to play this
Kai'Sa again.
>> And I mean, I can see that in a bad
matchup, you want to play high risk,
right? You want to play high risk, high
reward that you're saying, "Okay, I'm
going to play my Kai'Sa because this is
a way I could possibly win the game. If
I start running away with points, I get
extra draws from conquers. But if your
opponent has it, your possibly bad
matchup just becomes a nightmare."
>> So, double falling star targeting the
sea monkey.
with perfect information,
you kind of feel like, well, if you can
keep the sea monkey alive, you are well
away with the game. But not worth
dramping too much more at this point.
>> We're actually not even taking the
I I really do feel that from the depth
of my heart that you could get confused
on those ones. Oh, we're actually going
to play the set brawler.
Interesting. Okay. Well, actually, we're
playing set the boss. So if we're even
tapped out and your opponent decides to
singularity this set, you're like, "Hey,
you're DM for two. I'm going to DM for
one." Actually, just protects
Battlefields buff units at Battlefields,
right? No,
>> no, it's everywhere.
>> Yeah, it's you can just uh get it take
it back to
>> Yeah, basically like that builtin uh
guardian angel effect kind of by by
spending the buff.
>> That is just great. And we're just
passing on the side of Kai'Sa. you're
not having progress. They only turn six
and you don't have units. That happens
>> as a set player. You know there is no
units in hand at this point because you
basically are seeing you've done
nothing. Okay, nothing passed from
Kaiser is such a rare play like so so
unbelievably rare to just see a Kaiser
do absolutely nothing especially with no
units on board. So that I think is going
to be a bit of a struggle. Uh they're
spending the buff this time around
before the conquer obviously. Well, as
part of the conquer is going to be able
to get a card and then you put the buff
back on from set's ability. You layer
them in that way so that you get that
card draw very effectively. Look at the
advantage already on the side of set. I
do really like the monastery. It's been
a it's been a battlefield that hasn't
seen too much play in Origins because
there were not too many great buff
decks, but now you have so many more
ways to buff your units with Warmox
armor or for example the sea monkey that
that's just a flexible drop.
>> There is a singularity singularity. You
have to do something on the side of
Physica, but is it going to help you
in in my mind now? You're just
protecting the set brawler, right? Oh,
>> spend a buff that way around in order to
to get the uh reduced cost.
>> You don't even care about your sea
monkey. I get that. What I also would
have liked to see, which is really cool
interaction is you protect your set
brawler and then next turn you just draw
another card from the monastery. You
just reconquer this. What's what's going
to happen with the next three runes that
Kai'Sa has and then you get another free
draw. But also, you can hold and just
avoid the damage with this. So, I I'm
fine with either play here, but this
matchup seems so tough.
>> I think the other way of doing it this
way around uh is you still have the buff
on set should a follow-up damage
spell come through. So, like we know
that that u physica has other damage
spells in hand. And I I guess that
that's the uh decision being made by our
Kaiser player of like, well,
>> do I want to force you to have it or is
it more important to keep my spell in
hand? Yeah, I think actually you would
lose with this line to a possible
falling star.
>> M okay.
>> So you would just get sniped out of the
backline. There was still three runes
open. So I really like your your
reasoning for why we would keep the the
buff.
>> Just to double check cuz the Arata
falling star because you select targets
at the beginning. Does it still work
that way? And it's cuz you're doing it
twice as separate instances of damage.
Does you still get
>> Oh, no. I meant if you would let your
set recall and protect it with your own
set, then you could get start and then
you use the set.
>> I misunderstood the uh the line we were
talking about. Yeah, that that makes
total sense. Uh to catch us up into the
game right now, Ruin Runner has been
played um with a pit rookie as well. And
there is a plundering power which is a
unit,
but it's not the biggest of units uh
really to compete against a battlefield
that has Ruin Runner and a set already
in play. It is an adorable unit though
and we love plundering porro. Piracy is
a universal language. I can't imagine
that it talks like this.
>> You're just trying to get all of the
flavor text so that when they try and
challenge us with it that uh we actually
know I'm going to fail that horribly
when that actually comes through.
>> That's that's going to be bad. But I
mean
>> I think we should pay a little more
attention to the rune runner that has
been played because what's Kaiser doing
against that?
>> Not a lot. There are there's not too
many ways of breaking that. I mean, you
essentially have to kind of thousand
tail watcher, I guess, right? Like on a
subsequent turn when a room runner is
there. But we're going to just
>> put all of the equipment on I was going
to say on the camel, but that is
illusion being played. Uh, which of
course does have weapon master.
>> Was that was just this brief beautiful
moment of physical laying back in his
chair and just sighing really deeply
knowing this matchup plays a little
almost impossible. Again, I don't want
to take anything away from this and
phenomenal players can get back from the
craziest of situations, but in theory,
this matchup is just so tough,
especially with main decked ruined
runners. It feels like the hardest
counter to Kaiser you could possibly
imagine if especially if you get a
Warmox armor on it. You also just get to
buff yourself all the time. I mean,
you're already buffed, so that's fine.
But now, a Fay Dragon is buffing
everything you have. Double checking the
exact wording on Fay Dragon was uh busy
for that one as
>> oh my goodness it's to up to four units
I think
>> you get a bunch of buffs and then when
you spend the buffs you're going to get
gold tokens so good job with the the
monastery you're able to spend it
>> tidy up a little bit of this board state
just to make sure everything is clear
with the buffs with the uh equipment
>> in goes the camel into the void gate
>> I feel like this is adding insult to
injury putting the rune runner one of
your best units into the void gate
because you know, there is not going to
be any damage that is going to be put on
it.
>> Yeah. And typically, you know, there are
copies of Bellow's Breath, but this
camel does not care. It is well
insulated uh
>> against any kind of uh AoE at this
point.
>> When was the last time you had like
eight cards in hand and none of these
cards did anything for you?
>> It's rare. It's actually extremely rare.
Uh I would say for a Kaiser where you've
>> unfortunately like losing that Kaiser
early uh I I think has been really
difficult. I like
>> not to not to hop on about it too much.
I think obviously it's a it's a play
that if it pays off goes really well for
you. Then you have the Kaiser protected
with the retreats and you don't delay
yourself. You drawn into it. You
continue to draw.
>> But like in this situation specifically
that challenge has absolutely shut this
game down in Set's favor. But I am a fan
of saying, hey, you sometimes it it
sounds a bit stupid, but you need to
play to your win conditions instead of
playing to survive. So I agree.
>> If you wait two more turns and one more
turn, you have the retreat that you can
use to save the Kaiser from a challenge.
>> That's great. You keep the Kaiser, you
have more units, you can play with
those. But the matchup is already so
bad.
>> I think it's a better have it situation.
Sure. You're saying to your opponent,
okay, I'm going to try to high roll as
much as possible that I have a chance in
this matchup
>> because if not, this is already looking
bad. And now the plundering power
actually gets a gold token. So, we are
starting the race for Physica going up
to two points while Driara is sitting
comfortably at five with a phenomenal
board state. Three more units in base.
>> Time will to get another point. So,
we'll we'll be able to at least get
another look at the deck uh like at the
top card of the deck, see if there's an
any kind of out. Um
>> I mean, Physical has to do something,
right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. You have to play to
your outs at this point. It is only game
one, so you have plenty of time left on
the round. Still like 50 minutes on this
one. So, uh not a problem to invest a
little bit of time and try and play this
out. And you have a lot of other answers
in your hand other than for the ruin
runner.
>> That is very interesting. We are playing
in this Kaiser deck list. We are on
seven fury runes in a time warp heavy
deck list. So,
>> and we know there are Watchers there as
well. Um,
>> I mean, there are a lot of damage spells
in hand that that do cost uh red. So,
there's a stupify. We getting another
look.
>> Also, most of these spells you can just
use by, you know, exhausting your own
Kaiser daughter of the void.
>> Singularity, however, actually needs
mind runes. So, it's it's a very
interesting choice. I wonder what the
reasoning is, but honestly, most of the
time having seven to five of rune colors
does not really make the biggest
difference.
>> Draw draw into draw again,
>> it doesn't find what they need. Okay, so
that was kind of like a desperation. You
can see as uh as Physica was shuffling
through the deck, there was a copy of of
Progress Day further down in the deck
that I I saw. And um yeah, not that that
was exactly the out. It was like where
are the units in the deck at that point?
>> It is a great card that can get you out
of sticky situations. That wasn't one of
them.
>> No, that was not one of them.
>> Yeah. I wonder whether seeing that
how how do you want to bring in like
sideboarding here for for set is it a
matchup that you'd think oh maybe col
week does start to to be a little better
cuz they're so unitike
that you do have units like a pit rookie
for instance or a first mate where
you're happy to trade them away but is
that mean just like having perfect
information on the game and and and like
being able to see deck list where we are
in a closed deck list situation
>> I think actually that most of the units
that your opponent has on the Kaiser
side, those units are not worth being
>> okay called the wheat. That's fair.
>> So you have these porros, you sometimes
have a pouty por, so you're avoiding
deflect, there is watchful sentry, there
is lecturing yord, and with all of
those, you're more than welcome to trade
them with one of the units of the set
because most set units, they're going to
be buffed eventually. They have a
potential guardian angel built-in effect
on set the boss and they're always going
to be at three might the least. So, I
think that call the week is
>> Yeah, that's true. Actually, looking at
the deck list again now, I I I can
absolutely see that that that reasoning
there. I I guess I'm I'm duped by uh the
the game we just watched where you drew
no units, so it felt like you were
extremely light on on Kaiser units.
>> But, I mean, even even if those units
go, the plundering porro didn't do a
lot. But I I think that actually the
card you want to sight in is definitely
the sabotage. There is instances where
Kai'Sa runs away with games against
opponents where it shouldn't run away
because if
>> if Dikara is bricking
>> Yeah.
>> then I think that Kai'Sa still offers
more than enough time to get back into
the game. Time Warp helps closing those
games out. So Time War is basically
cheesing your opponent out of the match.
>> And that's what you're looking for with
sabotage, I guess, is like the primary
card is like you want to hit them at
that time where they haven't been able
to play it yet, but they've probably got
it in hand from drawing a few times. Is
that what you're you're looking for in
that?
>> Yep. you're trying to have your opponent
break with the deck, which already does
not look like it's going to happen. And
then, oh wow, we're even mulligan away a
pit rookie. So, that looks like we do
have some drops. It's Dreaming Tree
versus the Arena's greatest. So, we're
going to make it even Oh, the arena's
greatest for Wait, no, the arena
greatest for Kaiser. No,
>> that is a
>> We'll find it out.
>> We'll We'll find out. We'll we will get
that updated and find out. Does look
like Arena's greatest was chosen for
Kaiser. So trying to just shortcut the
weight to eight points. There is the Sea
Monkey again.
>> It's such a great card. It doesn't read
like it's much of a of a game changer
for decks, but especially against some
with something like the Monastery in the
beginning, you get free draws. It's
fantastic. And also just being able to
play this on curve make it a little
better and just immediately threatening
this plundering porro with being three
might. It's so strong. It gives you so
much tempo and yeah the question is is
physica going to protect this porro a
lot? Are you going to for example hex
tech ray the sea monkey and would you
even protect it on the side of set
because I
>> electron y is that what you found off
the top? It was uh yeah okay it is. So
it was supervi onto the power in order
to draw off the dreaming tree plus a
superfy trigger. So getting uh this is
where Kaiser curves out really well. I
was I'm very hyped for Dra that he did
not put the top card of his deck into
his into his roof pile. I that would be
me if I was playing. I would just reveal
my entire deck one one turn at a time.
>> But I I was just saying like finding
that lecturering nod whether it was in
hand or whether it was run off the top
doesn't necessarily matter in this case.
But being able to go okay I play get up
to uh my second point with the parro
conquering and uh now
get myself another unit. But I was
looking at whether we we were able to
get up to four on the st, but no, with
that contest from the the sea monkey,
it's not really enough.
>> And now if you're looking closely at
this hand, what is there to do that
somehow plays around the wind conditions
offset the boss? Because you have a good
singularity here. It would provide so
much value playing against two mid-range
units, right? You have a six might or
you have a five might five might unit
and a three might unit. Singularity is
in a prime position to stop your
opponent from their game plan, but set
the boss has something to say about that
most of the time. Oh, we're actually
going to call to Goroi
>> as game number one using the uh sea
monkey as bait at this point to uh be
able to keep the set alive. Just spend
the buff, use the call to glory for free
and or at least without paying for the
cost. The buff was indeed the
replacement cost.
>> You jinxed it. You jinxed it. Sorry,
Leonard. You're like, it it's gone.
Well,
>> I think they're fine. I think at this
position, I wouldn't worry too much
about revealing a Dorance Blade.
>> Information is key in the game, though.
I will say uh Ruin Runner comes out. Um
again, we talked about how difficult a
card that is to deal with as uh we head
through. And just to to note, because of
Arena's greatest, Kaiser is on two
points um as a part of this game state.
Yeah.
>> So that is where you know set has been
able to get the one off Arena's greatest
hold conquer up to two hold up to three
through that singularity and now looking
to to kind of like stabilize up to to
put four and potentially more in future
turns
>> and the ruin runner is just asserting so
much pressure and this is also something
that I find very very interesting about
the riftbound meta actually because we
have seen the deck distribution right
there is 15% on the highest played deck
in the room which is Draven then there
is 12% Kai'Sa and so on and so forth.
So, this is already a very open
battlefield. Of course, this is
supported by the fact that people want
to go for these best off cards, which
are really cool metallic cards. They
want to be the best player of their
specific legend so they can get this
really sought after card. But also in
this metag game, the rogue decks, you
can you can put them in tier list as
much as you want. I think any tier three
deck has the potential to just beat
Draven. They the decks are so close to
each other in power, it's incredible.
And I would even argue that some of the
uh some of the changes that have been
made to Annie over the last few weeks,
we saw Annie of course like taking down
a regional. I I think people have put
Annie low discounted quite heavily uh
some of the other ways you can play
Annie. Yes. Okay. The I play a bunch of
spells and I kill things on your turn.
Uh Annie kind of dropped off. But Ferris
4runner as a as a big body and then
replacing itself with units did actually
kind of help people kind of beat around
the Draven. I I like this time one rune
left available when the Kaiis is on the
battlefield. So if you need to retreat,
you can make a hasty exit.
>> Big big fan of that. Also keep in mind
the arena's greatest is live. So we are
rapidly approaching the end game. We're
already at four. I think this rune
runner is going to be able to just
conquer the arena's greatest. Oh, we are
spending our buff. So I think we might
try to pet that buff back. All right.
>> Just to just to replace it. A little bit
of uh
>> you know you're playing the pit back
challenge. Yeah.
>> Yeah. challenge comes through. So here's
the moment. Is that one up going to be
able to save the Kaiser?
>> First we draw because we are in the
dreaming tree. That is also such a
luxurious situation.
>> Has gone to the graveyard. So nothing
available to keep it alive at this point
>> again and again. And I think Ruin Runner
is just going to ruin run into another
point and ruin the day of Physica. Even
though it's 4-1, you're still very
comfortable in this tournament, but it
is looking okay. We're not even going
into the arena.
>> Yes. So, I was going to say going to
fifth point. I was going to ask you like
is there even any point of doing that
because you know you're off you're off
tempo. You're off like the the 2 4 6 8
uh frequency. So, is it better to
actually cut through the number of
spells that Kaiser has? Cuz a few of
them are restricted to battlefield,
right? Like um uh a bunch of them are
just dealing damage to to something at a
battlefield. So, if you're not on a
battlefield, you can't lose a set. Next
turn you go to six turn after you to go
to eight. Is that kind of like the the
decision making there?
>> Yeah, definitely. I can see that by
retreating the set. What I'm curious
about is not pushing the ruin runner up
forward because I mean it was played
last turn, right? Because this card
cannot be targeted by but so um a little
bit that's kind of what I'm I'm I'm
asking is because you you would only be
going to five by moving the Ruin Runner
up. So you could lose Ruin Runner to
something like a thousand tail watcher
for instance that that is in hand. So my
my question was like is that
>> is that the the I guess correct way not
that there are specifically correct
plays but I would say that's just like
the safest play at that point. I I
really like playing around the
thousand tailed watcher, especially when
you're getting tapped out. Even though
in the arena's greatest match, you know,
going to five points is super valuable
because you're then again two points
away from winning. So, a double conquer.
But I I think you're absolutely right.
If you manage to then conquer those
points, you're so far ahead when you
actually can leave some runes up,
>> I think you're in a much better
situation. Sometimes I I just like to
win those games fast, right? It's not
always necessarily the best play. Now
you're seeing that this was absolutely
the right choice.
>> Watch into base.
>> Even in the tough games, even in the
games that you're so far ahead as
Triricara, he just keeps his calm and
knows, hey, I I still need to play this
match up perfectly because otherwise I'm
I might be getting cheesed.
>> Yeah, with I'm pretty sure perfect
information.
Oh, Bellow's breath is in hand. That is
something also piercing light is
available. So that will
look to deal the final pass of damage
>> nice
>> to the back line to potentially that
set.
>> Yep. The set the boss is just going to
protect
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Otherwise, there could have always been
the chance for another call to glory.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> But uh
>> here comes a bellow's breath and of
course that uh the minus three from
Watcher will persist through the set
interaction. I I think that's what the
players are talking about here because
something something to know when set's
um legend ability kicks in set doesn't
leave the battlefield, right? So you
don't reset the minus that has come
through already. So it will the minus
three persists through
>> and so more damage on top of it will
deal with the set uh once again.
>> Yeah, that's maybe something uh very
interesting to note there. It's a good
matchup dollar knowledge there and I
think physica is just trying to take
full advantage of that even though you
know both are at four points and the
next turn I can already promise you
being completely exhausted.
>> That's looking like a double conquer on
the side of Draara and then I mean
there's still decent amount of play
actually for physica in this one just
with the watcher.
I guess this is the downside of of
actually bringing that set back that we
were talking about. Um is
the bellow's breath does have more
targets and even though you can't finish
off the rune runner, there's you know
questions to be said of like is there a
way to play around it but in this
situation you get the set and the pit
rookie uh combined. I'm pretty sure
that's what the team spotters at the
table and the judge team are working
through.
>> You can't get the set and the pit rookie
because you need to target one unit at
the battlefield first. So that's
Bellow's breath forward. We got rid of
the piercing light already.
>> Yeah, the bellow.
>> Yes. So that I think they're just
walking through the sequence of watcher
was played. Then I played the uh
piercing light that deals the first bits
of damage, gets through the set the
first time, then a bellow's breath
afterwards because of the minus three.
Now I think we can just bring it back to
us briefly until the situation is
settled. That has already been in the
past. So I think we're going to be uh
good in a while. But this is a a very
interesting scenario and I'm quite
curious to see the ruling in the end
there. So, uh it's going to be
interesting to find out the resolution.
>> Yeah, I think that uh speaks to
something that I've I've felt, you know,
coming from different games and and
seeing the the power of certain
different abilities and mechanics in the
game. For me, minusing and plusing might
feels incredibly strong compared to
damage being dealt uh in a turn because
it persists most of the time through to
the end of the turn. A lot of them will
read like give minus three until the end
of the turn.
>> It just means that whatever else happens
that minus three is staying there.
>> Uh whereas damage, you know, there's a
few points in the game you heal up.
Yeah. So, this is one of those examples
of where you can really use that
persistent minus three is actually kind
of minus
>> six over two different instances on set
where heals back up and then it's all
fine. It
>> it's a lot to to work against and those
nifty small spells. They can really
really deal some damage together with
the thousand tailed watcher. We already
got it figured out here. Now, let's see
what is going to happen there. So, we
have rewinded a little bit. So, no
piercing light has been activated.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm interested to know where
we've uh ended up in this situation.
>> Same honestly.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm looking at what the
resolution was. It looks like perhaps
we've
>> rewound
a watcher being played.
>> Yeah, we're playing the turn again.
Piercing Light is going to be used.
>> Kai'Sa is going to be exhausted. The
lecturing yord is targeting the set. And
now actually Draara gets to okay protect
the set here.
I think he's already possibly recycled
the rune before because otherwise he
would still have to do that now cuz
that's the cost for a set, right? So you
have to pay one power.
>> The judges are working with the players.
As we've said, uh just to clarify, um
this game is uh did happen a little
while ago. So, as we cast this, there's
nothing that we can actually do to
influence the game. Um, so we're our
judges have been helping through this,
but just for for those of you I know
that um kind of love chatting about
like, oh, why didn't you tell them this?
I'm like, well, this this happened in
time, and I would have to actually be a
time traveler.
>> Time war, make it a little bit
different.
>> Yeah, I I I think I think the original
read is is is correct, but I'm I'm
looking forward to seeing where this
actually ends up. I think the way it was
played out the first time, I believe, is
correct because there also there also
wasn't anything from from set. Uh no
runes available, so there's not like you
can punch first and try and play through
it. Um I'm looking at what other effects
were available, but I I'm pretty sure
set is doomed for this one.
>> At max a cold to glory would be that
could be played out because played at a
zero energy cost if you have a buff
unit. But I mean, we spend the buff, I
think. So that's that's that. Now we're
so far down the hole. I'm trying to
remember whether Call to Glory is action
speed or reaction speed.
>> Should be reaction speed.
>> Okay, it is.
>> We've seen this multiple times on a
singularity.
>> Okay, cool. So, uh at this you're right.
You are absolutely right in this
matchup. Uh so we've come to a state
where it does look like that was in fact
the resolution is the set has died. Uh
the pit rookie has died and now the rune
runner moves to the battlefield um and
conquers. And we also still have the fay
dragon backing up there. The rune runner
is at solid. Wait, that was eight. Eight
might, I think. So, so far we are
beating the watcher. So, we go up to a
conqueror of uh five.
>> But you know what? You don't beat
>> second watcher.
>> Yeah.
And that always feels good when you got
one watcher on the board and you're
like, "Yeah, but what if I do it again?
>> What if I give you minus three again?"
>> It's it's really really strong. Thousand
tilts watcher is such a huge card.
We've just smoke screens come to the
front and I'm like you can't smoke
screen the ruin runner. The camel cares
not for smoke at this point.
>> You can try but also like just going in
with the rune runner and not with the
fade dragon or I think we just played
the fade dragon this turn.
>> Yes. Yeah, I think so.
>> The one where it was ready was in the
last game.
>> So we are setting up a possible double
conquer turn being at five
points, five victory points and we are
playing in the arena's greatest just to
keep that in mind. So just two away
actually. Kaiser is doing really really
well in this matchup so far.
>> So it's going to be ponder watchful
sentry this time has a lot more units to
play with. That's like a big difference
compared to game one where uh game one
was like no units I've got nothing. I
can't play around anything. This is like
oh cool I'll play a watcher early. I'll
move to a battlefield. That'll be fine.
And that smoke screen what it will deal
with is the fade dragon as it comes
aggressive into the battlefield
potentially this turn.
>> That is true. I think that Dara just has
it figured out already. just immediately
going in floating one rune then putting
the Doran's blade under the fade dragon
that is already 10 might. This is
looking strong 10 might but this is a
card that can be reacted to
smokeokescreen immediately used. We knew
it was in hand. Uh obviously Dara just
kind of had to wonder and and
potentially play to out. Smokecreen
resolves. Now what is the answer from
Dara? That is going to be an orange.
Oh, challenge challenge.
>> I really like that as an action speed.
Ruin runner on eight might can't be
targeted for any kind of ability. So,
that is going to be a rough one. Can you
deal with this somehow? Can you boost up
your own thousand tailed Watcher?
>> I'm trying to think of what outs are
available cuz so much of the damage so
many of the damage spells of course
target. We've seen one Bella's breath
used already that wouldn't get it done
anyway. Two singularities, a thousand
tail watch trying to get excited. None
of which help neither in this situation
or in any future situation in dealing
with the ruin runner on the battlefield.
>> And then now we're conquering. That
would be the seventh point. Arena's
greatest in effect. So you would win the
game by Oh, wait. Arena's greatest
at the beginning. So we're still going
to eight uh in this situation. No, it's
it's all good. But we are still at what
you could effectively call game point by
being at six. Uh going to eight. So, uh,
the math has now mathed for set where
it's like, I'm holding both
battlefields. I got big units and you
can't do much about it. Um, that fade
dragon is going to get singularity on
the next turn, I would assume.
>> I'm a little bit embarrassed that I kept
confusing this with climb in reverse.
>> Okay. So, it's going to be a get excited
discarding
singularity.
>> Yeah. Okay. To with a smoke screen still
in effect, we'll be able to take it out.
Uh, so makes sense. Get excited is just
an easy way of singularitying one unit
by discarding it.
>> Two needs to
>> set just again gets so much value out of
everything. It's it's really incredible
what the deck can do.
>> But uh because of that buff uh fade
dragon doesn't actually die. It just
>> yeah ends up coming back.
>> Yeah, it just gets recalled because of
set the boss. So that is huge.
Singularity did not really get a lot.
>> Okay. Signature spell comes out. uh I
believe moves fade dragon up. Does that
take us to to eight at this point?
>> No, we still need to get the seventh
point because the pressure got killed by
the challenge on the rune runner and
then get excited was played on player
priority during the combat.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> The combat that wasn't really existing
and then you got rid of the fade dragon
which was I believe at four might.
>> Right. Thank you. Um now I'm the one
that's embarrassed.
>> I'm way ahead myself. I'm I'm way way
ahead of myself at this point,
>> but we are going. It was a It was a
complicated game state. So, we are at
seven points. This is game point. I
mean, we haven't had any kind of answers
for the Ruin Runner whatsoever so far.
>> Yeah. And still none. I mean, it's it's
the watcher in hand, but that's why the
rune run has come back uh come back to
base. Singularity
in hand. There is a Watcher. So,
Singularity not going to be an option
from here. But watcher will uh minus the
Fay Dragon and the Ruin Runner. So I
guess that is really Wait, I thought
Ruin Runner came back. Am I mistaken? I
must be mistaken. I I thought I saw
Dricara pull it back to base cuz
otherwise it leaves it somewhat
vulnerable here.
>> I think he just wants to hold with one
unit.
>> You have the Fay Dragon and you have the
Ruin Runner. They You are at seven. So
next point you're going to win and your
opponent is going to have a really tough
time dealing with both of those. Also,
you can just spend a buff and then
recall it
>> if you want. So,
>> you can offer your opponent the hey, you
need to conquer both battlefields,
otherwise I'm just going to win on
default. And if you conquer and if you
actually get rid of these powerful units
that I have here, well, too bad. I'm
just getting that back anyways. But
we're getting really low on on runes.
We're getting another gold token because
of the equipment.
Okay. And that's a falling star on the
Fay Dragon, but Fay Dragon is so
>> so six plus also the the watcher gives
so effectively minus 9 compared to where
it would be or at least minus three with
six points of damage. So, we'll be able
to trade with Aparo. Watchful sentry
going to take everybody up to seven in
this game. Um, so now we're just looking
for who can conquer both battlefields
first cuz a hold on the Watcher would do
it. But obviously now untapping with the
the ruin runner.
>> I mean, you just need to get rid of a
watchful sentry as well if you're taking
out that watcher. But that is all
already a tough ask at four runes with
nothing else. Do you have it in you? Do
you have another top deck that is going
to help you win that game? No. Packs up
the cards, looks at the top deck, and
scoops. Actually, Kaiser pulled this one
completely out of their sleeve.
Yes. Uh indeed. I think that um very
significant like turn where the the set
ends up dying to the Watcher. I think
the thousand tail watch are really
turning these games uh for for the
Kaiser. I think following that the the
the little harder to stabilize from
there off that second watcher.
>> Yeah, it is the thousand tails both
thousand tila watcher they really turned
those this game around. They actually
also needed both. So that's very
important where you're seeing a
sideboard from physica and there's
thermmo beam. Thermo beam is a really
nice card against equipment heavy decks.
However, I do not think that the set
doesn't work without the equipments like
it's it's Doran's blade, it's Warmox
armor. I think even if if your opponent
takes an entire turn to just thermmo
beam them, I think you're actually kind
of okay.
>> Yeah, again we see the main deck here
for Physik.
>> That uh worked a whole lot better in in
game two. Uh this time actually drawing
into units. Doesn't doesn't run run
without units in a in our second round.
But uh we'll see as we head into game
three
what our set player Driara can do.
>> All right.
>> Trying to think did we see the sideboard
cards?
>> I don't think we saw
>> I don't think we saw a sabotage
>> any of those. Yeah, I think hidden blade
is actually worth a sight in.
>> Okay,
>> because if you're I don't even think you
need to hide it, but if you want to hide
it, it can get rid of a thousand tailed
watcher. And as we have seen before,
Physika needs that push with the
thousand tail watcher and the body. It's
actually incredibly relevant there
because otherwise it's getting hard to
conquer those ruined runners feels
again. We're going to see I think the
sunken temple is going to be the last
battlefield we're going to play. And the
warriors the arena was actually from
physica. So Kaiso was actually playing
the racing the arena's greatest. Yeah, I
think we saw, you know, a lot of that in
in Origins, just saying, "Hey, I'm going
to get to eight as quick as possible."
>> I don't think that the game one
battlefields are correct, though. I'm
very sure that the monastery was
actually played by set at the void gate
was played by
>> Kaisa. Ah, okay. I get that. Yeah, that
that would make sense with uh with how
it was. But uh as we head into game
three, it's Obelisk and Sunken Temple as
already mentioned. So, uh,
I'm quite curious to see how much the
set the boss gets out of the obelisk. I
mean, we have seen that the deck D ramps
quite a bit. So, it wouldn't probably
hurt to get some of those cards out. Ah,
and we can immediat That's why Sea
Monkey is so great, right? Even if your
opponent lets you go first with the
Obisk of Power, you can get full value
out of this card. It's such a nice three
drop. I mean, it's it's a vanilla
basically, but in some situations,
especially also with a sunken temple or
a monastery, you can still get some
extra cards out of the buff because you
can spend the buff or in the case of
sunken temple, it's a little easier to
you for you with a dorance blade or a
bone shiver or something to get to
mighty status.
>> Yeah, there is a bone shiver uh comes
in. Uh physica, you got one of these
coming in through the door for the promo
card. just wants to double check the uh
the wording on it uh just to make sure
that we're all understanding. So when I
conquer channel one rune exhausted so uh
it does allow you to to kind of get that
ramp up for later turns. So the heavy
price that you're paying you're already
getting immediately refunded. Then you
also of course spend one more energy for
the sunken temple to draw one extra
card. And I wonder if now as you know
you've already invested one energy and
one power into the bone shiver. You've
already it's quite the heavy equipment
cost.
>> Yeah.
>> To equip it.
>> I wonder if there is being if removal is
being used now from the Kaiser
>> to actually just protect the sea monkey
because you can easily conquer next turn
again.
>> Oh, it's happening. It is happening.
This is the first time we're getting a
full look at the hand. That is a time
warp in hand. And I can tell you that
there is a sabotage in hand across the
table, which is exactly kind of like
that sideboard tech we were talking
about bringing in. Obviously, sabotage
is not a card that anybody is a stranger
to, but
>> it's always kind of like a rock paper
scissors of like, have you got the card
that I'm looking for or do I have to
take a secondary target? But Dicara is
going to find out when the sabotage is
played
>> that that time war is available to take
away.
>> Physical really wants to at this point
play with the Kaiser for a little bit.
Just really really tries to develop the
Kaiser so regularly in these games.
Could have also been a progress day turn
especially if you're playing versus
cards like sabotage. Progress day is so
valuable. Even though I I mean the thing
is you would like to use progress day
after a sabotage but then again there's
a high chance you just get the progress
day sniped out of your hand.
>> And I think one of the other reasons
Dara is like looking at things wants to
have the one rune still available to you
know threaten and represent punch first
uh wants to develop the board for rune
runner and doesn't have to sabotage on
the last turn because you knew physica
wasn't going to
>> there was zero chance of a time war
happening so you can do it on the next
turn. And so that's kind of like,
>> you know, skating the line, the fine
line of like right in the turn before
you can do it, I'm going to try and take
it out of your hand.
>> Agreed. That's that's true. Interesting.
Physica is going for a conquer here with
the plundering poro instead of the
Kaiser. So we are deciding not to get
the draw, but we're deciding that we
would rather want to have gold tokens. I
agree that gold tokens are very
valuable. There is probably also some
reasonings why we wouldn't want the
Kaiser at the battlefield. I think at
this point
he has had so many
>> it was there from the previous turn. Uh
so at this point I think
>> makes sense.
>> Yeah, it's just a progress day. Draw a
bunch of cards.
>> Yeah, I was going to say it can't break
through on the other battlefield for
now. So just draw a bunch of cards. And
the greatest thing about having sabotage
in hand is when your opponent says,
"Yeah, I'll just stack my hand with with
more chances of me drawing a time warp."
I mean, yeah, of course, you get other
options, but the likelihood that it's in
hand is now like the highest point of
the game up until now.
>> Thing is, also, if you're playing
sabotage now, Yeah.
>> isn't the chance that you're seeing too
many cards, is it?
>> That is true. It's like a kid in a candy
store. You're like, which one do I take?
>> We already only have 20 minutes left,
which is, I think, quite good for a game
three. But now looking at 10 cards in
hand, sabotage is going to give me so
many options to take away a card.
>> You're like, please don't take this time
off. Please don't do it. It doesn't even
show the whole deck, like the whole
hand. Oh, there we go. I found it. Uh,
it's right there at the back. Um,
>> and now I think Drakara is going to have
to first take some notes as well because
of course note takingaking is allowed in
Riftbound, and you do not want to forget
any of those.
>> I hope your short hand is good to to
write this quick. So, you know, a smoke
screen. Okay, I'll do that one. An R for
retreat. Okay. Watchful sentry, a W.
>> So, of course, time warp is a win
condition. And it's a prime target for
sabotage as always, but is there a
chance that you're also taking other
cuts? There's currently, I don't think,
anything that really combos off with the
thousand tailed watcher
>> cuz you're you're also not wor you're
not worrying so much about singularity.
I mean, you could There we go. Answers
our question for us. If that wasn't a
ruin runner and was something else, I
think there's an argument for
singularity, but time warp is like being
able to take that out of hand is so
important, right?
>> I would say the same thing. Oh, almost
took the obus battlefield back.
>> Honestly, that's that's really stopping
your opponent from going aggressive. So,
I kind of dig it.
>> We're taking the warmarks onto the ruin
runner, conquering, and then we are
immediately getting the buff for the
ruin runner. So, we get more might
already at seven. You know that your
opponent can accelerate.
We know that your opponent can
accelerate a good old thousand tailed
Watcher immediately in the next turn.
But I think this time around Dryara
might be prepared.
>> We uh invested heavily in camels um for
for the ruin runner
>> catch me if you can is the the flavor
text on that.
>> So remember
>> production are going to try and get us
with uh flavor text at some point. That
one I'm hoping I'm going to remember.
>> Oh, we got it. Definitely. I mean it's
it's very iconic. So I think thousand
tilt watch turn. How many runes are we?
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. So while Thousand
Tail Watcher is known to be a great push
on the opposing turn, even if you are at
so many runes, even if you're at 12
runes, it's really hard to go over a
rune runner with some backup. I mean,
yes, there is only one rune left open,
but we know how much might this deck can
cheat out basically. And this is one of
the times where the the changes to the
Kaiser deck from the Draven
uh
sorry from the um the Darius setup from
Origins kind of hurts because you don't
have cards like Cleave. You're not
running blood rush. So your direct
damage spells really don't help you
against Ruin Runner. So you're relying
on being able to go over the top of a
Ruin Runner and your opponent has one
orange rune available. And I mean the
fact
you have one rune available that's punch
first at all times. You have to be
afraid of it. So you can never go in and
just take that rune runner.
>> And there's another one. There's call to
glory as well. So yeah, exactly.
>> Get up to eight might here because your
sea monkey is buffed. Keeps another
still keeps a buff. So this this buff is
so valuable. And now physic I think
saying hey well you got to you better
have it. just seeing them tap both and
uh pull the orange runes to the side cuz
there's only one card right now that is
one power.
>> I mean, Physica hasn't seen the cards
before. He has not really seen the card
before. And also, oh, there's of course
always retreat. You can't get it this
turn. You might as well try again.
>> Yeah. So, of course, one energy, two
power. There's a retreat coming through.
Go on the watcher. Take that back.
>> I mean, everyone knew it was there,
right?
the conquer
from the ruin runner
card draw as well. Actually, uh yeah,
are we going for draw? Are we going for
a gold token with the plundering poro or
the Kaiso? This time around the the card
wasn't there already, right? I'm not I'm
not
>> No, no, no. Correct. Yeah, this time
around the Kaiser going would would get
that card draw for the turn. Is going to
be the power this time going in. uh will
get the gold. I mean, I'm trying to
remember now. I'm trying to think I
should have noted down the entire hand
that Kai'Sa had to remember whether
there was a second retreat.
>> So, we had Singularity. Oh, I don't know
if it was a second retreat. All right.
>> Okay. Okay. That that would explain why
you're not going in with the Kaiser cuz
you want try and save that.
>> But, I mean, at some point, you got to
get some value out of the Kaiser, right?
You want to find those draws. And so
far, I think Physica has paid a lot of
attention to playing out the Kai'Sa in
the first two games. Lost the Kai'Sa
immediately because it was played
perhaps too recklessly.
>> But this game, it was played. It's
living and it's not doing anything. It's
a true survivor that that it is, but
it's not really doing anything else.
>> Also, there's still a lot of pressure.
All of those mighty units on the side of
Draara looking to basically just punch
down on that Kaiser. And Kai'Sa is just
looking confu confused. The challenge
from the Ruin Runner onto the Kaiser.
That is nasty. I'm quite curious if
challenging the Thousand Tailed Watcher
in the next turn would have helped a
little bit more, but we're stupifying a
lot.
>> Still minus three on challenge, right?
When you challenge on the Watcher,
right, when the Watcher comes in, you're
still struggling from that one. Um,
>> agree.
>> There goes the Kaiser. Not a survivor
anymore.
>> Yeah. Um, I won't break into Destiny's
Child songs as we're uh as we're
watching the game. I don't want to get
DMCA on the stream. Um,
>> first mate protecting the sea monkey.
Also, not only protecting the sea
monkey, but also getting it out of the
sunken temple so that you can conquer it
next turn again. And as you do not have
the fallen star.
No, not the fallen star, the skyfall.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> Your conquer effects are not your hold
effects. Though this time around, you
really need to conquer the sunken temple
multiple times to draw cards. So,
perfect execution here. First mate,
getting sea monkey out of the danger
zone and ready to conquer it again next
turn to get a possible next draw. We
also still have the ruin runner in the
other battlefield, the obelisk of power.
There is one rune left.
>> Running it again. Running it back. One
rune this time is no, I've not got it
again.
And I think that's just fine because you
know what? We have set. I I almost
forgot about the ability of set the boss
because it hasn't been used this game at
all.
>> Never forget about set. It makes it so
difficult to trade into. And you know,
here is here's the time where like now
watch on a battlefield and depending on
whether they've drawn into another
retreat. Ooh, falling star is going to
take out the units that can be targeted
at least.
>> It's a really nice play. I mean you
needed the help of the watcher there
again but I like how physica is playing
his talailed watchers just getting the
maximum amount of value out of that card
but then again you are almost fully
exhausted on your runes next turn there
is going to be two ruin runners that are
looking to ruin your day and there's
also going to be a third card in hand
for dry carara might as well go for a
fifth card
>> another watcher I mean I I know we had
one come with retreat there is a retreat
in hand as well for Physica. So,
actually there there's there's utility
to look and see if you can take this
back. But being on six points for
Driara, I think might be the hill that's
too steep to overcome for Physica at
this point.
>> Yeah, it's going to be tough especially
because that's such an easy conquer
right there for a rune runner on the
sunken temple is going to get you a
draw. Then you just need to try and hold
there. Yeah, but I think that Dicara
with this little runes left available
for Physika is going to try and push in
the next turn because otherwise if there
is another Thousand Tailed Watcher, it
is going to be tough.
We're not choosing to take out the Sea
Monkey. Sea Monkey was at minus three,
so it was at three, right?
That was the initial
read on it, but then uh it looked like
as Drakara took them to take him to the
graveyard, there was some kind of
discussion about where there was maybe
additional might coming from. Oh, and
now you got buffed units, so you're able
to uh go just over the top of it. Uh
this should just be the end of the game,
right?
>> Yeah. Fade dragon, how are you going to
boost up your good old Yeah. Watcher,
you're already at seven here.
>> Can't target Ruin Runner at this point.
I'm trying to think of any outs because
again, there's there's very little ways
of buffing your units from this
situation. So, that is going to be a
traded
exchange there. The rune runner that was
hiding is going to be able to conquer.
And then it's just down to the cards in
hand to see whether they can get through
the sea monkey. And I don't know that
whether there's enough.
>> Sea monkey can be targeted. Two runes
are left open, but that is the fist
bump. Physica forfeits that match as
there is the eighth point reach for
Draara.
>> What a match. Honestly, really, really
well played from our set the boss.
>> Yeah, and I I think that that really is
a an exercise in looking at how
especially in Origins, people thought
the matchup was like potentially favored
for set in the way that the the game
plays out. I know that people were
discussing the erat changes to falling
star and a cathonian rain and how that
actually affects things with regards to
like the set uh passive from the legend
and and we kind of saw it a little bit
in in play there with the multiple
spells.
>> Um not so much of prevalence in in this
match. We didn't see in a cathon rain
but important enough to say our set
player is going to advance with another
win from our fifth round.
>> And we've just seen how impressive the
card rune is. It is a card that does not
have a lot of text. This card basically
just has one sentence and that is I am
unargetable by basically anything spells
or abilities. And some decks really
really struggle with that. And that begs
the question, you know, I was saying
earlier, okay, Fiorup was my pick to win
the event, but I was kind of getting
convinced more up to this up to this and
I thought maybe Kai'Sa is actually the
best deck in the room. However, does
Kaiser have a really really tough time
against basically any body deck, any
orange deck that can play rune runner?
Because if you're not playing a main
deck run, you at least play some in the
side, right?
>> Yeah, exactly. And I I think the Aurelia
matchup might also be another one that
is quite tricky. But speaking of
matchups, we want to go into our second
one. We're going to head right in to
another uh unique, I would say, matchup
that we haven't seen before. uh today as
we are diving into game three.
I believe it's between Renata Glass and
Ari
>> which uh is not two two matchups I was
expecting to see too much of today. This
is the Renata Glast sideboard. Uh so
there's time warp in the sideboard.
There's unchecked power uh and a few
other cards there.
>> That is really cool. If you control
gear, it comes in ready
>> which is really strong especially in a
deck like Renata Glast. You know, Rinata
has some sort of I want to say combo
ability. You have ways of cheating out
some victory points if you're just
looking at this chosen champion unit.
You can pay one energy and four power
cost for the mind power and then you're
going to get a point if Renato Glusk is
at a battlefield. So, every card that
can just get in ready, get a cheeky
point can help you to win games from
impossible positions. That is really,
really cool about the deck. you're
playing time warps and if you're doing
it right, I think you can score up to
five points in one turn.
>> That is insane. We'll see whether it
happens. Um
>> this Ahri player sideboard. Uh yeah, I
mean I think you're kind of forced to
play things like um disarming rake uh
for gear, like attacking gear. You've
got things like progress day in order to
draw more and then just some matchups
where you need charm a little more uh
just to be able to control the board.
This is kind of what I would expect from
an AI build. Uh, right now I actually
retuned my Ahri deck to just see what uh
was playable or not in in Spirit Forge.
I'm a big fan of Blitzcrank in AR. I
don't know how how competitively good it
is, but I think it causes so much
disruption to the game where you start
playing it to battlefields, pull things
across, you have sonasers there to
untap. Uh, anytime you can end a turn
and be like, "Yeah, I'll just untap four
battle uh four four."
>> It's so huge. Yeah, it is so much
advantage. You're getting so much tempo
and you're also playing some battlefield
that help you win games if you're
holding. However, Renata Glask also
enjoys holding on battlefield. So, if
you're playing something like the Grove
or on the paper tree, paper tree
channels one rune exhausted, I believe,
and the Keeper Grove is the name, I
believe, is going to draw you a card
when you hold here. So, that's that's a
fight to the death, right? If both
players want to hold a specific
battlefield, their strategy is holding
fields.
>> Yeah, Grover the God Willow. Yeah,
>> almost. Yeah, almost got it's a long old
name on that one. We'll get Vile Moors.
Oh, it is Vile Moores. Okay, cool. So,
uh
interesting. Vile Moors. I'm trying to
think of how you want to force people to
play around on on vile moors on this
one. That is already a fantastic draw on
the turn. If you are going second, you
have the card shop and naturally
malight gnus, which I assume that the
gnus is a German word for enjoyment.
>> Mhm. Malight enjoyer.
>> Malight enjoyer naturally declines the
gold gear token from the card shop.
>> Don't want the gold. I don't want to
give you another one. I don't need to do
that. That sounds like a terrible idea
against Ronald Glask who is just happy
to get to the late game with a stack of
gold. Yeah, another glass has multiple
ways of winning games with uh different
cards and also on forge god is a card
that is being played for every gear you
have. It gates one might that is really
strong. It helps you hold on to
battlefields but also the good oh we are
already starting to stack in this
battlefield.
>> It it feels like we're we're like doing
the like stocks holding like a hold hold
at all times. So, we are going to just
push in the Raven Bloom Student. And
Card Shop is immediately fighting,
immediately challenging the battlefield.
And now says, "Okay, well, all right.
I'm just trading off with your
plundering Porro while we're going
through a little bit of disruption here.
It's going to just be next turn." Oh,
that was a charm actually being played.
>> Okay. Yeah, that makes sense.
>> But I mean, the charm that was basically
a two for one trade. Oh, wages of pain
onto the Raven Bloom student. If you
respond to this, you're only going to
get up to three might with Raven Bloom
student. So, the old is denied a Raven
Bloom student to challenge it. We
haven't seen Raven Bloom Student so much
in Spirit Forge for now, but uh in this
game, they're coming flying.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh we are back into the the
live action here. Jumping through. I I
say live just as a reminder, we are
behind time a little bit as the uh the
rounds are playing out ahead and we have
some buffer time in between. Um, one
thing I wanted to bring up that was
interesting. I would be interested to
know whether Malight Goodness's uh
chosen champion has been swapped out
here because we've got Ahri Inquisitive
from the champion zone, which has this
been played. I I know a lot of Ahri
players were trying to make Ahri
alluring
>> work, which is when you hold, you score
a point. But I've always found it really
difficult to ever get those holds
through. It's so hard to keep her on a
battlefield.
>> This newer approach to the AR deck is
more mid-rangey. So this is actually the
perfect card. It's like a very tame
thousand tailed watcher because it only
has nine tails, right?
>> But you're still when you're attacking,
you choose an enemy unit and it gets
minus two might which is already huge
and it gives you a lot of tempo for a
three drop.
>> Yeah, that's very true. Uh and then that
stacks of course with um Ari Ninetailed
Fox the uh minus one that comes through
as well when uh when defending or pretty
much that uh when when people attack a
battlefield, they get that minus one. So
it ends up being minus three on that
particular unit. I love the ninetailed
to,000 tailed uh pun. I I will I will
give you I will give you the pause for
that.
>> They must have met somewhere right in
Router. Has to be reason. Yeah, they
they have different amounts of tails.
But let's actually see how Magad is
going to advance the board state here
with the Reinata glass deck. The Cam
Baroness. And honestly, Camparanus
really I think when I read it first I
was rather unimpressed with the card
with the legend
>> because oh we're playing the relleta
glass mastermind into the battlefield
already. We're not using our gold gear
tokens. We are dramping us. We're
recycling some runes in this scenario.
That is interesting. So we are valuing
the gold gear tokens.
And oh I thought we just used the score
one point effect but no that is that is
not happening. We're just reading.
>> No, no, just uh just yeah, arranging the
runes for Ronaldo to be played. I mean,
that's the thing is when Ranata gets
close to winning, we were talking about
this a little bit that you start getting
more value from the gold tokens.
>> Yes, exactly. When you're getting closer
to winning, when you're three points
within victory score range, your gold
tokens actually not only give you power,
but they also give you one energy. And
that is one of the only ways in
Riftbound, if not the only way, to
actually go over 12 energy in a turn.
And that gives you some crazy
shenanigans with cards like time warp.
>> So you can actually play time warp, then
play multiple other cards on the same
turn. But also, there's another way to
play with more cards at the same turn in
the Renata Glass deck, and that is
something that is incredibly cool. A
card that I have seen the last time in
Origins, actually in Victor decks, is
the Echo from Origins. Yeah, I saw a
couple decks running Ekko. So, it's one
of the cards that when it has a it has a
deathnell effect essentially that
deathnell
>> radiol oversightly.
So, this is this is a game-winning play
that you're setting up over multiple
maybe just two turns where you play the
echo in your base and you're looking at
your opponent's battlefields and you're
like, I know just that they are going to
leave their units there because if they
just retreat, I'm going to go in there
and time war and get double the points,
which might win me the game and make all
my cards better. But if they stay in
those battlefields, I'm going to echo.
I'm going to play all my cards as many
as I want, then try to go into
battlefield. Of course, my Echo is going
to die. Ideally, I'm going to take some
units with me or the Ekko is going to
take some units with him. And then you
get all your runes back. You can play a
good old time warp with so many cards
set up with an Renata glass perhaps
setup and then you can just go for many
extra points. It's phenomenal.
>> It is uh a very interesting line as we
see our Inquisitive going over to
Vmore's layer. So, I mean, you're always
going to want it to give that minus two.
If you're at home and you're thinking
about, hey, what's a what's an
interesting fun deck to build for
multiplayer or free-for-all, Ronald
Glask jam a Heimerdinger or two into
there, uh, and himinger can start
tapping for the ability and doesn't even
need the the battlefield restrictions.
So, there is a tell watcher we can get
back to actual competitive 1 v one.
Doesn't really matter about the minus
three at this point. It's watcher in
base like untap like past turn. So, can
go through to Ronald Glask's turn.
>> We're holding. We're getting a gold.
We're drawing another card for Grove of
the God Willow. So that is absolutely
massive for Renata Glask. And another
thing you can do with the time warp, if
you're actually having your Renata Glass
Mastermind on one battlefield and your
opponent, as in this scenario, is
starting to stack on top of the other
battlefield, right?
>> You can just go, you know, time warp,
crash in Echo, use Renata Glass ability
to get a point, and then time warp, get
another point in the next turn while
you're holding as well. stupify
singularity to clear both Ahri and what
count the runes. Can we can we get to
seven? Can we get there?
>> I think we can.
>> Question is, do you start using your
gold tokens?
>> Uh yeah, good question. You know what?
We don't see Renato Glass often enough
for me to know a yes or no answer to
that question. Instinctively, I feel
like normally it's yes, but maybe you're
like, "Hey, rich getting richer. We're
going to we're going to stay with the
gold and be okay recycling two.
>> Split the difference. One gold, one
rune.
>> Usually I would say, you know, the gold
is actually very very valuable for
Renata Glask. But then again, you're
never going to get to your time warp
turns if you are using your runes
>> to pay the power cost. So I think that
was a wise choice. Also, this play will
end up probably getting you another turn
where you're holding with your Renata
glass mastermind and then your cam
baroness is going to get you another
gold token. So, I think you should be
fine on the gold token end.
>> Uh, one thing to know if we're we we're
in turns uh is the time has expired on
the round. So, one player does need to
get clear. So, I guess Ranata Glass if
you get to hold use Ranata ability that
will hold you up to like take you up to
four points. But there's a watcher
accelerated. He's going to get onto the
vile moors. That will put uh Malfunus up
to three and I think is enough to hold
this game to a draw at the end of time.
If I'm not mistaken, if the if the point
totals are correct, if everything is
good, that means Malfunos goes up to
three. I believe
>> Mad is going to be the active player for
turn number three, which will be the
final turn of the game. And then Ranata
Glass gets two. But if we're at 10
runes, we can go for crazy time war.
>> We're at nine, right?
>> Wait.
>> And also,
>> sorry, it's eight, right?
>> Oh, it is 10. But
>> I believe
>> how does time warp loop?
>> I believe time warp you don't get the
extra turn.
>> Oh, wow.
>> In turns cuz I maybe I'm wrong. Please,
I would love judges to know.
>> Just a hidden blade onto the good old
Thousand Tales. Watch it.
>> But there's no turns, right? I mean, you
push the Raven Bloom and you get another
punch
with your gold tokens. I think the one
that right now is exhausted should be
ready at this moment.
>> I wonder what the decision is on this
card.
>> Yeah, I guess is that it? You you hold
to three.
>> Raven Bloom goes in after the the the
hidden blade.
>> Yeah,
>> you score a four and then Ronald Glass
can can tap up to five, right? That
>> Thank you for for seeing that line. It
was so uh so focused on the time warp
for uh you know whether it would go
through.
>> Oh, we're actually going to tell I think
we might might have clarified with the
judges.
>> I I imagine so.
>> How is the time warp situation here
>> also? All right, we are just
>> we're going to find out.
>> Yeah, we're just exhausting everything
right now.
>> We take out four mind runes. We're not
using our gold tokens. Okay,
the question is
actually if you get three turns, do you
steal away a turn from your opponent
with time war? That would be hilarious
as well.
>> I'm not going to answer that question
because I think I thought I knew the
answer to it
and I might be wrong if I thought I knew
the Yeah, I think the the table spotter
is coming in and saying you don't get
another turn.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> He's asking if we can rewind
>> because Mad I believe
>> had a line. Can you really rewind when
the game has ended? Can you can you
rewind the game? And I think that's very
subjective to the judges. This is the
first regional qualifier that we're
having here in Bolognia. So
>> I'm I'm assuming that so the judge team
will be the ones that have the the final
say on that. But I'm pretty sure that's
correct. Also, I will have to rewind my
statement about the gold token being not
exhausted anymore because you got that
one from
>> although at this point I don't know that
that really matters too too much.
>> And that's a block
>> revealing a lot of Okay, so there is a
hidden blade and that is the line that
you were talking about. Yeah. Okay,
Raven Blue moves to the battlefield
layer and we're getting another point.
So, we're going up to five. passes a
turn
>> eventually getting there to to to five
points will be able to get two points
clear from that.
>> That was touch and go for a moment. I
was wondering where we were going with
that.
>> I think that is way cooler than time
warping your way to victory by the way
to just use Renata Glask and a top
decked hidden blade there on the
Thousand Tailed Watcher. Ari had the
problem two turns in a row that you Ari
needed to develop the thousand tailed
watchers and then had to completely
exhaust all of these runes there. And
sometimes, you know, creating great
bodies on the board is is fun. It's
great. But when you're tapped out in
Rift Bomb, there are so many
opportunities for your opponent to
capitalize on that, to use removal
spells, and to just know, hey, I have
held these five cards in my hand. I
haven't used them in the last few turns
because I knew you would have some nice
responses. Now, I know you don't, and
I'm going to go all out, capitalize on
that, and then push you into a situation
where you cannot recover from.
>> Well, I'm going to take this moment to
capitalize on the fact that we are done
with another round of Rift Bounce, so we
can check out the standings of the day
so far. After five rounds of play, let's
take a look and see exactly where we're
at. There's a bunch of 6 and0 players.
Uh, we've got some Dravens in the mix,
an Aurelia there, a civ, a couple of
civies, a lot of Dravens, though.
Somebody is gonna screen cap this and be
like, "Yeah, Draven's broken." And I'm
like, "Uh, yeah, they probably can't
argue with that."
>> Shocker. Actually, there's there's some
big names in this that have been
successful in other trading card games.
That is really impressive that some
people they just have this this thing in
their brain which works with TCG, right?
>> Any any that jump out at you from this
first list,
>> Lorenzo Santo, Marcus Patel especially,
they are phenomenal players as well. And
I think other players in there as well
have performed well in international
tournaments.
>> Yeah, I the name Ian Jang seen around
the scene as well quite some time. I
mean anybody that's 6 and0 in this list
is going to be stacked and we'll be
following through uh some feature
players throughout uh the tournament. Of
course, as we get through day one, day
two, it's only going to be, you know,
more focused in on those top players. We
we've been quite spread out across
things getting a Ronald Glask here and
there. Um tomorrow I think we're going
to end up watching a lot of uh the the
meta decks decks that we're seeing in
the top eight at at this point in time.
>> Honestly, the way Renata Glass is
performing, I don't even know if we're
not going to see it in day two.
>> Yeah, we'll we'll we'll see. We'll see
whether it happens in day two. and we'll
see what happens in a few minutes time
when we come back for round six from
Bolognia
qualifiers here with a familiar face to
people who followed esports for a little
while. Jabin, uh, I'm just here to ask
some questions based on the players,
what decks they're playing, some of the
strengths. So, who you running here in
Bolognia?
>> I'm playing Aurelia. You know, a bit
controversial, maybe a bit meta, but I
played Teemo set one and that was a
challenge. So, I thought this set I'll
take it a bit easier. So, I'm I'm
playing meta today.
>> Nice. Nice. So, what is like your
favorite card to play in Aurelia here at
the tournament so far?
>> It's a tough call cuz the deck is like
so interesting actually. Like there's so
many lines with all the movement she
has, right? I think Diviant Dance is
probably the most satisfying just
because you know, you buff your might
and you know their might. So, it feels
really good. Um, so probably Defiant
Dance is like the it's normally the
killer piece in every game.
>> Opposite question then for Urelia. What
card do you not want to see your
opponent playing?
>> Uh, I think Rebuke is the worst one. I
feel like no matter how many not so
fasts I stack in my deck, I still get
rebuked like once a set somehow.
Rebuke's probably the the biggest
danger.
>> Well, hopefully you can dodge rebukes
for the rest of the tournament. Good
luck in the rest of your rounds and
we'll catch up with you later.
>> Thanks a lot.
>> Hello and welcome back to Riftbound
qualifier. Open qualifier qualifier.
Open
>> regional qualifier.
>> Regional qualifier. That's the one.
Look, I've been here for however many
hours now. 10 hours.
>> A long day so far.
>> I'm I'm used to
>> five games 40 minutes each.
>> Mhm. and then I'm done.
>> Welcome to the world of TCGs, my friend.
>> We're here for the long haul, but
honestly, it's more action-packed than
you could ever dream. So, realistic so
far.
>> The twists and turns that can come
around in a trading card game, I think,
are very dynamic, and I think there's a
lot more flexibility within that. So,
welcome to our world.
>> Yeah, I I'm enjoying it. It's been a lot
of fun. I think we've had some really
cool matchups as well. We had that lease
in winning last time we were on the
desk. This time, we're going to have a
couple of fun matchups as well as we get
into round six. We have the metag game
breakdown. Before we get there though,
we already saw the top 10. Lots of
Dravens sitting in those spots.
Metagame, okay, less than 20% Draven.
That is
>> encouraging overall, although Dravens
have been converting to that 6 and0
score line. Kites are a little bit
higher than I expected, I'd say.
>> Oh, no. That was my prediction. You see,
I I was expecting the prowess of Kaiser
and the experience that people have had
playing it through set one and set two
to to bring up that 11% share total,
which I think is fantastic. I think the
one that I'm surprised to see up there
is Ahri, actually.
>> Yeah, Ahri actually quite surprising. I
will say I think Ari has a very
dedicated fan base as she does in
League.
>> Oh, yes.
>> I think a lot of people play her cuz
they think she's cool.
>> She is cool. It doesn't surprise me that
we see a few of her at least 54 players
out of a 1,719
player pool is only 4%. And it may be
that they just open the signature. You
know, if you open the signature
overnumbered, you're like, well, I've
got to play the reh now.
>> True. That is true. But it's also a lot
it's a lot of people fighting for that
top spot for that for that AI best of.
That is a bigger share than I was
expecting for Ahrig and I'm pleased to
see it. It's a very cool deck. It's got
very unique mechanics, but I wasn't I I
would expected Rexai to be above Ahri
personally, and I know it's a small
share, but it's there.
>> Yeah, I agree with that. I also think
there's a possibility, as you said, with
the Kaisen kind of with the Annie decks.
People are comfortable on these decks.
They haven't had a huge amount of time
with Spirit Forge. It's only been out
for about a week right now. So just
bringing in something that you're aware
of and you're comfortable with. Even if
maybe Rexi is slightly better in the
meta, even if you uh think that Rexi
could be slightly more consistent,
bringing out an AR makes a lot of sense.
We're going to get into our first game
though of round six and
>> let's see what we've got to bring you
guys. We've got many unique matchups and
this is certainly another one of them.
We're going to be bringing it all the
action. Yeah, we don't know which one
yet. We know that two are taking part,
but we don't know which one we've got
straight off the bat. But regardless,
it's going to be a good game. And this
time it's going to be Kaiser versus
Jinx.
>> Yeah, Kaiser into Jinx as we you talked
about a little bit. Kaiser obviously a
legend that came out in Origins. A few
changes here. You see the Piercing Light
firstunner coming in. Apart from that,
relatively standard compared to the
Origins list. You also have the
Plundering Pora and the Bellow's Breath
for that little bit of extra power. But
overall, it kind of does what it wants
to do. It's a very heavy spell slinger
damage deck trying to wipe away your
opponent's units while keeping yours on
the board.
>> That's its whole thing and it's been
shown strength to strength especially
through Origins. Many uh many a nexus
knight has seen a good Kaiser deck. But
Jinx, the literal loose cannon right now
of this event, a really understated card
in theory in a vacuum. A very very
powerful legend ability at the start of
your beginning phase. Draw one if you
have one or fewer cards in your hand. So
you can kind of play out and then draw
naturally back in. Now Jinx has this
interesting flow of game where you pop
off at different moments and you take
your time and then you have a big pop
off combo turn and then you take your
time and then you have a big pop-off
combo turn and using those kind of peaks
and troughs to your advantage and using
them at the correct timings is crucial
to this matchup and is crucial to Jinx
gameplay. So, I'm interested to see how
it interacts with Kaiser and whether
Olex can kind of bring Jinx into this
space with Kaiser being quite so
dominating.
>> Yeah, you can understand also what it's
trying to do bolstered a lot by cards in
Spirit Forge. You have a lot of this
discard draw idea, things like the scrap
heap, you've got the Ezreal in there as
well that can do quite a lot of work for
you. So, we'll see how it goes. There is
Jinx on turn one going to play out the
uh treasure hunter to kick us off and
we'll see where they go from there. Now,
some of these cards are in Chinese.
We're pretty good at identifying the AR
for you. I will say I am not perfect at
it. Is a Zorn Warren at the bottom and
the void gate up at the top. Kaiser
loves that void gate. The extra damage
that it gives to you when you are
targeting units just gives you so much
more power.
>> Yeah, it gives you that extra wiggle
room that you need. But the nice thing
about a Jinx deck is that you're kind of
not worrying about that early game
anyway. You're going to dip in for a
point. You're going to get that treasure
token from the move and just start kind
of littering the board with these really
cheap units. You don't mind if they
suffer. You don't mind if they go down
because that's not what you're comboing
towards. You're comboing towards those
big turns where you're revealing things
from the top of the deck. You're getting
those kind of last rights, Razes and
Death Rockets late game and you're
wanting to see the battering rams and
the nocturn horrifyings off the kind of
stack decks and cord shots. Hex great
coming out from problems eye here on the
Kaiser just to clear out that treasure
hunter wanting to make sure it doesn't
get too much value but immediately
another one backs it up alongside the
noxious hopeful getting all of those
runes used and five might on the board.
A really nice hit early on for Ollie UK.
Oil UK. Ollie look.
>> Ollie look I think. I like that.
>> Sure. We'll go with a ring to it.
>> Yeah.
>> It does sound a little bit like a phone,
doesn't it? Look.
>> Okay. Problems goes in. Okay. Going for
another point there. Just starting off
this game. Nice and slow for both
players. But honestly, I think this is
the way you have to go with this. Kaiser
going in with some more units at this
stage is advantageous. Of course, we're
going with our champion unit. Uh very
strong. doesn't need to be accelerated
at this point though. You don't really
need to push that much harder to kind of
get ahead because you know that Jinx
can't do much right now in regards to
raw power.
>> Yeah, just going to go for the stack
deck. Have a look at the top three. Make
sure that you are getting into a good
position in terms of hand. Not really
using the uh loose cannon legend ability
too much. You need to have one or fewer
cards in your hand to do that. And at
the moment we have an Ezreal, a
battering ram, a Bushwack, a couple of
seals, and that treasure hunter. The
>> second seal, the switcheroo, and the
treasure hunter in hand at the moment.
Battering round put down to the bottom.
>> Going for the Ezreal taken. Okay.
>> Yeah, I think we took the Ezreal. I
think we want to go for the card draw.
Kind of get more units on the board.
Kaiser is certainly a a slightly more
aggro deck, especially because of the
amount of spells that they can cast even
cheaper because of their legend ability.
So, you kind of want to be going
toe-to-toe with them in that respect.
So, going in with the Noxus Hopeful here
just to take that easy um easy
battlefield there.
>> Take the watch for Sentry. The Death
Note trigger does come out draws a card
for our Kaiser player. So, we'll see
just how effective that was. going to
spend the gold and what?
>> Put that in the piggy bank. What are we
getting?
>> Gold for seal. Seal for an Ezreal. Feels
like a very solid turn. Ezreal then
coming down will make us discard the
final card in or one of the two cards in
our hand and then draw two. Get rid of
the third treasure hunter that we had
from the start of the game. First card.
>> Couldn't quite see what it was.
>> No, I couldn't quite catch that either.
>> I mean, that's okay. We can't be
expected to see everything that goes
into everyone's hands, you know. No,
exactly. But honestly, I'm looking at
the synergies in this deck right now,
and I'm feeling really good about Jinx
like having this much card draw already
early in the game, piecing together
those nice pieces, ready for a big pop
off if needed. Kaiser's kind of taking
the back seat right now. We know that
she can definitely come back with a
ferocious glare, but we're still
managing at the moment just to keep on
top of things. Going in with a battering
ram.
>> Yeah, really nice. If you can get a
couple of cards off early and then the
banner coming out for two are going to
hide a card as well. Could be a fight or
flight would make a lot of sense in this
sort of position. If you go in with the
Kaiser, knock it back. Don't you don't
get the conquer trigger as the uh Kaiser
survivor player. So problems eye there
would not be able to get the extra draw.
>> Ooh, we got a falling star. So we can
start to pick apart the Jinx
battlefield.
>> Also, I believe a progress day at the
back of the hand there.
>> Oh yeah,
>> love myself a little bit of progress.
You know, a nice little card draw you uh
back into games if you are falling
behind in terms of that metric. We are
going to go with the falling star.
>> It's just so cheap with the legend
ability, right?
>> Getting uh that extra cost reduction is
just so powerful in these situations.
Taking out an Ezra, taking out a Noxious
Hopeful because the Noxus Hopeful was at
the void gate. The damage which would
usually only be three uh amplified up to
four enough to take out that might.
>> Ooh. Okay, Kaiser going in. Don't think
there's going to be much of a response
to that. And that we do get the trigger
from its ability.
>> Looks like we got more removal there,
which is always helpful. We love a bit
of hex tech and going in with a
lecturing yord just to pump it up there
in the battlefield.
>> Also has tank, which means that if you
do go into that battlefield, the Kaiser
isn't at risk. There's a battering ram.
You can see on the other side the
lecturing yord will be able to eat up
enough of that ram that the Kaiser then
doesn't die through the trample on the
ram. So, you think it's Is there a name
for this battering ram? Because in Lord
of the Rings, Grand is the famous
battering ram, right? I feel like this
one should have a name as well.
>> We might have to name them by the end of
this set. Maybe we'll figure it out.
We'll figure out the perfect name.
>> Interesting, you know.
>> Oh my gosh. The interesting thing to
note about this board state is now that
Problem Zite is out of runes, we won't
be able to have any mid turn
interaction. So kind of knows that they
can kind of get away with a few sneaky
bits here. Going straight away with the
stack deck. Of course, we get to have a
little look and see which of those three
cards we'd like to put in hand. And
again, I'm really impressed with how the
Jinx has the Jinx deck with the purple
that it can employ and use this chaos.
They're able to now have a draw engine
that gives them more reliability into
these matchups.
>> Yeah, push back coming out as well for
that readying. So, getting rid of some
cards in hand, which is nice if you want
to do try and activate that legend
ability.
>> Journeying through the deck is powerful.
>> Little conversation happening with the
judges, it seems. Problem just making
sure that everything was okay with that
bushwack. I don't know if we have put
the fresh gold token in because I think
that gold token there was already in
play. So maybe we it's that we need the
the gold the extra gold
>> power. Oh, true. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> From the bushwack maybe,
>> but I'm not sure.
>> Uh but regardless, it it matters not
right now. The point is bushwack is in
play. Friendly uh units enter ready,
which is incredibly powerful for just
being able to continue to put the
pressure on problems eye here. Again, we
could go in and kind of deal with the
Yord
>> just to get it away from the
>> Kaiser.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh but I'm not sure what else is in hand
to be able to play, but Oh, there it is.
>> Gorge shot. Okay, let's have another
look. Been through the top three a
couple of times with the stack deck.
Let's have a look at the top four in
increments of two. And Ezreal in the
options. Expect that to be taken. Really
the the discard one, draw two. So
powerful. If you don't have any cards to
discard, you still draw the two as well.
you do as much as you can out of cards
like that. So, my expectation is it will
be the Ezreal. Can't quite see. Did you
notice what the other card was?
>> I didn't, but I I think regardless if
you've got the option of an Ezreal when
you've just lost one, I think that's I
think that's the take. I think that's
the play.
>> Oh, snap keep there from Olly. Look on
the next one. Oh, it must be an Arasa.
He's counting how many cards there are
in his trash.
>> Must have been. It's got to be, right?
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Yeah, counts coming out from Eye as
well. Here it comes. Surely.
>> Surely.
>> But do we put it in base or do we push
it to the battlefield?
>> It's a good question. It's a good
question because you could use it to
bolster up the uh the treasure hunter
sitting at the Zorn Warren. Do you need
to or do you want to try and get on
towards the other battlefield?
>> Well, it's coming in ready. So,
>> a traveling it's a traveling merchant.
Okay. So, maybe it wasn't the Rasa.
That's going to go in get them.
>> Try and pop the yle as well potentially
just again to get that away from Kaiser.
kind of being Kaiser's like little
little minion in the front there, not
allowing anything to get past the tank
damage.
>> Nice trade. Nice trade. Battery Ramno
goes in. Kaiser is going to fall. As you
said, you talked about the sneaky tricks
when problems was all out of energy and
it has really paid off there for Olly.
Look,
>> the merchant, they were like, you know,
you can't do anything to respond to
this. You have nothing left and you
don't have any hidden units. I know that
I can quite confidently go in right now.
Deal with that Y then Kaiser one at a
time. Here it is. That was beautiful
sequencing bringing out the Rasa from
the kind of reduced cost mechanism that
we've seen and grown to love already.
>> I feel like, and I might be wrong on
this, the Bushwack was played this turn.
Was it lots? Okay, so then shouldn't the
battering ram and the Rasa come in
ready?
I think the battering ram was the second
battering ram because we have two at
play. But I think that the
>> No. So the first battering ram was
played on the previous turn. I mean this
in the end doesn't matter, right? If he
wants to put them in base, you can put
them in base, right? But I feel like
that battering ram and that VA should
have come in ready on this turn.
>> But again, they're probably best in base
to be honest right now. And we're over
to problems turn regardless. And looks
like we're just going in the switcheroo.
>> Beautiful.
>> Swapping the uh kind of might and attack
powers of these two units. So really
pushing problems eye now to make a
reaction. We're going with the ray.
>> So the switcher will resolve makes the
Noxus hopeful a one might makes the
treasure hunter a four might and then
they will both trade.
>> Oh, so the battlefield is left empty as
both units fell with a very simple
reaction from Kaiser there with the hex
tech, but a really effective one. That's
why we want these we want these runes up
and ready for those moments.
>> Yeah, that we do. Electron Y going into
base to get excited drawn off. It had a
plundering power, a thousand tailed
watcher uh sitting in the hand there as
well. can be used very effectively with
things like the hex tech ray with things
uh with any of those damaging spells
just to make it much easier to get rid
of a roster to get rid of a bashing ram
the ability just to uh ping them
>> for three less than I haven't seen that
card in a while
>> I've seen a few kaisers playing it
recently it can work really well you
have to discard and then because you
have things like the first four running
you just discard a high might card gets
rid of the battle at the void gate
That's really nice removal. I like that
a lot and I think it's um very poignant
using that card into Jinx.
>> Yes. I mean, it's one of her main
foyables as a as a champion. You know,
>> he's a legend.
>> So, using her own tech against her.
>> Yeah. We have two card draws here for
Ollie. Had less than one in hand at the
uh start of his beginning phase. So,
draws from his legend trigger and then
draws again for turn.
currently in a pretty commanding
position when it comes to might on the
battlefield at least or in base. Going
to crack out the
rebel there.
>> If you can't read it on your screen, no
worries. We can read it for you. When
you discard one or more cards, ready me
and give me plus one might this turn. It
is one of the arcane promos, which is
why the art looks pretty different, but
very cool.
>> Beautiful. And you know, going ahead and
hiding more at the battlefield. really
all establishing that commanding
position now and you have to against a
deck like Kai'Sa. Kaisa is the queen of
comebacks. She does not mind that you
have this overlooming presence.
Generally speaking, a lot of the high
cost
kind of attacking units in Kaiser like
Thousand Tail Watcher love this moment.
>> They lap it up for breakfast. So if you
thousand tail watcher reducing the might
of everything by three that's a three
and a two. You can go in with your
plundering power and clear out a
bathering ram. But that rasa still
stands a little bit taller. A stupify
does help you with that means that you
could trade out both the rasa and the
bering ram. But there are two units in
base for ollie luck. And so if you then
pass the turn those two units go in you
conquer conquer you go to eight. It's
not the best position for problems eye.
So, he needs to try and establish a
presence on one of these battlefields.
>> 100%. And I think the nice thing in this
situation is that the thousand tail
watcher does come down. And of course,
if we do end up being able to draw more
cards, we might draw into something else
we could use. However, obviously that
cost a lot. So, we're going in with a
thousand tail watcher here for the seven
against. Yep. All good.
>> Wait, it's against three as well because
of the reduction.
>> Beautiful.
The accelerate on the thousand tail
watch are doing a huge amount of damage.
>> Super for a drawing
itself. Now you kind of want to go in I
mean you need to go in with at least one
of these. It's looking like it's going
to be the lecturing yord keeping the
plundering po back to conquer afterwards
so that you can get that gold token.
What have we got hidden here? Is it a
fight or flight? It is. Bounces the
battering man back. decides they want
more power, more might on the next turn
rather than trying to force a trade with
the plundering power on this.
>> I honestly think that's a really great
play. It's a great signal to say
actually I I can hold my own, but I need
these units. I'm going to I'm going to
come back because I've already had my
might reduced this turn. I I don't fancy
losing it, but I also feel like I'm not
going to carry on this survival tactic.
long is sol
and unexpectedly so. But Jinx has some
great late game um tools to utilize as
well to have some removal of smaller
units like these Yles. So I don't mind
seeing them at the battlefields, but
also does pose a risk with things like
super mega death rocket.
>> It really does. Jinx now uh sorry Kaisen
now sitting at one energy hex tech ray
or I mean maybe a retreat but you don't
really want to use a retreat in these
situations kind of all that we are
relying on at the bottom battlefield we
have nine might need to hold Ollie luck
away from taking both so looks like it's
going to be a well it's an Ezreal and
a cold shot and something else in hand
as far as I can tell ram goes in Yodor
dies and it's up to seven.
>> It's a really strong position for Jinx
to be in. If we can keep this pace up,
>> then we're just going to overrun Kaiser
before they can actually respond.
They're running out of uh
>> of enough resources to kind of kind of
deal with this onslaught that Jinx is
really pressuring on right now. We
talked about those es and flows and yep,
that's it. Looking like that's the game.
Jinx the loose cannon taking game one
against the overwhelming champion of set
one, Kaiser.
>> Yeah, and surprising. I think this core
that the Jinx has managed to wrangle
together has really allowed her to play
around the edges of the legend ability.
It used to be that you felt very weak
being like, well, I get one extra card,
but I'm having to dump my hand so
consistently to get this legend ability.
But now with the stack decks, with the
cord shots, with the Ezreal as well,
you're just allowing yourself so much
more freedom. And credit to Wally Luck.
Played it really well. Have another look
at the main board here.
>> Singular fears, double switcheroo. I
like the last rights as well.
>> It's very heavy on the two costs.
>> That's the point. Yeah, you want that.
You want those low quick units at the
beginning and then you kind of build up
to these big combo turns with things
like cold shot and then the last rights
and we saw the bushwack to really great
effect in that game. And honestly, it
was played perfectly. I can't fault any
move there. It just was seamless and
against such a strong deck like Kaiser
and so well respected. I I think there
are some Jinx fans in the room having a
great day.
>> Yeah, agreed, agreed. Uh we see the
sideboards for problems eye on this uh
Kaiser list. Brineer could be okay. A
couple of those there. Unchecked power
as well will be able to wipe away a lot
of those lower energy units that are
being brought out by the Jinx. Have to
see exactly what we do decide to bring
in on that sideboard. As a Kaiser list,
it is pretty standard. You are, you
know, looking for those thy tail watch
the turns. Ferris forunner helping you
with that time warp as well. you do have
like a relatively good suite of removal
for low might units. Piercing light,
battle's breath both do perfectly in
those sorts of situations.
>> I think the problem is the high cost of
those. I think at the moment it's kind
of like the falling stars are great, but
then we get into things like singularity
and progress day and it's like, oh,
actually those are really high cost and
I'm not gaining enough for playing it.
Like I'm taking out little things or I'm
drawing a few cards, but it's not quite
getting me into what I need to get into
right now to be able to actually take
the advantage back. and all I'm taking
out are these two cost units. But
actually, I can do better, but I think
that's the problem is that there's too
much to invest
>> Mhm.
>> in taking out little guys.
>> Yeah, it's always tricky when they can
just be repopulated so quickly. It's
you're not playing into a tokens deck.
You're not playing into an Azil or
Victor, but it can sometimes feel like
that where it's just all of these little
swarmers coming out dealing a lot of
work to you. We'll see where we go in
terms of battlefields as well. Okay,
>> minefield on the bottom, side obelisk of
power on the top. Minefield is when you
conquer here, put the top two cards of
your deck into your trash. So, building
up towards those rasers, building up
towards those larger uh well, rases
specifically. Even fizz obviously can
work relatively well if you do have
those fizzes in your list. Obus power
allowing us to channel three, meaning
lecturing yord, turn one for problems,
treasure hunter, and a noxious hopeful
turn one for Ollie. Wow, you couldn't
make it up. That's almost perfect.
You've get you've got the bonus off the
obelisk. That's exactly what you wanted
and then be able to play two low cost
units. That's the perfect early game for
Jinx.
>> Yodo going in on his lonesome towards
that top side, but he'll be happy enough
to gain the first point of the game.
Chucks are pondering Porro down as well
alongside a second just to make sure
that if those conquers do begin
happening, he's in a very good spot.
>> Yeah, we got some backup. We We're doing
okay. Let's see if Ol can continue to
put the pressure on. We do have a riser
in hand, so there is kind of that uh
that uh that pressure to maybe start
using the battlefield to that effect.
But looks like we're going to go in and
challenge, which I really like. We're
just going straight in there saying,
"Can you respond? You are so low right
now." But we can respond. The hectic ray
comes down
>> like a shot to challenge that Noxus
hopeful.
>> I wonder if Ollie is uh
>> thinking about bargaining. Yeah. Going
to chuck out the hard bargain. Wants to
keep that Noxious Hopeful around and
will do so. No energy left for Problem
Eye. That is a point on the board for
Ollie. Has a Rasa and Ezreal. And I
could remember the last card a moment
ago, but now I have entirely forgotten
it is my
>> I'm sorry I distracted you. That's my
bad. And we got a gold token in creation
already. And
>> oh, it's a battering ramp.
>> Yeah, here's another battering ramp. Th
this has been an explosive first two
turn for Jinx. And it's something that
you don't expect from this deck. I'm
pleased to see it. I love to see the the
raw power going into this right now. Of
course, we then get to put two um cards
into our trash from the top of the deck.
And again, that's helping to play the
Razalator.
>> Yeah. Not the cards you would want. I
think you do have an Ezreal in hand, so
it's okay, but you you are trashing an
Ezreal and a stack deck, which are tools
you want to use to look for better cards
in your deck. Uh it does thin the deck a
little bit. You know, you can argue your
odds of getting the other cards you want
are higher now because you've got rid of
an Ezreal and a stack deck. But in the
end, the ability to pick and choose from
top three is so beneficial that you
really want to keep that going.
Singularity out, clearing the board out
with the 11 effective might on the
board. Getting rid of nine of it makes a
ton of sense. Alongside that, the poro
going in, getting a point, getting a
gold for problem.
>> And it's cleared. The board is clear.
Ollie look going from such a an
advantageous position of one spell has
made all the difference. And that was
that's what Kaiser is all about. It
really is. And the thing is now for
Ollie though, that's three more cards in
your graveyard.
>> Yeah,
>> you could Rasa here. I We all like
playing Rasa for one power.
>> That's fine.
>> You can play Rasa for more than that if
you so desire.
>> And we can here. We've got the option.
There's already a lot in the discar
pile. The reduction of cost would still
be severe, but we're we're going in with
the with the Jinx, of course, and yet a
last. The comeback is here. We're
bringing it forward, honestly. Brilliant
show as well, especially because that
Ezreal is now in the discard pile. At
least last rights has an opportunity to
pluck that back.
>> Yeah, can grab the Ezreal back out of
that. Can get the battering ram. Get the
uh the noxious hopeful as well if you
want. I think Ezreal and Bing are
probably the two that you really are
looking for. So
>> now Problem is gone up. He has gone up
to five.
>> That's huge.
>> If you can get to that six mark, you can
see here I say I don't need to hold. I
can look to conquer to six. I'm so far
ahead. Three points ahead of Ollie right
now. I can take my time about this a
little bit. Has a pount in hand. Looks
like that's what's going to enter into
the base right now. Also has that Kaiser
in his champion unit spot and that's
going to come out as well. No need to
accelerate it. You've already scored on
both battlefields this turn. No reason
to try and go back to a battlefield at
all.
>> Porro is a Kaiser's best friend. A very
porroheavy board right now.
>> I don't know if there were many of them
in the void.
>> No, I don't think so. I feel like it was
>> but somehow I feel like
>> I feel like Kaiser like having metapro
>> Yes.
>> would would adopt all of them.
>> Yeah. She's one of those champions where
you think you spent a lot of time in
what is this hellish landscape but
actually it didn't really affect you.
You're still a kind loving person.
>> That's kind of surprising but also look
at these cute guys.
>> Yeah.
>> Rescued from Bellevth now hugs the
Porros. Jinx going into the minefield.
Another two cards recycled from the top
of the main deck. We are at I believe
eight. It might be more than that.
Ezreal. Now there's going to be another
discard. Don't want to get rid of the
Rasa. We'll be drawing two. And that
will get us up to nine. I think it's a
fight or flight maybe. I'm trying to see
what the second card is under that Rasa.
Yeah, it is a fight or flight.
>> Is a fight or flight. Yes.
>> Are we discarding Rasa here?
>> I don't want to. Well, because you can
look for the last right to equip and
then resurrect the RAS.
>> Yeah, I think you're right. I think
you've got to go with that. I think
you've got to think ahead here cuz we
can equip even after a unit has joined a
battlefield. We can equip
>> but then you're equipping to hold and
that feels dangerous to me against
Kaiser. Yeah,
>> but then the other option is you you
discard your your fight or flight and
then you don't really have that combat
trick to be able to do much. So, the
rasa is going into the graveyard. Jinx
gets readied because of that discard,
gains an extra might. Now we're going to
cold shot on the Ezreal, paying the
repeat cost with Ezreal's passive
ability.
>> We love that. Again, getting things
cheaper makes games better.
>> It really does. Really does. Go Mats.
>> Talked about at the start of the day,
we're talking about at the end of the
day.
>> Always pays off. Another Ezreal draw to
hand I think off that second iteration
of Cordot, the repeated iteration. well
more than required here for the rest. I
say well it may have been one
>> that didn't actually count immediately.
>> Make sure that we're kind of holding
that space because again having units on
battlefields is too risky against Kaiser
right now especially when they have
managed to establish as much heavier
board. We've got two unspent gold tokens
and all of this all of these active
runes. So actually I think it is too too
too scary to leave Jinx there right now.
Jinx needs her army and her friends. So,
we're going to have to wait a little bit
longer to see that pop off turn from
Jinx. This is what more what we expect
from a Jinx deck where they kind of take
their time, build things up, and then go
bam.
>> Mhm.
>> And we did draw into another RA. So,
>> yeah, another
Exactly.
>> Here we're going to disco
hesitation on the hard bargain will go
into the trash. Jinx gets readyed again.
could equip the last rights here and go
for the conquer.
>> Oh, and then get the recoil effect.
Getting something back with
>> But look, look at this hand. It's
>> gin.
>> At the start of the turn, we were at
like two cards.
>> And also, like again, we said the the
effect of the champion unit is draw one
card when you have one card in hand. And
so many people perceived that as when
I'm deck building, I should be getting
rid of all my cards. No, just draw more.
>> Yeah, just draw as many as you can.
>> Just draw them.
>> Draw them all. And if you happen to be
low on hand, it's a great effect,
>> but it's not the be all and end all. You
don't need to focus in on that too hard.
>> It's a deck building uh fallacy to a
degree. It's like my deck does this,
therefore I can only do this. That's not
you can things can bolster the way that
you want to attack, the way that you
want to build your deck. Jinx going in
here after being readied
>> uh again with that discard. A hidden
card going down likely a fight or
flight. Could be the switcheroo as well.
We saw that playoff dividends in game
one
>> and I think that's the thing. Problems
eye now it knows the risks. They know
kind of what happened in game one. So
now we can look forward to those and see
whether they can respond. They need to
make sure that they have things in hand
that could deal with those threats.
Otherwise kind of probably going into
the other battlefield might be
advantageous here. We're at five to four
points scored right now. We didn't get a
hold point going in uh on that turn
because nothing was at a battlefield.
So, it's kind of looking at what the
correct status to get up to eight is
going to be at this point knowing that
you need both battlefields on that
eight. This part of the game is tricky
in and of itself because it has so much
thinking involved because you need to
know when is correct to conquer, when is
correct to bring things back to base,
and when is correct to just hold.
>> It's one of those difficult ones cuz if
problems I have been at six, Ollie plays
the the turn entirely differently cuz
you have to make sure you have presence
on the board here. If the Jinx gets
attacked, you want to fight or fight it
back. That's cool. It's like, okay, I
can give you another point. You can go
to six. you're going to do it anyway
with this Kaiser going in. We'll get the
card draw and then the minefield
trigger. Time Warp, Ferris, Forerunner
both going to the trash
>> into the bin.
>> And time war being one of those cards in
Kaiser that does win you games. And now
that's in the trash. We can't get it
back. And that that could be disastrous
if we don't manage to get anything else
that can kind of bolster us into a
winning position. If we manage to keep
this lock on Jinx,
>> the Jinx most likely just going to get
taken out. We'll see the Hex Tech Ray
being paid for
>> and then it's whether we take a unit, we
use another spell. Looks like another
spell's going on or a big one
>> or
so. So reducing the might of Jinx after
doing the damage means that she will go
down. avoids any shenanigans with the
fight or flight.
>> Fight or flight just gets discarded at
that point. Can't stay on the
battlefield with no one there.
>> Yeah. And when you've hidden a card at a
battlefield, it has to then target that
battlefield because you some people
would be like, well, fight or flight
says returning unit space at a
battlefield. Kaisers at a battlefield.
Why can't I bounce that? If you've
hidden it on the the obelisk of power,
it has to be used on the obelisk of
power. A couple of small niche examples
where that doesn't count as much like a
zyas. becomes a gear predominantly it
says at a battlefield it is at this
battlefield when hidden
>> and we're keeping things calming
into that
>> unit and just kind of said look we've
got this unit in a base they've got one
unit each base if you can deal with
those cool and then I'm going to try for
the seven eight in the same turn but
they've put a threat on the board to
slow Olly looks down
>> yeah yes they have thousand uh the
thousand tail stack deck just a singular
stack deck coming out and I think there
was a a cold shot stack deck and
something else top three. So, we're
going to have a cold shot cam out using
the seal to pay for the repeat cost with
the Ezreal as well.
>> And it's what we're digging for here.
Are we digging for removal? Do we want a
death rocket? Do we want
>> a Raza? We don't want to overcommit to
anything, but obviously at this point we
want as many big units or a lot of kind
of coverage to take out units as
possible. We want that repetition from
the super mega death rocket if that's
available. But right now looking like a
good position, but there's a lot of
scary stuff on problem size kind of back
line there.
>> Yeah, that thousand tail watch is going
to be the most concerning point of it
all. by itself takes out the Rasa
battering ram in onto the plundering
pole perhaps. Not battering ram knocks
just hopeful. My apologies. Perhaps
looking for the trade. Interestingly,
we're not seeing the last rights that
equipment going onto anything yet. Uh
when you conquer with it, you do get the
ability to cast a creature from your
graveyard or a unit from your graveyard.
So,
>> we're looking in the graveyard there to
see if there's anything worthwhile
bringing.
>> Anything trashed? Anything in the trash?
You you have a look through any fund
that you've left in there.
>> I don't think there's anything
impactful. I think that's the problem.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think there's still a
Russer in there cuz we discarded it
earlier on. I can't remember us
recurring it.
>> No, I think you're right actually cuz
this was the one from hand. So,
>> there is another big unit in there. It's
whether whether it's worthwhile taking
the borrow down. It's also do you want
to do you want to conquer both
battlefields before you recur the rasa
so that you can play it to either one or
do you want to specifically put it on a
on a certain battlefield. Also the last
strikes is giving your unit plus two. Do
you need that plus two for a good
conquer
>> problems lets the Nox is hopeful take
down the porro porro power no longer in
play in that battlefield
>> but there's plenty more on the bench on
the uh battlefield where that came from.
Yeah, the plundering P and the P are
still there. Still available for us. I'm
going to
equip the last right. So, what are we
recycling? Have to recycle two cards
from our trash. It's going to be a hard
bargain. And looks like we're just going
for simple stuff. Yeah, nothing too
>> outrageous.
>> Nope.
>> Where are we equipping it though? Is it
going onto Rasa? Are we going to buff up
an Ezreal? No,
>> I think it's got to be the Rasa. Yeah,
you want to kind of get that unit as big
as it can be, especially if you're going
to try for a hold
>> maybe for the last rights
>> or we're going in for the conquer. We're
saying, "Okay, I don't think you have
it. I think you can't respond and
problems. I could not respond to that."
So, we do get the trigger there. And of
course, we get the point for the
conquer.
>> Yeah. So, you can sack these triggers
however you want. It looks like the
minefield trigger is going to go off
first. That means that we do recycle two
from the top of our deck. Oh, not
recycle, discard two
>> from the top of our deck. Put two into
the trash.
>> We're probably going to go for the Razer
here, I imagine.
>> I think that makes the most sense. It's
basically free one power.
>> The battering ram.
>> I'm trying to work out what the
battering ram gives us over just
bringing back the rasa.
>> Maybe there's an argument with the Jinx.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah,
>> I could see the Jinx.
or even just like the fact that this
might hold and then you get more than
one thing back. It's kind of the what do
I want first? Maybe it's Ezreal. Maybe
it's more card draw. Maybe I'm still
digging. Maybe I don't want those big
units yet because those aren't entirely
necessary. We are bringing back the
Ezreal and again just like really
putting a stand there. I think going for
the last rights twice. Uh not very last
rights on it, is it? It's doing it quite
right.
>> Yeah. Um I think trying to go for that
twice is admirable here. We do have a
Rasa in hand. I wonder if we had that
before if we drew that because I can see
the Ezreal line where it's I put Ezreal
down. I'm going to discard draw two. I
know there's one Rasa in my graveyard
and one on the battlefield. If I draw my
next Rasa, I actually have more might at
this battlefield than if I just play the
Rasa.
>> Absolutely.
>> I have an extra three from the Ezreal
coming out. So, we got a couple of
overzealous fans and Rasa and I cannot
recognize that card in the middle.
Um
>> late in the day. Late in the day. It
looks like it. I don't think it's a hard
body.
>> I don't think it is. Oh, it's a scrap
heap. It's a scrap.
>> I think it is a Yeah. Or I was thinking
factory recall, but I think it is scrap
heap.
>> Yeah, I think it is a scrap heap. Okay.
So, on top of the Noxian hopeful. We'll
make it Noxian's hopefuls alongside an
overzealous fan.
>> That's an odd group, but I respect them.
>> Well, I mean, they're really hopeful and
this one person's cheering them on. It's
like you can do it. I believe you. Yeah,
positivity.
>> There's a fan in both stands now. Both
bad stands got a fan.
>> Nice, nice, nice, nice. Uh, looking for
the double. Yeah, lots of power being
put, lots of might being put on both
sides.
>> Saying if you can't, if you can't take
over both of these, you're not having
the win. And I'm then going to try and
take it back from you. This is a real
tussle. I wasn't expecting this from
these two decks. And honestly, I'm glad
to see it. It's very interesting.
>> Yeah, Ollie luck as well. only one win
in this series away from going to 50 and
one
>> on day one here. Undefeated, one draw.
>> Uh that's how the scoring system works
in most TCGs. You know, the middle
middle one is losses and the end one is
draws, which can be a little bit
confusing to some people. Definitely not
me. I definitely haven't been confused
by that at all in the past. Uh six wins
on the day does get you into the day two
action. So, Rocket Barrage, Bellow's
Breath, a Stupify, and is that a Darius
at the back?
>> Looks like it. We can draw more cards
for Stupify, and I think that's a good
start to this turn. You want to be
seeing as many cards as you can to be
able to sequence your turn properly. So,
I think for the cost of a stupify being
quite low, I think this is advantageous
to be able to see more cards. And seeing
more cards is better. And we have, of
course, we have the Kaiser ability. We
have two unspent gold tokens. So I think
here you stupify, but the difficult
decision is who to use it on.
>> Well, it's going to be the last writed
roster that gets stupified. So it goes
down from 8 to seven might, but still on
that battlefield, you have 10 18 might
with an overzealous fan there for
protection. On the top side, it's not
looking much better. You have 16.
No runes available for Ali, though. So
Problems Eye kind of knows what's in
front of me is what I have to deal with.
problems. I did draw a time warp off
that stupify.
I don't Okay, I'm going to say it. I've
done it before and it was horrible. In a
skirmish, I had to use it to draw a
card. I had to draw it just to start my
turn again.
>> And a worst case scenario sees that, but
I don't think that that's advantageous
here. But it's it's a play.
>> Uh we're not going for it. And I respect
that much more than my cowardice way out
of I guess I'll try again.
>> I mean, sometimes it's nice just to have
another go, have another shot at it.
Darius Trifarian is going to be the play
here already accelerated up to that
seven might ready to pseudo accelerated
but even then you've got 14 16 plus a
couple for the pouty power 18 total
might and
>> it's a lot yeah but on one battlefield
there's more than that for so
>> it's not it's just not enough that's
what I'm saying like that's why it's
it's frustrating because I can play
things but they're just not enough
they're just shy of anything and I don't
know if problem has any removal in hand
right now to be able to deal with some
more of these units post stupify.
>> It looks like he's going to use daughter
of the void to cast something. Bellow's
breath. Where are we going?
>> Yeah, I think that makes the most sense.
>> Going to do two damage to the
overzealous fan and then two each to
both those Ezreals, putting them down to
well, they're still three might but with
two damage marked on them.
>> So, they have one kind of essentially
health.
>> One health left. Yeah, it's uh one of
those intricacies in Riftbound where you
have to have done damage equal to the
might, but doing the damage doesn't
reduce the might in any way.
>> Yeah, he kind of heals up at the end of
the turn. So, if you don't deal with him
in one turn, he'll brush off his wounds,
put a plaster on, and get on with it.
>> Yeah. If someone is zero might, they
aren't dead. You have to have still done
a damage to them to actually kill them
off.
>> So, this is where we'll be looking at
moving in on that base now because we've
we've made all that effort to weaken
things. So, it's kind of a you don't
want that sunk cost fallacy of not
actually then dealing with those
threats. Only taking one unit out just
doesn't feel good. So, at least being
able to scurry a few of them away feels
better. But I think we're going all in.
>> That we are 14 16 18 might on the side
of problems eye. On the other side,
we're looking at only 14 with some
damage marked.
>> Only you just said only 14.
Not a ginormous number.
>> As a as a player, anything less than 40
is low might in my head.
>> Kind of works.
>> Oh, respect it, man. I respect it.
>> What's Ollie going to kill off here? I
think is the big question you got to
ask.
>> I think it's got to be the heavier
units, right? We can deal with Porros.
>> Yeah,
>> Porros are just puffy little friends. We
can deal with those later.
>> The good thing for Ollie as well, as
soon as he holds, he gets one of those
units back. You want you want to recur
your Ezreal, go ahead.
>> That's why we wanted that last right so
heavily defended.
>> Mhm.
Makes a lot of sense. Makes a lot of
sense. So, we have two porros defending
the gold coming out of the plundering
pro being not used this turn. Four
damage to
>> Oh, no. It says kill the gear there for
the rocket barrage.
>> And I think that's perfect. Honestly,
you get to choose one. You kill a gear
or deal four damage to a unit in a base.
>> Kill the gear. Yes, absolutely. That was
the problem. Dealt with that
marvelously. And although problems is
low on units, I think at this point, you
know, it's we're in a not awful position
all things considered. Now, can Olly
look just pull forward enough? Can they
take that final battlefield? It's not
great to do it now because we don't
really want that cuz we're only on six.
>> We would need to take over that
battlefield.
>> At seven.
>> Oh, okay.
>> I think we should be at seven from the
hold if I recall correctly because Yes,
there.
>> Oh, yeah. I thought so. I doubted myself
because I saw it. No, I was wrong.
That's okay. But no, so we should be
pushing. We're pushing for the win here.
This is the moment.
>> I don't think we can. I don't think we
have any accelerate to get there in
time. Yeah, the scoop comes out from
Molly. We go to game three.
>> We can't do it.
>> Huge play from Problem Z to regain
control of the top battlefield, keep
themselves in the game, and then a lack
of accelerate for Ollie UK, Olly Luck,
sorry, caused a a few problems.
Rocket Barrage there really coming
through from the sideboard showing just
why it's there for exactly these odd
scenarios where actually you need to
deal with some gear because otherwise
that is going to be your undoing. Gear
has been so powerful and instrumental in
Spirit Forge. We've seen so much success
from gears and from the kind of harsh
increase in gears that we've seen and
having something simple to deal with
that and keep yourself in the game.
marvelous
>> because your options are rocket barrage
and and thermmo beam really and you
don't want to be using a thermmo beam
just to kill off the last rides.
Obviously it will hit the seals as well
but less impactful later on in the game.
Thermo beam much more built for those
heavy gear decks that really want the
gold that really want to be able to play
you know spellers etc. They're good
decks uh is what I call them generally.
Ollie we'll see if he decides to
sideboard in anything else. was coming
deck working as intended
>> but didn't just p just didn't quite pull
up there did it like started off really
strong was really confident was feeling
good about it and then Kaiser did Kaiser
things and all of a sudden the board
just kind of fell apart
>> and that is often the problem like
Kaiser doing Kaiser things this is the
reason that people don't play as much
Jinx Draven does Draven things Kaiser
does Kaiser things does Aurelia things
and like Jinx can work really well but
it feels like the consistency isn't
always there the ability to really
control the board effectively against
high damage spells or good removal is a
bit of a struggle. I didn't actually
check to see what the uh the last two
battlefields were going to be. It'll be
a discovery surprising.
>> Yeah, I think uh it'll be interesting to
see as well if Ollie decides that they
want to be on the first turn. I do like
playing first on the first turn. I I
think it makes the most sense. uh kind
of you have to decide it before
mulligans, but you are looking for those
lowc cost units. So getting out an early
um traveling merchant or something would
be very effective for them. Go through
our mulligans. Uh what do we have? We
have a reaver's rope and a star tipped
peak as well.
>> Love to see the sportsmanship there.
Fist bump to start off the game three.
Very nice. And we are able to make a
play. Jinx going first.
>> Ah, it's looking like a seal. Yeah,
we're not mad at that. Just getting a
little bit of ramp, a little more kind
of permanent
spendage on our board.
>> Seal into cold shot. I feel like you
could seal into Noxious Hopeful as well
if you wanted. You have the the energy
floated, right? So,
>> yeah. I mean, I think just digging here
for the for further cold shots and stack
decks, those kind of
>> maybe in more early kind of two drop
units. So I think digging through the
deck at this stage is very advantageous
even if you're not kind of equit doing
much. You're not putting a lot of units
into play. But you're right the hopeful
makes it through as well. Happy with the
Legion effect there.
>> Yeah it's true. I I for some reason in
my head I was like if you play cool shot
you can't play the Nox hopeful but the
energy is still there. You can still
play it out. So gets to play a three
card turn one into a single card turn
one from problem with that watchful
sentry coming out. Arasa was put to the
bottom of the deck. options here on turn
two hopeful in towards I mean do you
want to go start it do you want to go
reavers do you want to even do that
first I'm trying to work out if there's
enough to be able to play the battering
ram that's sitting at the back there
will cost you the three and because you
recycle turn one I don't think you have
enough to actually get the uh the
battering ram out this turn so Ezreal
comes down we're going to have discard
and draw. Stack deck or cord shot are
the options. I mean, battering ram
obviously also an option, but the
expectation is you want to keep that cuz
it's a five my unit often for two or two
or three energy. It's really powerful.
>> I don't know. I think at this point of
the game, you're wanting to cycle
through the deck. I think you're wanting
to draw as many cards as possible and
you can get that bing round later.
>> Oh, there you are. You just got one.
>> Got another one. It's fine. Genius.
There's more. It's okay. And that's the
point like drawing cards, you're more
likely to just
>> jump back in and have those cards again.
But also, we know last rights is a
thing. We know that units that do hit
the trash aren't necessarily going to
stay there. Whereas the other cards, we
can't recur those.
>> Mhm.
>> 100% correct. And obviously shown by the
fact that it worked for you. If it
works, it must be good.
>> Oh, there we are. Nice falling star
there to just completely decimate Ollie
looks bored there. Just gone from 100 to
zero like the opposite way around to
what you expect there. And of course
then moving in for that first point on a
battlefield.
>> Yeah, getting that watchful sentry in.
Managing to get the first point. Start
tip picked allowing you to channel that
rune exhausted whenever you hold doesn't
mean you need to get through the turn
cycle.
>> Speaking of battering rams, there's
more.
>> Look. Okay. How was I meant to know that
the the top of the deck was all rams?
Okay.
>> You've got to be kidding me with how
many rams there are here.
>> That totally bit you straight away.
>> It's just a woolly situation, you know.
Yeah. Uh, that's what drawing cards
does. We love drawing cards. Drawing
cards gets you
>> more battering rams. I'm never going to
let
>> Sean isn't close enough a pun to
showing, is it? No. Feels like it should
be. No, I feel sheepish about that one.
>> That's a bit better than close door.
Yeah, I'll allow that.
>> What we got in hand? We got the double
batting ram, uh, the treasure hunter,
and the cool shot in the look. It's a
fight or flight, a stack deck, and a
noxious hopeful. We're going to take the
stack deck out of the middle.
>> Yep, I agree. I think again, this is
what Jinx is all about. You want to you
want to go on that curve that we were
talking about earlier. You want to you
want to save your save your stack decks
and just call shots. You want to pop off
with them. We didn't see any knock
horrifying. I'm not sure if they're
playing it in this build. I haven't seen
it in their build, which is a bit of a
shame cuz I think that's a really lovely
combination with these sorts of decks,
but
>> it's really in hard bargain to the
bottom alongside another. So, that's two
cards played so far this turn.
We can make it three with a cord shot if
we want.
>> Or do we just Yeah, cold shot for the
three.
>> We're going to use the seal.
>> It's basically free.
>> The bait is on the repeat right now.
>> I think I think you go for it.
>> We are. We're repeating.
>> Okay.
>> I think it's so important at this point
for Jinx to just establish as many cards
in hand as possible.
>> Keep on the last rights.
>> There's another seal. You can make it
four.
Play the seal.
>> Yeah.
>> And then play the battering rams. No.
Going to decide. Oh, well, you don't
even need to play the seal because you
can battering ram for two and then
battering ram for one.
>> That's
>> That's how maths works.
>> That's how we do it. That is battering
ram at its at its finest. Really, that's
exactly what we want to see. And there's
the comeback there. There it there it
is. We we were out of units. Problems
dealt with the threats on board and now
they're back. Now problems has a lot of
runes here. We have a lot of power and
it looks like we're going to be spending
a fair chunk of them. So, let's see how
we go and what's coming down on
my goodness. You got to be kidding me.
>> It's huge. It's just huge. Immediately
getting rid of everything that Ollie was
trying to do on the previous turn. I
will say just notice champion unit has
been changed around here for Ollie. He
has moved to Jinx Demolitionist with the
ultimate art away from Jinx Rebel. Uh
accelerate assault two and when you play
me, you discard two on that
demolitionist. So, it will be
interesting to see if that is a I mean,
obviously, it's a strategic move, but
how effective that will be at actually
combating some of problems boards. The
accelerate does allow you to mitigate
situations like at the end of game two
where Ollie just didn't have a unit to
get out to the battlefield.
>> I also really like the fact that you're
able to then use it to discard more
cards. So, then you're giving yourself
more power in the bank for other units
because
>> you get things cheaper. And once again,
if we can play it for free,
>> it's the best card. Go crazy. We got Oh,
okay. The last rights is in hand again.
So, that does kind of give us that
recursion power, but is it too early? Do
we need it right now? We can have it in
play, but then it's kind of under
threat. We know that there are threats
to it now.
>> Yeah, we know that you've got the the
thermo beam, you've got the rocket
barrage, the ability to take it out. So,
my expectation is that we won't go last
right as of yet. We do know also there's
a Rasa near the bottom of our main deck
because we put it back there early on
with one of the stack decks. So for the
moment my expectation is build a bit
more of a base get yourself in a strong
position is only on two is only going to
go to three with the hold can accelerate
their Kaiser out for four but
>> the Fizz and the last rights here really
not sure on that decision and honestly I
don't blame them they've gone for the
last rights. I'm I'm not sure about it.
I'm going to be real. I'm not sure about
it. But then again, I'm not 401 with
Jinx here in Bologna the regional
qualifier. So, what who am I?
>> Well, I mean, you're Amy.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Your truth.
>> Really strong hand. Wow, that's a lot of
units and a lot of might to go with them
>> and only enough runes to kind of be
playing a small flurry of those right
now. Yeah, the forerunner is nice in
this sort of position because it does
just generate you so much might
throughout the rest of the game. Falls
foul of something like a fight or flight
which we have seen coming out of oi
switcheru as well can cause it problems
but you're still getting the extra mech
if you do get switched to rude on it. It
doesn't get rid of that ability that
death nail so I wouldn't be surprised if
we do see the ferris 4runner. It also
sets you up later for a thousand tail
watcher into double mech attack.
>> Beautiful, beautiful combinations there.
And the first four runner is a really
annoying unit to have to deal with for a
deck that has so many little units like
Ollie does. So I think that's a nice one
to just throw right into the battlefield
as they've done there with the death
nail effect. So when it does when it is
removed from play when it dies, you get
to play two three might mech tokens to
your base.
So it replaces itself and kind of splits
in two and I can move that around and I
can utilize that. It's fantastic. Such a
annoying card to deal with. really irks
them in these situations where you've
got lower powered units at this stage in
the game. Ollie Ollie really doesn't
have the access to the bigger units that
they need right now to deal with
something like that effectively.
>> I thought that was Ollie's hand for a
second. I was like that's four battering
rams I've seen so far. That's not the
best. But no, the the trash slightly
bigger than the hand as of this moment.
Does have a cord shot in hand as well
with Ezreal's static effect. It's going
to be reduced on that second cost. So
only has to tap the seal. It's one into
hand. Next one on the bottom. That Rasa
slowly moving further up and another one
going into hand. A hard bargain selected
there
>> alongside a Rasa. So we are I believe
that that trash looks bigger than 10 to
me for maybe 11 or so. H I wouldn't be
surprised if we start to see the rasers
come out, but we've already seen from
our Kaiser player that they're pretty
good problem size, pretty good at
dealing with these rasers when they do
come down.
>> Going with the stack deck first. Again,
I think that's good. I think sequencing
wise, you want as much knowledge as you
have as you can get before you start
playing cards because you want to be
able to know exactly how much you need
to spend in order to play all of the
things you'd like to play on your turn.
Going for another seal here. were really
seal heavy in this one.
>> Yeah, I guess I'm trying to think about
what I would do in this situation. And I
realize as you have previously said, I
wouldn't be in this situation because
I'm nowhere near. But it's if you play
the Rasa, you're just at such risk of
the first 4Runner just trading into you.
>> Playing the Rasa and then putting the
last rights on it does get it out of
that range, but then a hex tech ray and
a ferris 4runner trades into you really
effectively. You can you can rasa into
reaver's row and then have the option to
uh retreat as soon as you come into a
battle uh like into an actual combat.
But as soon as you put rasa onto a
battlefield, it becomes really tricky.
>> It does. It's literally enemy number
one. That is what your opponent's going
to be going for. It's your highest kind
of might unit and it has the last rights
on potentially as well.
>> Terrifying. And they are going to want
to remove the last rights more than
anything. Accelerated demolitionist
seems to be the option here.
>> Honestly, I like it again. Kind of
churning more into your discard pile.
Accelerate just for that extra boost.
And yeah, Jinx Demolitionist not a card
I thought I'd see today and I'm not
upset about it.
>> No, it's also the alternate art. This is
very cool. The additional cost will be
reduced for the accelerate from the uh
the Ezreal static effect. So, we're not
going to have to pay that full one extra
energy and power. I assume you know you
reduce the power side of it because that
makes a lot more sense if you are
playing into it.
>> And uh there is the seal tapped. Fizz
getting discarded. And there's the last
race accelerated in to get to the
conquer and then you can bring the fizz
back only having to pay its power cost.
You could also look towards something
like the battering rams. Trying to
remember how many cars we played this
turn. It's definitely a few.
>> Oh yeah. I think it's enough. Uh, but
it's hard to keep track sometimes cuz
these are long turns, but it's because
they're wonderfully convoluted. It's
because they need to be because that's
how you beat Kaiser. You don't have a
choice. And of course, just really well
assessed there going into the Ferris
4Runner going, I'm going to need to deal
with you sooner rather than later.
>> And because it has that assault as well,
it is stronger than the first 4Runner.
If you just look at the last right and
the the Jinx might, you might think,
well, it's a six for six. is not the
best trade, but double mech's going to
come out for problems as the 4Runner
hits the trash.
>> They go into base, so they're not an
immediate threat, but they're going to
come up at some point, maybe next turn.
So, we don't need to worry about them
right now, which is lovely. Last right
stays there safe for now.
>> But we know there's a thousand tail
watcher in bombside hand.
>> We do.
>> And that will take the Jinx down to a
very unimpressive three. And a mech is a
three.
>> It is. Uh Jinx might be not long for the
playmat battling round coming out to
round us off. Still two runes available
for Ollie,
>> but a very low hand size at this point.
And although Jinx is, you know, Jinx can
draw some cards. One more would still
need to be played. Two cards left in
hand. We're really starting to see where
Jinx runs out of steam now. Really
starting to struggle along.
>> Yeah, she needs to get some of that hex
tech.
>> Speed her up a ton. Jay has been
hoarding it
>> apparently. as says Kaiser apparently
gets a hex tech ray. She's from the
void. How has she been making up these
rays? You know, some sort of secretive
society smuggling it into the void.
Belvth at the at the helm.
>> I reckon the porros snatched it for her.
>> Oh, yeah. You think so?
>> That's my story line in my head.
>> Bum is actually this sort of evil
mastermind controlling his porros to get
hex tech for for guys. That makes sense.
>> All all under the guise of these look at
these sweet little guys. They can do
nothing. Look how pouty he is. Okay. I
hate the fact I'm going to make this
reference, but it's like the minions in
Despicable Me. Like, exactly right. But
they're cute, but they're bad.
>> Okay, so here we go on to problem side.
Currently sitting at three points. Not a
player really scoring a ton so far. The
Russa was played at the end. We got a
double ray singularity, a thousand tail
watcher and the progress day sitting in
hand here. Lots of removal. Yeah, lots
of removal. Relatively cheap as well.
Xtech Ray doing three damage to a unit.
We're going to kick that off on the
Ezreal.
>> You know me, I love a bargain. Here we
go. Getting a hectic ra for an Ezreal.
I'm down with that math. And then we're
looking like we're going to go for
something a little little chunkier next.
I don't I didn't see any high costs
apart from the thousand tail watcher.
So, I think I know what's coming.
>> I'm I'm wondering about it as well cuz
you could have just if you're going to
Thousand Tail Watcher.
>> Yes.
>> Why not thousand tail watcher put a mech
into the Ezreal? I mean, he gets
retreated, I guess, from the because of
the Rever's row. So, you don't want to
just give him that safety. Um, yeah.
Okay. I can still see a thousand tail
watch there. This is why these these
players are up there and I'm here
because it takes me that extra 30
seconds, you know? Takes me that extra
little time to think about why I just
like to do the thing. I'll be I've got
this big card. Let's play the big card.
>> Yeah, that's the thing. I That's me too
all over. But here we go with the
singularity actually to take down some
of the units that are just sat pretty in
base right now. actually no threat to
anyone, but problems I sees them as a
threat for next turn. And that is
worthwhile spending to get rid of them
now and try to mitigate the risk of them
coming forward in the future. And now
Jinx is all alone.
>> Yeah. And the problem for the Jinx here
is there's another Hex Gray that will
take her down to three damage marked,
six might in total. So three more damage
needs to be found. And there's a mech.
>> There's there's two mechs.
>> But there's more than enough.
>> You can throw both of them in. You can
just throw one in and then chuck the
other one in afterwards if you so
desire. Still those two runes available.
Yep. Go for the want, go for the trade.
Jinx is dead and the last rights has no
home. A eulogy sung for Jinx
Demolitionist as her hubris has been her
downfall.
>> Absolutely.
>> Unfortunately,
this just might not be enough now with
only two cards in hand. I don't know if
Ollux can bring it back. They're drawing
some cards to just see as it knocks us
hopeful. I can't see much more.
>> Scrap peep.
>> Scrap he peep. We're going to draw the
cards and see if we can get out of here.
Let's keep going.
>> The way these runes are being being
exhausted is not encouraging me in how
how Ollie feels about this right now. An
overzealous fan. A little bit too late.
A hopeful will come out as well. The
last rights can get equipped, but you're
still you don't know there's a thousand
tail watcher, but you can kind of
suspect that there is enough removal in
this Kaiser's hands. You're stuck at
three. All your big tools are in your
trash. Two holds for Problems Eye. One
more turn for Ollie. Looking for that
elusive fifth win. Still just out of his
grasp.
>> Just out of reach unfortunately at the
moment. Problems eye really taking the
stance here. going straight up to seven.
We just need to
>> another watcher
>> this to eight. Another watcher. You've
got to be kidding me. That is absolutely
phenomenal. And you do expect it at this
point. You know, when Kai'Sa gets to
that many runes is exactly what's
coming. You it no one is not expecting
this at this point. It is very kind of
targeted that when Kaiser gets up to
enough runes, you you're going to see
it. You're going to see the Thousand
Tail Watcher.
>> It's the Y2K bug for Ollie. You need to
be cautious.
this double millennium coming in with
these 2,000 tailed watches.
>> Very much so. It is not a good look and
unfortunately I I think it all just
spells disaster here for Ollie. I don't
think they're going to be able to come
back from this at this point. It's not
looking fresh for Jinx. Jinx would
really need to to step it up at this
point. A top deck of what could be a
savior? I just don't know.
>> Well, cuz you don't have any accelerated
units. You have your overzealous fan
that's sitting at four might with the
last rights on it. You have eight might
in total to play with. Right. If we look
through the trash, we see triple
battering ram as far as I remember.
Double rasa or maybe just single rasa.
There will be another rasa coming round
through the deck soon.
>> Sing too late. I think it's too late
now.
>> Yeah. All you need is a singular hold
>> and that's it.
>> But if your problems like how you how
are you bolstering your defense? You're
going to progress day first. Except that
you don't need to win next turn. If you
manage to hold, all power to you. All
power to you. But you don't need to do
it immediately.
>> No, there's no rush right now, which is
a great place to be.
>> Could be a piercing light sort of angle,
though. No,
>> it's a borrowing. Just hold it. Just try
and hold it. Try and hold at least one
of these, right? That's all you need to
do.
>> So patient. I want to see action. I want
to see damage.
>> It's cuz they're good at this game.
>> I know. And that's the problem.
>> Obviously, it's great to watch. teaches
us a lot as we go through it. Couple of
questions coming out from Molly as uh
I'm sure we will get that rectified as
soon as possible. One card in hand does
mean that
>> Loose Cannon Legend will activate,
>> which is a great position to be in for.
But I think that might be it for us. And
Kaiser, Daughter of the Void, overcomes
the rebellious Jinx.
>> Huge, huge for Kaiser in the end. Great
play from Ollie where they could find
the angles, but in the end there's just
a little bit too much power. Too many
rays, too many powers sneaking them out
in terms of the hex tech. Overall, great
performance by Problem Z. And moving on
to 50 and one, one win away from that
elusive sixth that will take them
through to day two.
>> I'm feeling pretty good about my
prediction of Kaiser doing quite well.
I've got to say that I'm feeling quite
good about that. But if you guys want to
hear from the Kaiser Survivor
themselves, we've got them on interview
for you.
>> Welcome back to the round six winners
interview of the regional qualifier in
Bologna here for Riftbound, the first
European major event of the League of
Legends, TCG. And I'm indeed joined by
the winner of last round, Problem Sai.
How are you feeling, man?
>> I am feeling great, thank you. Uh I
didn't think I would get this far, but
uh I'm happy I did, especially against a
couple of these decks that I have never
seen before. Yeah, I mean you just
played versus Jinx Loose Cannon. That's
a pretty interesting choice for a
leader. What were you thinking when you
saw it?
>> Uh I thought it was uh Immortal Phoenix
like play stuff out of the trash removal
deck at the start because that's how it
was played in set one. But as the game
went on, I started to slowly realize
that this was a miracle version of the
deck and I kind of crashed in that first
game. I'm not going to lie. So, when you
saw it was more of a miracle version. Do
you just thought, okay, well, I'm just
going to play it like it was versus
Miracle Draven.
>> I was thinking about that. Yes. But, uh,
I also realized I was really looking for
a moment to plan my progress day, but I
never got to that moment because it was
uh they played Bushwack and went really
fast. Was
>> What was do you think the most pivotal
moment in one of the three games in game
two or three that you won? Uh it was in
game two where he uh start he was at six
points and he put all his units on the
board because the turn before I played a
watcher
and he probably expected that since I
played a watcher so early that I
probably had another watch in my hand.
So he was playing around uh both boards
getting wiped by two watchers.
But uh event I didn't have a watch in my
deck. So I just eventually just removed
one side the weaker side of the board
and then took that over and he couldn't
recover from that.
>> Very nice. I mean I want to talk a
little bit more about your deck list
actually because we have seen Kaisa had
great success over in China as well with
a deck list that has reduced units
drastically. So there was no Darius, no
nothing. Basically only the thousand
health watchers and some two drops.
You're playing a Darius and you're
playing a Ferris forrunner. Why is that?
Well, it's mostly because I expected a
lot of Kai'Sa to show up and in this in
a mirror match up in Kaisa, you really
are dependent on those bodies. You
really need to see that your that from
one card they have to throw out at least
two cards or like more cards so you
outvalue them. That's why I decide to
add uh Ferris for
the deck currently runs not a lot of
accelerate units. So against Kaiser
matchup, you need to score that point
fast. So I run the Darius to get that
point and when they all out and they
have to like spend more.
>> Did you play a lot of Kaiser Mirror so
far?
>> Uh I played a bit in uh at the start of
set one. Uh but I eventually switched to
a set so I didn't I didn't I played
Kaiser for like two weeks and then the
week before this event I also played
Kaiso. And in this tournament, did you
play Samos or not yet so far?
>> Uh, I only played Kaiser in this
tournament. So,
>> all right. Okay. Thank you so much,
Problem Z, for this interview for taking
the time. The tournament is continuing.
It's going on rapidly. So, we're going
back to the live coverage and round
seven soon.
>> It's going on rapidly according to Leo.
And I have my wire in front of our That
was unprofessional. Medic, I'm so sorry,
medic. I apologize. I apologize. We are
here for round six, feature match two.
We're going to jump into game three
between Darius and
>> Draven, the brothers of Noxus.
>> The blood brothers of Noxus.
>> Yeah. Well, are they? They are blood
brothers, aren't they? Actual brothers.
Yeah. And then they like blood.
>> Yeah. So, it's like a double kind of
meaning there. It's great.
>> I mean, I like them. I like I like the
law.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it's fun.
>> Mhm. I like that we've got this tussle
of the brothers against one another and
they have similar style decks to an
extent.
>> That's true. It's a quite a common theme
in League of Legends, the sibling
rivalries. Yasio and Yon are big on it
as well. Morgano and Kale actually very
friendly in their sisterly uh more
lovely rivalry than anything else.
>> That's good. We love to hear that.
>> Uh game I believe this is game three,
but I only see one uh point up at the
top. So, oh, it's game two that we are
jumping into. Draven taking game number
one.
>> Darius, a uh champion legend that we uh
sorry, legend unit we don't see too
often. Uh has legion and one energy. So,
you want to use that for your legion
effects like this noxious hopeful after
playing out the trusty ram hound to kick
things off.
>> Yeah. And certainly as a really strong
point to start the game with. you're
going, "No, not one unit, two units."
>> And honestly, that's a great start from
a deck with a lot of power. And then, of
course, uh, you know, we're going to try
and come back with that. But actually,
this hand is it's looking okay. We've
got the treasure. We got the
overzealous. We're looking good on that.
Ride the wind. Not right now. Kaiser,
not right now, probably. Unless you do
just go for the Kaiser just to get
something big in play. We're actually
going Wow. Okay. Straight in with the
Darius uh champion unit. Yeah, with that
Draven it's going to do a lot of
enemies. The brothers are on the field.
It's hard to I think the what the Draven
does give you is that fury recycling
power, right? The ability to get the
plus twos off it pretty consistently. So
if Marshall here on the Darius does go
in, you have the ability to kind of
outmatch on a lot of the on a lot of
these threats. So trusty ram how it is
giving uh it gives itself plus one for
every friendly unit at the in the area
or is it I think no it's just one unit
yeah if there is a friendly unit with it
gets plus one so it sits at three right
now four for the noxious hopeful and
then the BF sword being played into base
here we'll see if there's a decision to
equip nope just using that legion effect
again to get that noxious hopeful out
>> it certainly is big that sword so it
could do some real damage in this
matchup we Putting the sword somewhere.
>> Oh, we are. Okay.
>> Oh, it's a dog with a sword.
>> I love this.
>> It's a dog with a sword.
>> Best day ever.
>> Yes.
>> I mean, I would be concerned.
>> No, I wouldn't.
>> I would be very like,
>> is it holding it in its mouth?
>> Mouth. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah. And then, but like when it
comes when it comes up to give you a
lick.
>> Nah. Sword.
>> Yeah, that's the problem.
>> No sword.
>> Okay.
>> He's in a battlefield, my guy.
>> I mean, that is true. But what about if
I'm like, "Hey, come give me a snuggle.
We finished the battle."
>> That That's at the end of the day. This
is mid battle cosmetic.
>> Come on. Also, this ramhound is massive,
by the way. Have you seen how big it is?
I mean,
>> there's a person riding it in the art.
>> Oh, that's true. Actually,
>> maybe that is more of a decapitation
angle, though.
>> I mean, that's why it needs the BF
sword. You couldn't give it a long
sword. It's not long enough.
>> It needs a big sword.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Treasure hunters in now. As I
expected earlier,
>> I'm pretty sure the abbreviation is is
big feline sword actually. So, it's not
even in the right species.
>> I knew it.
>> Back to actually what's happening in the
game.
>> It's okay. We got a lot down. We got two
overzealous fan and a treasure hunter
again. Just populating the board. We're
not going into battle yet. We're getting
our army all built up at base and then
we're going to go in later and show our
brother what for.
>> Yeah, we'll see if that Darius Tfarian
does come down at some point. Wouldn't
be surprised if Marshall decides just to
hold on to it. Spectrum Matron, the
rally, the troops, and the forerunner in
hand. Matron bringing back a three or
less energy unit.
>> But it looks like forrunner might just
be used to really make this arena's
greatest battlefield a problem to deal
with. And I'm sure Draven is pretty
miffed that Darius is claiming to be the
arena's greatest.
>> I I think that is quite the story line.
That's the stance. I can hear it now on
the news. Darius taking over. This just
in. This just in. Darius, the agree is
greatest.
>> And Draven will certainly have something
to say about that.
>> Excuse me, sir. I disagree.
Uh the retreats coming out here from the
noxious hopeful and the trusty ram
hound. Second Opal going over to the
obelisk of power just to get you up to
four. These increments of two so
important when you are playing Riftbound
unless you have aspirin's uh climb out
where you're going to nine. But uh being
within two points means a double conquer
gets you there. A holding a conquer gets
you there. Makes it a lot easier for you
to actually crest over the winning
point.
>> It's not just about scoring points. It's
about when to score those points and in
what order. Like a three is an awkward
number in this game. Being stuck on
three points is odd and awkward and not
quite what you want. You kind of want
that flow all the way to eight.
>> Do you find it cool that all of the ones
that you don't really want to be on are
odd?
>> Yeah. like they're odd numbers. That's
odd. That's odd.
>> Wow. Here comes an accelerated Kaiser.
Now looks like we're going for that
aggressive turn going in where there are
lower kind of units on the board and
going to start taking over these
battlefields back into Elmore's court.
>> Yeah, I mean the issue kind of is is if
you go with the Kaiser and some units
into the Noxious Hopeful, uh the Noxious
Hopeful can just defend. This looks like
a blood rush or a spinning axe angle to
me. Kaiser goes into the first 4Runner.
Elmore is going to use that action for a
rebuke. In fact,
>> lovely.
>> Yeah. Bouncing the 4Runner back to hand.
>> All that energy used to cast it.
>> Not really.
Kind of wasted. At least it's not too
much power, you know, just one fury.
>> Double draw coming out from the legend
trigger alongside the Kaiser Conquer
trigger. You have won that combat. Now
Draven's going to meet a hopeful of
Noxus and show just why they shouldn't
be too hopeful.
>> Yeah, Shoo's boss. Make sure that we're
getting more card draw as we take over
more combats, winning combats. It's
exactly what Draven wants to do. Want to
make sure that we're keeping up with
that. We get a gold token and draw a
card. It honestly couldn't get much
better than that.
>> Yeah, I agree. I'm going to very
slightly sidebar here for a second.
>> Look at the Draven Vanquisher. Yeah,
>> on that battlefield.
>> And tell me that his face upside down
doesn't still look like a face.
>> It does a little bit.
>> Have you got like the smile at the
bottom and a big bushy beard?
>> Yeah, I kind of see it. Yeah. No, I get
you. It does look like that on that art
at like at this moment.
>> I think so. Cuz where the dye is, the
shadow makes it look a bit like he's got
a throw. It does, you know.
>> It does a little bit.
>> Anyway, back to reality.
>> Okay, we're back. Overzealous
fan. Yeah. Gonna I think this is smart.
Put them in.
>> A fan for you and a fan for you.
>> Yeah,
>> they're great. They're dispos. I mean
fans.
>> Fans are disposable. Just joking.
>> Quick, go to Go to your social medias.
>> Fans are disposable. You heard it here
first. But it does make sense cuz they
are in this game.
>> In this game, when they just kill them
off, you bounce.
>> They don't They don't treat them very
well, these lads, do they? They do not.
Darius and Joan just like, "No, no."
>> Yeah. No need for any any true fans
here. I'm just going to get rid of you
anyway.
>> No, they just want the originals.
They're all about themselves, these
guys. And that's exactly kind of how
their mechanics work, too. And that's
kind of why I like that it's very
thematic.
>> Um I'd be tempted here to put the ferris
4runner back into play. I'm not going to
lie to you.
>> It just nothing else is feeling great
right now. I feel like you want to get
units on the board and you want that to
be a bit more of a stronghold situation.
>> Yeah. Going with the rally the troops
instead. When a friendly unit is played
this turn, you get to buff it. You also
get to draw a card. Play it out for two.
>> I think we're just trying for the draw
there more than anything cuz the hand is
just looking a little bit damp right
now.
>> There's also the option of playing out
the Darius comes in at eight because
it's ready.
>> Looks like that's happening. Maybe
>> that's only four. That was four.
>> Oh, four and uh hand of Noxus five cuz
it's got the legion effect. There's the
recycle. There's the Darius. will come
out buffed at eight might in total. Now
can attack with uh the noxious hopeful
towards the Kaiser battlefield. Even if
the Darius gets backed out, the noxious
hopeful still trades with the Kaiser at
four m a piece.
>> And then we've kind of dealt with that
threat of the hold and taking Elmore to
the four and then the five points.
Elmore's kind of fine here going to four
though, not five
>> as we spoke about earlier with that kind
of that nice curve of point taking. Uh
we're going all in. Okay.
>> Okay. Not taking the Kaiso battle build.
Going for the uh going for the obelisk
of power here.
>> Power. Yeah. So, it's an interesting one
cuz the Draven on defense can buff
itself. There's two fury runes. So, you
can get that Draven up to eight. The
Overzel fan. The expectation is you
bounce the Darius back and then you're
dealing into six and four, which is 10,
but you can take out the uh trusty Ram
Hound if you so desire.
>> That's a tough situation. I'm not sure
what I would do in this situation. I'm
not sure how I would react to that cuz I
that was unexpected.
>> Yeah,
>> I feel and I feel like that's a lot of
strength in that as well. Marshall
bringing unexpected plays, kind of
throwing your opponent off, doing things
that they weren't kind of
>> expecting. They they weren't thinking
that that was going to be the case. They
were thinking, okay, they're probably
going to go for my Kaiser. And actually
going onto the Obliska power here.
They've got a plan. Yeah, it seems to be
working over. Zealous fan is going to
bounce the Darius. No real surprises
there. That trusty Ramad still buffed up
by one might because there's a hopeful
alongside it.
>> And then I suppose it's whether you
>> do you buff.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you go to six on the Draven to kill
off the ramhound or do you just accept
the trade with a noxious hopeful?
>> Right. And the ramhound is good but then
also the the gear stays in play, right?
Whereas the hopeful is always going to
be Fortnite.
>> I agree with that. It does mean that you
make a marshall have to recycle an
order.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah. Which is interesting. Oh, we're
back to us for a second as there was a
judge called
>> forcing the spend of resources. We've
we've shown so many times already today
how powerful that is.
>> But you are spending a resource to make
your opponent spend a resource. And it's
like how how valuable is that, you know?
Oh, who knows? Oh, we're coming back.
>> All right. So, yeah, it's just going to
trade into Nox. for not going to have
the Ramound traded into does reduce the
Ramhound's might because of the fact uh
that it no longer has a unit by it side.
It's kind of the anti- lonely porro
needs things by its side to uh actually
be stronger.
>> He needs friends. And again, I think
that's why I like taking out the hopeful
as well is because you do then reduce um
the hounds power anyway
and start to chip away at at those
defenses.
>> Whole point for Elmore gets them to
four. Marshall is at five as far as I
can see and can remember. Yeah, it's
going to tick up right now. Haven't had
a a good look at Elmore's hand in a
little while, but still in a solid
position. One point behind around now
isn't the end of the world for a Draven
deck. You have so many tools at your
disposal. We haven't seen the the
spinning axes. We haven't seen many
rebukes. We haven't seen
>> one of those. We haven't seen a falling
star.
>> And we're going for the double target
there on the Yep. on the base. So that
threat is already dealt with before it
could even really come into fruition.
They managed to bounce it back and then
go, "Okay, now I'm going to falling
star. I don't really want to deal with
you, brother. Please go away."
>> Mhm. Damage of their own in hand, it
seems for Elmore. Another falling star
is going to kill off the ramhound.
>> The rough.
>> Hey, very good.
>> Oh dear. What you like? Okay, we're
going for a treasure hunter there.
Straight on in again. taking back that
battlefield and Marshall kind of doesn't
really have anything on board. So, can
they bring it back from this position?
Elmore was seemingly in a similar
position, but actually again, there's so
many accelerate units. There was enough
in base to make this happen. And now
it's just a do I retreat Kaiser to keep
him safe.
>> Yeah, make sure that you have that extra
degree of safety of being in the base.
Have these order runes all lined up for
Marshall. I'm pretty sure this is going
to be double fury with uh the spread.
>> We certainly need that right now. Ferris
4runner
>> doubleunner double matron and a brin
here. Thundersoft. What can we bring
back with the matron in this sort of
position?
>> There's not a huge amount of options.
Ram hound
>> is cheap enough to be uh brought back to
life. Noxious hopeful too expensive. So
usually you are looking at things like
the Shinsha if you want to recur or
Vanguard Captain as well can be pretty
powerful. Gets you that extra might.
>> We just haven't seen them. That's just
been luck of the draw at this instance.
>> That's just the way it works. Just the
way it works. It is going to be the Ram
Hound back with that spectral matron
will get that buff from having a
friendly unit in the area.
Do you do you do you do you? Well, you
can't forrunner anymore. You're not
going to equip the ramhound either with
that BF sword. We're going to have
Elmore go to seven and it's all going to
be down to two marshals next turn. Not a
huge amount of runes available for our
glorious execution to hit Elmore on the
Draven.
>> Do we need them?
>> I don't think so.
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> We have Oh, we don't have enough for
another falling star, but we do have the
gold. So, we're okay in terms of getting
the double furies.
>> We've got Kaiser in base. We've got two
battlefields. Both in control right now.
Both were low might units, but it might
kind of be worth just stacking one of
them up, bringing another back and then
trying for the eight next turn or just
going going for it and just saying I'm
going to hold here and if you can't do
much about it, then that's game.
>> We have a tie turner in hand as well. So
I'm wondering if there's an argument to
hide a tie turner somewhere.
>> I like that.
>> And then I'm trying to think where do
you just go on the overzealous fan?
playing the overzealous fan up towards
this obelisk of power. You could tie
turn a hidden at the top side.
>> That might just give us enough
protection to to see this turn through.
There's only two threats on board right
now that Elmo kind of knows of.
>> So the reason I like Titan here is you
already have the Overz fan to bounce
something on the bottom side here. You
can tie bring the Kaiser in sackly
overzealous fan and then bounce
whatever's coming in. And the Kaiser has
four might so we'll beat or at least
equalize the spectral matron will beat
the ramhound by itself. Although the
ramhound I expect unless we get an
accelerate unit which I'm pretty sure we
can't is going to be equipped with that
BF sword. So
>> really nice position here for Elmore on
this Draven.
>> A great position to be in a very strong
stance and I I think the writing's on
the wall here. I don't think that we're
going to be able to bring this back, but
I could well be proved wrong because,
you know, this is a very reputable kind
of space to be in in regards to the
tournament at this stage. We are far
into the tournament and both of these
decks are doing really well. So, if
there's a way out of this situation, I'm
sure they're going to be able to piece
it together. But right now it's just
pondering about whether that's even
going to be possible cuz I think
especially with that hidden card. It
just gives that extra level of thought
of the oh
>> could be a final flight could be a
switcheroo could be a tie turner.
There's a lot of different options
there. Bin here is going to come down
early which would stop the reaction from
Elmore with this titer. Needs to do it
now if they're going to play it. Also
has the ride the wind in hand. Only
needs to hold one battlefield. remember
currently has their forces spread out a
little bit. There's an argument to crack
out
>> the Kaiser on towards the top
battlefield, ride the wind, the
overzealous fan over, have the ability
to double kill uh the overzealous fans
and bounce two units back at the same
time
>> cuz that's not playing great in this.
>> Draven is just great on social media. I
I'm going to say he has a great public
image. Darius is probably more
hardworking, has conquered more
battlefields, has done more stuff across
the course of his career, but Draymond's
like, "Hey guys, cheer for me, please."
And then the overzealous fans are there.
>> They're just there.
>> Social Andes, I said.
>> So, we're going for the activation there
because I mean, you kind of have to. I
think you're forced into it a bit.
>> I mean, you don't have to have the TI
Turner swap positions with anything.
It's a may trigger.
>> So, it comes in exhausted. Yeah. It
looks like we're just going to have the
TI turner there as a extra defender on
the arena's greatest battlefield.
>> Just another unit to put a little bit
more might over there. It's not doing
much else, but it's something. And that
is often better than nothing.
>> That it is. That it is. Marshall needs
to take over both of these battlefields.
They're the equip on the Ram Hound.
I just don't know how it's too possible.
You go in with the Ram Hound down
towards this bottom side. It gets
bounced by an overzealous fan. You go in
with the Ram Hound up towards the top
side. It gets bounced by an overzealous
fan.
>> You don't have enough runes for a
Darius.
>> No, it's not possible. Like, it's just
not possible at this point. You're
getting bounced.
>> There it is.
>> Straight back. Recall to home.
>> And
>> I think it's just Dunzo.
>> I think that is Dunanzo. I don't think
there's a lot more we can do. I mean, we
can take it though. That's it. GG.
Elmore taking it in. getting that
glorious executioner name to its peak.
>> There are a lot of gloriouses when it
comes to rift man. Great play by Elmore
by the way. Uh really good stuff overall
on the on the Draven, but you've got a
glorious evolution. You've got the
glorious executioner.
>> Y
>> there's probably other ones
>> probably
>> in glorious inexels day. Um
>> we got some glorious, isn't it? Yeah.
No, honestly, that was a fantastic game
to behold and I'm really interested to
see kind of how that's going to go on
throughout today, whether we'll see more
Darius, whether that's kind of whether
they're going for a best of. I think
that's a very strong place to be in.
When we had a little look at the kind of
meta breakdown earlier, we saw there
weren't a lot of Darius players. So, I
think that
>> this match score is going to be very
well placed to go for that best off
price.
>> Yeah, getting into day two is huge for
your best off, right? It's not going to
be a huge amount of players that do it,
especially when you're playing a deck
that has 50 or less participants here in
the regional qualifier in Bologna. We're
going to take a short break, I believe,
before we get into round seven of the
day. Two rounds left. Don't you dare go
anywhere.
Hi guys, welcome back. I am so blessed
to be with Dave, one of the game
designers of Riftbound. Dave, how are we
feeling about the colossal size of this
event as the first in Europe?
>> I mean, it's great. Honestly, I I know
like in my heart and intellectually that
like, yeah, TCGs are huge in Europe and
players here love it, but it's a whole
different experience to be here and see
the enormous passion that everyone has
for it. It's really cool.
>> I think that must be like your baby
coming to life. you see spring in front
of you.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I wasn't the only
designer of Riftbound, but I did run the
team and I and it is really awesome to
kind of finally see players kind of
playing with their strategies, kind of
making them their own. It's really cool.
>> Was there anything in particular that
you were surprised about when you came
into this event originally? Um
I think not necessarily surprised but I
think like maybe maybe pleasantly
surprised if you were to put it of like
just seeing the diversity of what
everyone has come to play with right I
think sometimes I get nervous you know
we can't predict everything and it's
like oh is everything going to be a
single deck right like is it going to be
all Draven or something and I do think
that there was some risk coming into
this tournament that that was the case
and what I'm seeing in side events and
even in the main event just like people
getting excited to play their own legend
the one that they have a lot of
experience with and and still being
competitive with them and I think that's
really awesome
>> and I think that's a sign of a really
welldesigned game that is something that
has been so at the forefront of rift
bound and something that has been so
celebrated by players and you can feel
it in the room today. Not everyone has
chosen a champion that is expected to do
well. They've chosen their favorite
champion. I think you've done such a
great job you and the team of bringing
that to life.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> So with Draven being like I say a bit of
a concern for the meta,
>> right? Public enemy number one perhaps.
>> Right. Uh, was it something that coming
into this event you you kind of did
think to yourself, oh, is that going to
be a problem? Or did you expect people
to go against the grain and go, "No, I'm
going to solve this."
>> Yeah, I think, you know, there there's
so many different kinds of people who
play TCGs, and it's really awesome to
see that also being true in Riftbound.
So, there's people who are like, well,
I'm just going to play the best deck,
and there's people like, well, I'll
never play the best deck. I want to beat
the best deck. And I think we do have
that in our audience, too. Um, I think
that, you know, I was a little bit
nervous, especially with like the
tournaments happening in China prior to
this event, that, um, hey, maybe
there'll be some runaway success with
some version of the, you know, the
builds. But, um, yeah, I think that
players are finding ways to attack it.
And I do think that because you see
different people with that different
outlook, you get a lot of diversity.
Plus, like the best of prizes help kind
of direct people in different directions
than they might otherwise do. So, all
that is coming together, I think, in a
good way.
>> I think it's really harmonious. that's
worked together with the theme of
Riftbound as well with having these
champions. They're all there for a
reason and they're all great in their
own right and I love that we get to
celebrate that together as people who
have never played TCGs to very coveted
TCGs in other games have all come
together in a hall that is packed and
more people would be here if they could.
>> Yeah, honestly that's true. I think uh
we're we're very grateful that Rift is
so popular, but I think the the kind of
flip side of that is yeah, there's like
way more demand than seats that we have
at the table. Um you know, I think
that's something that we'll probably be
able to make some improvements on over
time, but you know, I think the c over
the course of this next year, it'll be a
question of hey, how how big is this
competitive scene going to get? You
know, how much do we want to make sure
we support the people who are coming
just play and have fun and maybe like
meet new groups and new communities. So
all of that is like big factors moving
into the next few events.
>> That's absolutely spectacular. I'm so
glad to hear. Uh have you got a really
good feeling about the future of
Riftbound when it comes to these events
and the scale that we're going to be
able to get to?
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean, we're still,
you know, it's funny. Riftbound's still
kind of in its infancy, right? The game
just came out basically less than a year
ago. And so we're seeing now with these
regional qualifiers is like the only
place to play at a high level other than
a few kind of third party events. And I
think as we start to introduce the
regional championships and eventually
worlds and bigger and bigger third party
tournaments, you'll see I think a much
richer um and healthier ecosystem that
is still developing right now, I think.
So there's a lot I think it's been going
well so far. There are challenges and I
think we're approaching them in a
reasonable way. And then I think there's
a lot of a lot of distance to still
travel there.
>> Well, I'm so excited for all of the
events to come. We've got a bunch of
sets as well that we're ready for as
well and that a lot of people are
already really excited for. But I barely
feel like we've touched on Spirit Forge.
I think there are a lot of decks even in
this room maybe that people will not
expect to see but actually could do
really really well in this event.
>> Yeah, agreed. I think um I've seen a few
builds of Rexi that I think are really
interesting. I've seen a few Lucian and
Aurelia and Azer builds that I think are
you know sort of like tuned in ways to
maybe deal with the meta that's
expected. I think Ezreal is still a
little bit of an underdog. So, I
definitely see that turning out. And
then, you know, there's still some set
one, you know, Origins Legends and
Legends that I think are still quite
strong, especially with the new
additions for Forge. There's a lot of
equipment that slots quite nicely into
decks like E or decks like Annie. So,
>> we have so many more surprises to come.
Thank you, Dave, for joining us. It's
been a pleasure and I hope you enjoy the
rest of the day and the thrills and
spills that come from this event.
>> I am very excited to see what happens.
>> Amazing. We'll see you guys in a moment.
Always always love hearing from Dave and
of course Amy as well. Great interview.
Uh James Li joined by Leonard Kunik. I'm
gonna keep saying it. Uh here for the
last round for us of the day. It's not
the last round of the day. I think
that's really important to to state. We
still got two rounds of play left. Uh
but this as we go into our next round is
an important one because this is the
time where a lot of players will start
locking up their qualification for
tomorrow. So to to run you through that,
it is going to be that threshold of
getting above six wins. six wins is uh
18 points. So as soon as you cross that
threshold, you are guaranteed for the
next day. However, obviously everybody
wants to go eight and zero. That's that
would be the perfect thing going into
day two.
>> I mean eight and zero. Yeah, you're
>> sometimes you would say you have top cut
almost locked in, but there is going to
be a bunch of rounds of Swiss as well.
So you're not quite there yet. Of
course, starting 80 would be a sublime
start
>> and we're not quite there yet for
getting into game. We want to touch a
little bit on some of our uh discussions
we had coming into the event with Spirit
Forge changing uh the meta a little bit
on our predictions, but this version was
actually outside of predictions for us.
This was where we were looking at what
are our cards and combos that we like
from the set. I like the combo you
picked of pick crew and call, but we
haven't seen it at all today from our
games on the feature match at least.
Yeah, right. It seems to not have
performed so far as well. Walking
through the top tables, there was very
few Ezreal, I want to say as well. But
pit crew and KH basically is a
combination to play around the Draven
glorious execution ability, right? So
you are scoring points, you get gold
gear tokens. You ready the pit crew
again because of the call because you
got a gear and then you can just push it
back. You're never going into combat and
you're always trying to score free
points and then remove some other cards
from the Draven. And that is versus the
best deck in the form, a combination to
starve out that deck from draws.
Meanwhile, I wasn't expecting to see Vex
outside of a sideboard, and somehow we
saw a main board earlier today, which I
was quite happy to see. Fizz, I think,
has been a staple uh just on, you know,
recurring spells from the graveyard. Um,
these two necessarily don't have the
best synergy together, but purple is so
strong that these are two cards I expect
to see coming in in many of the Chaos
decks. Uh, be sure to share your
favorite combinations coming from,
whether it's Spirit Spirit Forged or
from Origins, uh, on social media with
us. And then this is what we were uh
looking at combinations actually for the
meta and what we thought was going to be
very strong. So I will start with myself
on this one. Um so not necessarily
played together again. Overzealisan I
think is one of the biggest cards that
is going to affect the meta for Draven.
You and I haven't had the the luxury of
casting it today but has been very very
strong. But what we have seen all day in
our matchups is punch first making a big
impact in combat. Yeah, you know, it is
a heavy cost to pay two power, but it's
so flexible when you only have to pay
one energy. So, you keep up one rune
that is ready on the opposing turn. Your
opponent will always have to play around
plus five might at action speed, and
that is not always very easy for me.
I've gone with Guardian Angel and Ezreal
Prodigy. Ezreal Prodigy, of course, is a
card that enables so many people call it
miracle versions of different chaos
iterations of the decks. We've seen
Jinx. We've seen Civer, we've seen
Ezreal, we have seen Draven in miracle
versions and Ezreal is the key component
of that just because cards like Coldshot
gets they get insanely cheaper if you
want to repeat the cost and of course
all of those
>> green decks those K is it?
>> Mhm.
>> Those decks they just guardian angel is
such a key component there. If you take
a side Azir, even Azia runs Guardian
Angel, but there it is not as important.
But something like Ireelia without
guardian angel, I think it would be
unthinkable to play.
>> Yeah, it is a a powerful card at keeping
things alive. And we'll see if our next
players can keep their tournament hopes
alive as we head into our first match of
the round. I believe this is round seven
we are going into. I have lost track of
the day, but I am enjoying a lot of the
rift. Yeah, round seven sounds about
right as our players of course are
looking to get to that coveted spot. I
know we had some 6 and0 players uh
coming out of the last round already and
we have a spicy one today with Rumble
going up against Victor. Uh Rumble
definitely uh in that prize card like
best of prize card bracket I would say
where you could look at performing and
and taking down the tournament but the
mech based play from Rumble has not
really found its place in the meta. you
essentially are just kind of playing
units on a curve and uh then giving them
some synergies with the mechs and then
hoping that you can kind of stay in the
game and and stay later on.
>> I really like this iteration of the deck
because it plays more genuinely good
staple cards for this fury and this mind
colors these domains. It's it's really
really strong. It's looking very good. I
mean, you're not playing too many mechs
as you said before, but you have some
pushes with your mechs. And then we have
this is Victor leader finally.
>> I know you were looking forward to
casting this deck specifically. This
version of Victor, which is not the kill
spell, Victor. You said this one is a
lot more wide board, lots of units
based.
>> It has Zinja in it. One of my favorite
junglers of all time. Zinja is so much
fun to play in League of Legends and of
course also in Riftbound because this
card really gets you going fast. This is
an aggro deck if you want in Rift Bond.
There's very few of those, but you can
just in your first turn
>> always, always, always get at least one
unit. Of course, because of the Victor,
there's a good chance that you're
starting with two units and then on the
next turn, you get your Zen Xiaou in as
well. That is already pushing for so
much. You you are rushing a big board.
You have Kell the weak. So, this card
also stops your opponent from, you know,
chasing you when it comes to the board
state. So, I think this deck can
overwhelm your opponent quite fast. And
the important thing on Zingshow, as you
were kind of alluding to, is uh Zingsha
if you have two units enters ready. So
is able to get onto the battlefield,
conquer uh and get things going early
on. There is a little bit of a finish in
this deck with uh under Titan where it
but the unit the turn it is played um
gives your units plus one might. I think
it's plus two. Plus two, sorry. Yeah.
Yeah, plus two. Undertain really nice
top of the curve for the Victor deck if
you are even playing that card. But also
something that I just really enjoy from
the Victor deck is you play two drops in
that deck. You play cards that you can
play on curve. But with Victor, it's
almost always correct to just start out
with a recruit token. You want to
maximize the value you get from your
leader ability. And we can see it again.
There is going to be another recruit
token. We're coming in with the Zenhao.
You have two units already in your base.
So that means that you can just
absolutely rush into one of the
battlefields. Now the big question is
are you going to push into the Tfarian
war camp? Yes, you are. Well, I would
assume that the other recruit token will
give Valor's layer a visit.
>> It is uh a likely way of you know
getting that clock going.
>> Are we?
>> Yes. Reaching for the recruit. Yeah,
makes sense to go up to
two as uh we looked to pass it.
>> I love Zen Xiao Vigilant because this
card
>> I can tell already
>> it's not only aggressive, right? But it
also has tanks. So if you are using it
to push into a battlefield and you put
some recruits behind it,
>> yeah,
>> your opponent will have to assign the
damage first. It's great.
>> Protect your little ones. That is more
utility than Zinchow has in League of
Legends. As a as a League of Legends
caster, you're seeing Zinchow, you're
always like, well, he's going to do one
thing and that's it and then he's going
to die and that that's the end of the
game. But in Riftbound, he has a second
ability with tank, so is able to to tank
through. But here comes Rumble on
>> to the Vile Moors layer as first time
we're seeing Rumble today. So mechs get
assault. Uh all of your mechs get
assault from the legend ability. Uh, and
then the scrapper version is also going
to give you plus one might.
>> I think the legend ability gives you
defend.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Much better if you're trying to stack up
time in this vile moss layer. However,
when you start stacking up your cards in
the vile mos layer, you are limiting
yourself to this battlefield relatively
fast. I will say,
>> yeah, thank I appreciate the correction.
That is me sitting the other side of the
table. reading fine because Rumble
Hotheaded actually gives you a salt.
>> So there is a
>> good yesterday I played some rumble. I
know my stuff about that.
>> He did. Uh let's not talk about who won
that game in the game that you were
playing. Rumble. I uh I think we should
focus on this game a little bit more cuz
I can save you uh save you some slight
embarrassment on that one, but it's it's
all good. A grip of cards including
death grip at this point. So another you
know card that came in from Spirit
Forge. It's a draw mechanic. It also
allows you to kind of buff up a unit. A
draw mechanic for your opponent though
is uh the hidden blade on the Rumble
just going to say, "Yeah, I'll give you
two cards. That's fine."
>> I don't know. I mean, that's very very
early. I don't really think you have
anything to back this up, right? So,
it's going to be tough to push here.
We're going to just get another token.
So, that means you won't be able to play
your faithful manufacturer of Kouge of
Curve on this turn. I think maybe you're
going for a possible forge of the
future. No, we're going to go cull the
weak. We just call the weak for a
plundering porro. That is a very
aggressive play. Of course, you are
playing an aggro deck. You want to score
more points to get rid of that
battlefield. And honestly, the more I
think of that, the more I like it
because you are assembling points. There
is nothing in the base for Rumble.
Rumble is not exactly known for having
so many mechs that are entering ready,
but
>> this is red. This is Fury. You can go
Kai'Sa. You can accelerate. That's going
to be a good time.
>> Absolutely can. I think uh based on the
list we saw at the beginning, there are
Watchers in this deck as well. So,
there's another you you called a Kaiser.
There is a Kaiser coming down onto the
battlefield. And one thing this deck can
struggle a little bit with the the
standard mech version of Rumble is if
you trade like efficient removal into
it, it kind of just falls over a little
bit. Uh but Kai'Sa definitely changes
that complexion a little now will be
able to uh you know go to the
battlefield look to draw cuz there is a
super fighty coming out.
>> I love this especially because you're
not pushing your Kai'Sa into the vile
mos layer because yes that's a very easy
take there. You're going to get a draw.
It's going to be nice, but in this
situation, you want to be able to
retreat to your Kai'Sa on the next turn
or do some other stuff with it and then
get more draws in the future. I really
love that Clim was able to punish his
opponent for that because honestly, that
was a lot of points that you got from
this play, right? But callulling the
weak a plundering porro, that is not
only dedication,
that is commitment.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's also very bold.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean at this point you
would love to have that cola week back
up.
>> Yeah, you would love to be able to call
the weak the uh the Kaiser from this
situation. Although, you know, if you
don't deal with the power, it wouldn't
actually work for for for the Kaiser
because obviously you do get the the
choice as the as the the player when you
have two units. So,
>> we'll see where our Victor player goes
next.
>> My issue with that play was you were
ahead in points.
>> Yeah,
>> your opponent used a lot of energy and a
lot of cards from hand to put them into
the VMO's layer. Is there a point where
you say, "Okay, I'm going to stick with
the Trafarian War camp, or I'm going to
stack recruits in my base until I find
something like an Imperial Decree to
easily out that Vos Leia because nobody
is rushing me to commit all of these
cards there and to get the
>> fast points because those were not easy
points. Sometimes there's an open
battlefield, you push a recruit, and you
know it's going to get traded away, but
it's an easy point." That was a lot
committed, a lot of runes committed, a
lot of cards from hand committed to just
get rid of those two units that really
did not threaten you that much.
>> Forge of the future comes out as well.
Kimcha had to to to read it. It's also a
card that I always think is a unit
because
the guy, it's just a dude, a very ripped
dude
just coming onto the battlefield and I'm
like, wait, does that have a might? No,
it plays a recruit and you can kill it
to recycle four cards uh from trashes is
the specific wording here. Trashes means
you uh can choose either uh trash pile
to to recycle from.
>> Of course, that is much more useful
versus chaos decks because they tend to
start even milling themselves if not
just cycling through their cards cold
shot.
>> Stops them ringing for quite so uh so
cheap.
>> Exactly. However, you you give them a
bunch of cards back, but I mean, if you
put them on the bottom of the deck, the
card draw gets less Yeah. strong, I want
to say. But, uh, F of the Future really
is I think what the guy is saying on the
card is why am I not a unit? That is
that is I think that's what he's asking.
Very sure about that.
>> Oh, I I wish I could tell you. I wish I
could tell you, man.
>> See, and now I mean, yes, we got to hold
with a recruit, which is good. But you
Oh, wow. Are are we trying to do it in I
think we do it at base layer, right? You
>> Oh, no.
>> We just get rid of everything.
>> Yeah, you get everything from the
backline with the repeat and uh
>> but you can't hold. There's no way you
let your opponent hold to six. I would
say Ferris 4runner is played somewhere.
I I don't know where exactly the Ferris
4Runner is being played, but it is
surely somewhere.
>> Yeah, I think they're uh defining
>> that does. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Now I
>> Yeah, now I can see the clarity on that.
>> I do like Bellow's brething the entire
back line,
>> right?
>> Big fan of that now considering that
otherwise if you take care of the
recruit token, your opponent is just
going to be able to conquer with the
faithful manufacturer.
>> So you just have the moment to retreat
there with the Kaiser as well and give
no punish for your opponent to bring in
a ready unit and then just take that
point as well. It's a bit greedy if
there is something that can accelerate.
you're getting punished. But I think we
are at only seven runes because of that
called a weak play. Yeah,
>> only one mine run. So you don't even
have to play around and watch
>> and you don't necessarily have the
payoff here for that under Titan. I
believe there is one in hand. So seal
gets played.
>> Good old seal of unity.
>> Yeah,
combos with that Victor ability so well.
You just get to spend the rune. Okay,
now I'll now I'll recycle it. Get a
seal. Play a card. play Victor the uh
leader.
>> Yeah.
>> On to the base in Origins. I feel like
there was a lot of discussion around
like, well, you never really end up
playing Victor to to a a battlefield at
almost any point. And some some people
were like, well, I don't really even
play Victor cuz he doesn't do a whole
lot sometimes.
>> Barely ever used that card when I was
playing Victor. However, you need to
time your turns a lot when you want to
play the Victor leader because if you
want to invest so much energy and power,
then you will have to get the maximum
payoff of it. And I think now
>> he's a vanilla, right? You don't have
anything else except for recruits.
Ferris for is going to take another one.
Now Rumble is I think Rumble is way
ahead in this matchup. It looked so good
for Victor in the start. Got so many
points but ran out of steam. And here's
where some of the difficulty comes from
uh playing against a ferris 4runner is
if you deal WITH IT ONCE, OH, IF YOU
DEAL WITH it once, you got to deal with
the other one on the other battlefield.
And again, it it replaces itself with
effectively the same amount of might. So
when Ferris 400 dies, the death nail
effect will kick in. You'll get two
three might unit. So actually ends up in
Rumble being better because both will
get any buffs that you have applying to
mess. But now we're getting extremely
close to the end game. I think this is
this is the end game now, right? So we
have Chacho on the other side who's
already at six, so just needs a double
conquer versus Climchure who is at five.
So if you let Cler hold here
>> while you're setting up your base, you
lose nothing from it.
>> It doesn't matter if you're if your
opponent is at six, doesn't matter if
they're at seven, they just can't go to
eight. So that's
>> still a turn to chill. What I think you
really need because that's a very sticky
field there that Klin Ker has. Yeah.
>> You need Imperial Decree.
>> Yeah.
>> And you need so many more units in your
base to clear off those units because
the mechs will spawn in base. You play
the mech tokens into the base. They're
going to be absolutely useless on the
turn in which you double conquer.
>> Right. If you just clear those fields, I
think you lose 100% because that's going
to be 12 might in base just from death.
I I'm I'm trying to figure out I'm
trying to remember whether there are any
time warps in this deck uh from the deck
list that we saw at the front. It's not
in one in hand. So, it would have to
come off the off the top for any kind of
other tricky way into to winning this
matchup because is there a world where
you conquer one like take out the first
4runner that is on vile moors for
instance in a way and then on next turn
if you had time warp you'd be able to
hold from seven to eight.
>> It's funny that you asked this but I
think in the deck list we saw that only
two mind runes are being played so
>> well they're both there so no you can't.
Yeah, exactly. You can never play. Wow.
I have seen a lot of the uh a lot of the
order runes, but yeah. Okay. I'm
guessing in that case there is no time
war in this deck.
>> You can you can attempt to play a
watcher in this deck, but there's going
to be very few situations where you're
going to accelerate it. Actually,
>> I'm glad you spotted that because I I
wasn't prepared to to count the rune
colors at this point in in the game. I
wasn't tracking it. I wonder whether uh
cuz again closed deck list so uh
Climchshire
>> I guess won't be able like they'll have
to have counted the the rune types that
have been recycled at this point.
>> It comes up so rarely that the rune
types actually matter that
>> but this is one.
>> Yeah, exactly. But people don't really
pay too much attention to it all the
time. I mean of course you're checking
if your opponent resolves all their
cards correctly and play their cost.
>> Of course. Yeah.
>> Victor holding a BF sword is not
something you see every day. We're
playing some AD Victor at this point. Uh
going to I guess the thing is if you
conquer you will take the battlefield
but it's going to get replaced by two
mechs on the back end.
>> Yeah. Do you have a win condition from
this? I mean you can't really do
nothing. But as I said earlier, if your
opponent just holds one battlefield,
they are just in still a sublime
position.
Oh,
wait. What happened now?
>> Was there a a stupify or something?
>> Oh, wait. We have rumble. It's a mech.
>> Yeah. So, it's getting the bonus the
shield. Yeah. And I think that I think
that Chacho also
>> Yeah,
>> kind of miscalculated on that. Not
counting for the defender uh trigger
that will come through and give it plus
one. It looks like you're playing versus
mid-range Kaiser when you're just
looking at the unit. So, I think it's
also very easy to forget that there is
actually a Rumble Legend ability active
in play.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly.
>> I and we talked about it earlier as
well. So, it's it's one of those things
that like you
>> to to give a little bit of benefit of
the doubt when you're in a featured
match area and you kind of like have
something come up and then you lose
track of it, you forget. Even as
casters, we're like, "Yeah, well, we've
talked about it already, so I'm just
gonna forget that and put that in the
back of my mind and not really recognize
it." But that does make this board state
way worse because Victor doesn't see
himself die. So you don't get a recruit
from that. There's no real way of
refilling the board after that other
than to use the legend ability and play
I believe it's an unsung hero under the
recruit. But is that recruit ready?
Because then you have an easy conquer on
the vile moor layer if there is nothing
like a hex tech ray in play.
I think it was I think I'm assuming it
was the one from the previous turn that
was played from the the legend ability.
>> The question is what do you have in your
deck that you could possibly use for a
double conquer turn in the future? Do
you want to keep as many recruits around
as possible to maybe find an Imperial
Decree push in the next few turns. If
you top deck Imperial Decree, you equip
the BF sword to your unsung hero. You
trade into one of the battlefields. So
you take out everything that is in there
because you can spread the damage,
right?
>> And you get the draw two at that point
and then you might actually find other
units that can help you. So I think not
taking the easy point and hoping for
more units to go for an eventual double
conquer in the end game could be the
right choice. This is another one of
these times where when you're on the
even point marker, getting the odd point
of like going from four to five or 6 to
7 is a lot less impactful if you don't
have like time warp in your deck. For
instance, going from six up to seven
points with time warp, very very much a
valid strategy. But when you're here
looking for that double conquer,
sometimes it is better to just save the
resources cuz as you said, it's untap.
If you have Imperial decree, you can
clear out some of the battlefields.
However, multiple units does make
Imperial decree a little bit trickier.
And a singularity will make it even
harder cuz the unsung hero goes, recruit
goes. Now we're down to one unit with
two battlefields held with at least 10
at least without a defender trigger
going on one of them and then another
eight on the other battlefield. I I
don't see a way out of this.
>> How is that legal that this is the best
play in that scenario? Singularity on a
two drop and a recruit. That sounds so
wrong, but it was so right because
otherwise DBF sword equips, you get two
draws, you can find a way back into this
game. Now, Victor is completely starved
out of resources. Climchure on the
Rumble is just sitting there chilling.
Eight mites from two mech tokens. We'll
never forget about that one again with
Rumble.
>> Yeah, no, I'm not going to forget about
that one as uh I mean, I'm looking at
even Yeah. Okay, there. There we go.
Chacho is going to extend the hand for
game number one. I mean, even Watcher
doesn't do it. you can't clear both
battlefields at that point. I don't
think you were able to really get over
the top. That's another thing to to keep
in mind because of the the sequencing
there. You always have to be aware that
watcher will apply the minus first and
then when you go into combat, the
defender uh you know the the additional
might will come from that defender
trigger uh coming through. So you've
always got to account for that in your
math
>> problem. Very interesting to see.
>> Did Climshire, I think the name was,
>> count the runes of his opponent because
do they know?
>> If you see that your opponent is on 10
order and two mind, you can almost
always rule out the Watcher, right?
Roger is a theoretical play that could
be played, but I think it's interesting
deck building. If you just include two
mind runes if you play a watcher,
>> you just know that you're going to have
the runes. We're going to find out as we
go through sideboarding and the main
board. And it is uh it has been a day of
uh quite a few different matchups. So uh
trying to hold which victor exactly the
the lineup we have. There is an Imperial
decree in the uh sideboard. I get
>> singularity on two mind runes is wild.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's there. You're just
going to
>> The thing is hey if you need it it's
there. You'll get it. You'll draw it.
>> I think I agree with I agree with like
four mind runes, right? So there's no
watcher in this deck and actually
there's almost no no uh there's really
no way of playing the blue anyway.
>> You play triple seals.
>> Yeah.
>> There is very few chances that you're
actually going to lack order runes in
your deck at some point. And if you're
siding cards like Singularity, I think
you want to have four. I think you want
to at least threaten a Watcher. You want
your opponent to play around cards that
are not there because that is actually
also in riftbound a pretty key part of
your strategy. There is so many
interactions that can be played on any
turn. If you're taking Draven, for
example, I think if your opponent has
two runes open and they're playing
Draven, there is eight different cards
you kind of should play around and you
have to take every single every single
thing into consideration. If you're just
playing two mind runes, there's so many
cards that your opponent can't rule out.
I would not play around Watcher. I would
not play around singularity. Might come
back to bite you after sighting, but
there might also be a dead singularity
in your hand if you do not find your
rune.
>> Ooh, here's the aggro turn potentially
going into uh turn two for Victor. So,
it is an obelisk of power game coming
into this one. So, being able to play
the unsung hero and a recruit in the
first turn is a a nice spot to be in.
>> Do we just start with our rumble hotad?
We just throw it in immediately. By the
way, did you know that with the arena's
greatest, each player scores a point in
the beginning and it doesn't just go to
seven, it goes to eight still?
>> I I'm glad you you had the moment to to
clarify that. Uh
>> oh my,
>> as we'll see uh as this matchup
continues, seeing taking a look at our
Rumble players hand that is a breakneck
mech, which is not a card that I see
very often. Gives them deflect and
ganking. Yep, that is actually quite a
lot and it's a it's a fun card to get
out if you have it, but there's also
quite something that you have to resolve
it.
>> Yes, that was my reaction to
>> I'll be honest. Same. Uh, card
recognition, rally the troops. Okay.
Yeah, of course. Um, we're getting
through. It's been a long day. It's been
a long day at this point. Um, no Zin Sha
at this point. Vanguard Captain. Uh, so
we're getting buffs essentially and you
you get to draw one. So able to just
kind of refill the hand,
>> get a bunch of uh recruits. That's
actually quite nice. At this point,
you're going to stack up quite the board
at this point. You go up to you
basically just added four eight might to
the board very quickly. And here's the
aggro side of things.
>> What a big combo there. That is a lot
already. But again, not starting with
the seal of unity is a bit unfortunate
because in those Victor decks sometimes
in Houston, we saw a different iteration
in set one of the Victor deck where you
>> didn't play seals. You actually wanted
to play more mind runes.
>> But in those seal of unity victor leader
decks, they are so rune hungry. They are
power hungry actually. And if you do not
find the seals, sometimes you're really
on the back foot. Wow, that is
>> that is already something. Hothead and
the Ferris 4runner. No rooms open. So,
if there is a big turn, it's going to
hurt real bad. I guess you're you're
kind of assuming that you're going to
get the crack back on the um when the
when the mechs come back. If our Victor
player ends up, you know, going to
contest, going to conquer, gets another
rally, the troops in hand. if they look
to conquer the battlefield, they're
going to theoretically spend a lot for
it. Although that undertitan, are we at
six runes at this point? I believe.
Yeah, six runes at least. So, you could
just
>> kind of barrel over them in force at
this point with an undertitan and two
recruits that have been buffed.
>> You could conquer that battlefield and
that would fit the game plan he had in
the first game, which is really
committing into getting those points.
Yeah,
>> there is also a world in which you're
chilling a little bit because those you
are far ahead in points, right? You at
four, your opponent is at two at this
point. Still going to eight, don't get
me wrong.
>> But I think that you can just build up
more units on your field. You can maybe
even play a Victor leader. You can set
up a big power turn for the Undert.
Okay, you can get the point, but then
there's going to be two mechs in the
base. Five cards in hand already. So,
it's going to be six. You're going to
lose a lot of people.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a uh a big old
board state at this point. This is uh
faithful manufacturer plus after the
rally the troops. So, everything coming
in is going to get that extra buff. So,
faithful manifactor gets buffed, the
recruit gets buffed. There was a I
believe that we've still got Victor
legend ability to play and we're saying,
"Yeah, let's just stack these out in
front." Uh, it's getting crowded over
here.
>> We're setting up a big under Titan now.
>> Yeah, this is huge.
>> Yeah, we've we've rallied the troops.
So, everything gets buffed that you're
playing now.
>> They're double rally. They're ready.
They They're good
>> actually. Yes. Now you get another Oh,
immediately got it from from the judge
with a buff token was like, I got you.
Also, I really appreciated that we do
not have the Damasian or noxion soldier
tokens anymore for the recruits in
Victor, but we have the actual Glorious
Revolution recruits. Love it. That's
very important to me. They came marching
straight out of the set of Arcane.
There's a lot of actors on on this stage
for for the recruits. This is uh going
to be an interesting board state to keep
a track of as we've got an empty board
basically for Rumble against an entire
army marching towards
>> five battlefield seven.
>> Do the math.
>> So we have the faithful manufacturer
which is at two. So that would be eight.
>> And it got a buff so it's at three.
>> Yeah. The the buffs I'm going to add
later.
>> Okay.
>> Vard captain should be 10. So we're
adding six buffs which would be 16 might
in total. That might be completely
wrong. I'm just going to count again. 1
3 5 7
10 12 16. Oh my goodness.
>> I would say use the pen, but I I don't
want to break the stream when I do it.
But uh
>> that is a lot of might coming through.
>> It's 16 actually. Got it.
>> It's a lot.
>> And now
>> is that with or without the under Titan?
>> Without the Undert.
>> Without the Undert. So then you add the
Undertitan on on top of it. And uh
>> don't get me started on counting again.
I can't
>> I should get the abacus out. Start
moving the beads.
>> I I cannot be asked to to count this
again. But we have
a big undertitan turn ahead of us. Of
course,
>> seal right when you don't need it
anymore.
>> The thing is I would still like to see
an Imperial Decree because oh my
goodness, it's double seal. Of course,
this card it's just always there when
you don't need it anymore. You're
absolutely right about that. I think if
you had an Imperial Decree, you would
rather like to trade away with those two
units, get those mechs into the base and
then later on run over them again.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> If you're shoving recruits in that
battlefield, you're going to get a
decent trade. It's going to be nice.
It's going to be feel great because of
the value you're getting. But then
again, you're losing so many recruits.
They are valuable. We don't trade lives
here.
>> The the buff the buff tokens got to go
with it.
I think that's the unbuffed. Wait, the
buff token.
>> That's what I mean. I think it's a a
recruit token with a buff token under it
and a recruit token under that and a
buff token under that. I think I think
>> there was one recruit without a buff.
>> See, it is. Take the move the buff with
it. That's got to go.
>> There. There was one token without a
buff. I think
>> there it is. Move. Okay, good. We picked
the right.
>> Nice. I really like that Chacho says,
"Hey, you know what? It looks like it
doesn't matter. It does.
>> It does. It does matter. That that's the
point." And uh to to prove it, we we'll
keep it here with the buff token in. I
will move the recruit that didn't have
one specifically.
>> I really appreciate Chachu's patience in
this game because in the last one, it
felt like he was rushing things. There
was this called a weak stopped him from
ramping onto a plundering boro did not
do what it was supposed to do in the
end. And now I think he's just waiting
with the under titan. This big push to
get the double conquer because if you
kill a Ferris 4runner, there's basically
just another one. And actually with
Rumble Hothead,
>> they're more threatening than just the
Ferris 4unner.
>> That's true cuz you get that additional
additional activation on the two units
rather than the one
>> one extra might. Oh, I think we might be
going for an under Titan play here.
There's you have vengeance.
>> You can play another seals. Okay. All
right. Well, maybe you were just setting
up.
>> Just chilling. We're just just chilling.
Vengeance could also be a play here just
to be a little bit more efficient, a
little bit more on your curve because if
you want to go for the big undertitan
push.
>> Yeah,
>> actually I kind of dig that if you're
taking out the Ferris 4runner,
>> there's just the five might rumble
hotad.
>> Yeah, I was going to ask where the
vengeance goes. Do you do you do it on
the 4Runner now and then take the
battlefield underneath it?
>> Yeah, I'd say you go into the first
4Runner. You know your opponent doesn't
have too much. have to be wary of the
signature spell of Rumble that costs one
energy and one power as well. But you're
going to look at some cards here because
you know a mech was played
and I think that now you can just go
what do you use? You take the Vanguard
Captain I'm pretty sure because you
don't want to use multiple of your
units. Even though on its own it has the
highest might, it is one of many and
you'd rather lose. I I guess moving two
is not the end of the world. It depends
on whether I mean we know there's a
stupify enhance. So you you don't want
to trade badly on that. Uh
>> I I think you need to push at least a
recruit token and the vanguard captain
because otherwise you also don't get
over the rumble hot because it's
defender.
>> So if you go with just the one unit, you
are running into superf. And here we go.
It is going to be the uh the two units
moving. Yeah. It's going to ensure that
that battlefield does get conquered.
>> Yeah. And that also plays around the
signature spell which gives one might to
each mech.
>> So I I really like that because you're
going to end up with a faithful
manufacturer. It can be traded away
later on, but you're not wasting
recruits on this. And it seems like we
have played our Victor leader that is
going to give us more recruit tokens. So
we're basically trading one for one
here. Because honestly at this point it
doesn't really matter if you have a
Vanguard captain or a token. You just
want to undertaker everything and gen
undertitan. Sorry.
>> It's okay. The Undertaker can be here.
Somebody hit the gong. Uh the lights
will go out.
>> Those of you that get that reference
will appreciate it. But uh those of you
that are looking for Undertitan, it'll
be very different and you'll just get
plus two to all might uh might to all
units.
>> In my opinion, that's better.
>> The board. Okay, that's fair. I I
appreciate that. Going up to six points
though uh in order to hold both means
>> Pincha has to put something to contest
both battlefields this turn just to make
sure that you actually keep that. But
the reality is I'm trying to look at a
line where you're sitting on the rumble
side of things and you actually can hold
through what you're assuming is an
undertitan turn cuz that is a massive
amount of damage on the next turn coming
from Victor. I like how aggressive decks
in Rift Bomb play completely different
from other TCGs where it's not only like
going for face or turning cards
sideways, but you're actually preparing
for big turns while you score early
points. And it can be so frustrating to
play against an aggressive Victor deck
because you can get your points. You can
conquer back, but you know what's coming
and you might not be able to stop it.
>> I just want to clarify something on
stream that that did just happen for
especially newer players that may be
unfamiliar because there's a Victor
leader on stream. Uh technically what
was happening and the players were
shortcutting is um the faithful
manifactor goes to the graveyard with
the recruit token as well. Uh but Chacho
shortcut and just took the token that
was at the battlefield, moved it to the
base as technically a new unit, but just
was shortcutting. He didn't actually
come back to the base. It was u just a
quicker play. Um you'll see a lot of
players do stuff like that.
>> Victor leader is kind of hidden. I would
use that word, but it is a key word. So
it's
>> you don't get to do that. kind of like
so the Victor is buried beneath recruits
which is something that he I think he
digs it.
>> I think he's happy with that.
>> You know who else is digging the
Undertite.
>> I uh I like it. We'll we'll see how that
ends up going. It's one mech and one
rumble. So I mean at a worst case you're
looking at what 246 can get past the
rumble and then 1 2 3 4 plus the Victor
can get through the mech as well.
There's another
Ferris 4Runner. So now it's I mean if
there's anything other than an Underten,
it's probably the best chance that
Rumble is going to have to hold this.
But knowing that the Underten is in hand
makes this a very different situation. I
want to say this is not another Ferris
for honor. It's the same one from before
because when Rumble Hothead conquers,
you can recycle one of your mechs and
then you reduce that energy cost from
the mech you recycle to play out a mech
from your discard.
>> Right. Right. Right. That that makes
sense.
The same one back back again as uh
we go into potentially Oh, and it gets a
call a week as well. Do we have the
runes to play at all? Uh I see seven.
>> I don't think you need to.
>> You don't need to. But is it just adding
insult to injury at that point?
>> Yeah, maybe. I think I think what you do
>> you just undertate under Titan slam it
and get into game three.
>> I think you say, you know what, math is
for defenders. You slam the other Titan,
you let your opponent deal with it.
>> Yeah, math is for defenders at that
point. Um, we can co-opt that phrase.
Math uh math should actually never be
for defenders. As an attacker, you
should always do the math in in this
one.
>> But I like that. I like the thought. I'm
I'm on board. From this position, we can
say math is for defenders. If you're
playing aggro, you have to at least take
some shortcuts in thinking, right?
If you're playing an aggro strategy,
there's there is a there is a specific
reason why you're playing aggro decks.
>> You know, there are games where I would
suggest shortcutting is is is fine. And
it would be like Nexus Knight, maybe a
Summoner Skirmish. Being five and one in
a regional qualifier event where getting
to six wins gets you locked for day two
is probably not the time where I would
shortcut the brain power on figuring out
the math. I would probably take a few of
the 25 minutes that are left just to
just to add it up, make sure it works.
>> That is that is true. We were also of
course only joking here. Chachu is
taking his sweet time with this turn.
Rightfully so. It's a big turn. You have
1 2 3 4 5 six seven
>> also. I mean, you're one down in the
series, right? So, if this doesn't win
you the game,
>> the chances are if Rumble can stabilize,
I mean, you're you're going into the uh
5-2 spot. So it is a significant moment.
Here comes the undertitan.
>> 14 might sweeps across the board and
says, "Yeah, we're getting plus two to
everything."
>> 14 might. That is absolutely incredible.
So you're looking at this. We have
Rumble, of course, the mechanized menace
giving shield to your mechs. So on the
one side in the arena's greatest, which
is I think the smaller defending
battlefield, we have the Rumble Hothead
at five might. And we have a mech token
at four might. So that is nine.
>> I think it's 27
might. I haven't added it up fully, but
it's uh 4 8 12 16 19 22 Victor 25 27 I
think is correct. Is I can't quite
remember. Is Victor 3 or four?
>> Four.
>> Four. Okay. So 28.
We have to pay attention to not think
that this undertitan under Titan is also
attacking because he's currently
basically in the battlefield of aisk of
power. But of course there's so many
unit cards that you need to find a
different place to play this under
Titan. But I think so we need to take
out nine on the arena's greatest. I
think that's the easiest one to do. So
we have two tokens that is four. Then if
you push in the four, then you also want
to push in the Victor leader, I would
say, because that is 11. No, that's
wrong. That is actually only 10.
>> So, how much how much do we have on uh
the arena's greatest, did you say?
>> So, that should be nine.
>> So, we think that that is nine.
>> Yeah.
>> I uh
>> All right. I tried. I was
>> I hope that you guys can see the things
we're drawing right now, but if not,
then
>> too bad.
>> Yeah, I don't want to break everything,
so I I might leave it with that, but uh
yeah, anyway, that's not important. Um
nine on arena's greatest. You can get
past that with essentially the three
recruits. I guess you you kind of have
to play around what is in hand. So,
looking at things, you can kind of
expect a super fight. You don't care so
much about that.
>> I mean,
>> what else do you play about? I do not
think that you're playing the Void
Seeker. Yeah, I was going to say, do you
play around Void Seeker? Probably not.
>> Void Seeker is not the greatest card if
you do not have Kaiser legend ability.
>> So, this is going with another six on
top of that. So, that's 10 14
if the two recruits that are in hand,
they're the ones without buffs. Go onto
Battlefield. So, that would be I I think
the most efficient way to do this is
just take a recruit and Victor because
they together go to 10. And I mean that
would play into stupify, but that would
still I mean it wouldn't play into
double stupify. So I think
>> you always also have to play around
rumble ability, right? So you you do
need to go quite a bit over um just to
make sure you're you're getting past
that break point of like I'm definitely
getting this battlefield.
>> We're pushing multiple recruit tokens. I
thought that was another recruit token
with a buff. So we have 4 8 11 14.
>> Yeah, it's 14. Yeah,
>> that is quite the overkill I want to
mention. And then I just wonder, can he
clear the other battlefield?
>> That's the next question.
>> 48
14. Yeah, cuz 28.
>> Yeah, we could have done that. 28 is is
pretty easily divisible at that point.
>> It would be enough to, but does it play
around so many things?
>> Yeah. What have we got in hand? I think
there was a stupify that,
>> I guess. And I think we have our rumble
signature spell that can be repeated.
So, you're getting full value out of all
of the runes that you are having still
left open. That would be plus two for
every single me. And you can use that on
the first combat, the danger zone. And
we can also, you know, profit from it
from the second one. All right. Danger
zone is
>> danger zone.
>> Everything immediately gets recycled.
>> Will not sing the song because we don't
need to get DMCA.
>> Being hesitant on which runes to
recycle. Almost went for the easy way,
you know, physically of taking two mind
runes, but then decided, hey, I also
want to take a fury rune and own one
mind route. So I'm very well distributed
with those runes. Really like that play.
>> Was danger zone repeated? I didn't quite
catch how much was tapped. So it was
repeated
>> and then a stupify comes out. So
essentially with the with the defense
trigger plus the danger zone that's
going to give the mechs that are
defending plus three plus the stupifier
is going to give minus. So we're really
in the tank on math here. I It's been a
long time since I was in school. So 9
and then you get plus four which is 13
and we had 14 before. No,
>> it was 14 as we had it. So it is going
to be a full trade.
>> Full trading. Yeah.
>> Okay. So that then
>> it could have been worse.
>> It it could have been worse for the
Rumble player. I mean now we get to look
at like what happens on the second half
of this because you can't conquer both
battlefields now as Victor. You don't
>> have the might. And then what does it
leave us with? six plus three plus the
defender triggers plus the extra two
from the might. So it's 8 + 5 13 plus
defender triggers. So 15.
>> Yeah. I I think that Chachu is actually
at a really decent spot here if he just
conquers the arena's greatest.
>> Uh-huh. Because your opponent is going
to hold up to six only. So that is not
gameshot for them. Still have the body
of the under Titan. There is also a
world in which you just do
>> you have to for hold here, put recruits
and the Victor on the the battlefield
and just say, "Okay, we'll try and try
and get onto the things on your turn."
Or is that overkill?
>> I can see that. Uh depends on how
desperate you're getting with the game,
right? Because if there is a
singularity, I think you lose the game
either way.
>> Yeah. And uh next turn would be Watcher
if Rumble's playing. And again, I'm
sorry I can't quite remember the deck
list from the beginning if it were in
there. But anytime I'm playing against
blue, I'm like, "Okay, watcher at eight
is always like a break point to to to
watch four and play around." So, Rumble
goes up to six.
>> Yep.
>> Can't win this turn then. Uh, but needs
to be able to deal with this heavy hold
of uh
>> I mean can basically win right
>> if you are finding the right.
>> There is the watcher. Oh, that is a
watcher. And that is so important
because
there is not a lot of might anymore on
that field. You can take
>> full might now. Yeah,
>> basically everything. And I do not think
that there is anything that can be
played from Chacho. Just basically gives
up all of those cards. Takes the ability
to
>> basically as you said is game. Like I
don't know how Victor with
>> nothing.
>> Like not a lot can actually do this.
Does that mean you get what undertitan?
I singularity doesn't win this for you
cuz it won't get through watcher and the
forerunner and then you give them two
mechs in order to conquer both.
>> You need to conquer both because
otherwise you lose. It's not conquer
both to win. It's conquer both or lose.
>> Yeah, exactly. And again, this is a
match that will qualify one of these
players. And there is the handshake.
Clim will take the series 2 and zero.
goes into the last round of the day
knowing that they're locked for day two
of Swiss with a 6 and1 record so far.
And that looked tense right down to the
last moment where it was like, well,
this this Victor math is going to add up
everything. Is it enough to get over the
line? And it wasn't. Through that danger
zone, through all the defensive triggers
on the Rumble is able to survive.
>> If you're messing with the mech, you're
going to get into the danger zone. This
is this is just what it is. some of
those really niche combat tricks. I
mean, let's be realistic. Many people
for practicing for this tournament, they
have never played versus Rumble. I'm
guessing that some people also don't
even know what Danger Zone does.
>> Yeah, I uh was not expecting to say as
we ended round seven that a Rumble would
be 6 and one. But here we are playing
for potentially now looking for maybe a
tournament placement, not just that best
of Rumble card. But we are going to take
a a few moments before we get into round
eight, the final round of the day to see
who will stay in the tournament for day
two.
Hey, James here with some more players
on the floor in Bolognia. Uh we're
finding out what your favorite champion
to play is, what you're playing at the
event, and your favorite cards from the
deck. So, what are you playing today in
Bolognia?
>> Uh today in Bolognia, I'm playing Fiora.
Uh yeah, is our main deck. Um so, it's
going really good. Yeah.
>> Nice. Nice. Then what's your deck of
choice for today?
>> I'm playing Annie today.
>> Awesome. Awesome. So, favorite Annie
card that you're playing in the deck?
>> My favorite card right now is uh Ranga.
It's a new one from set two. Um and I
like it because I feel like not a lot of
people expect you to play it as a
reaction, especially when you're on the
battlefield. So, when you're holding and
someone tries to come at you and you
play Renga, it's more of a like
surprise. So, people don't expect it as
much. But yeah, that's my favorite right
now.
>> Fair. Fair. And Infura, your favorite
card in your deck? Uh my favorite card
in Fura is the actually champion. Uh so
it's really nice um because I can
actually with the combo we set I can
buff him making out eight and actually
ready him up and actually go into rush.
It's actually a really nice combo and I
think it's going really good.
>> Okay, last question for each of you.
What card do you not like playing
against with your deck?
>> Oh wow. Uh what cards? Um I really don't
like Dven against Draven. So, uh, yeah,
I guess like all the type of like cards
that like have Draven is, uh, is bad.
It's not coming in my mind, but right
now, but yeah.
>> No, that's that's fair. There's a lot of
cards in Draven people don't like. As an
Annie player, what card don't you like
seeing from your opponent?
>> Um, if I'm playing someone with blue, I
hate seeing Singularity. If I'm playing
like Kai Style, Victor is probably my
most annoying because I don't play too
many units. So, yeah.
>> Fair. Fair. Well, good luck in the rest
of your rounds of the tournament and
we'll catch up with you later.
>> Thank you.
>> Welcome back to the caster desk here at
RQ Bologna. I am Medic. I'm joined by
Amy and we are here for the final round
of this wonderful Saturday evening.
>> It's gone so quick. I hope you guys have
joined us for all of the action. Haven't
missed a beat. And if you have, you've
got plenty of time after the broadcast
to go back and re-watch anything so you
don't miss out. Ready for tomorrow.
>> Don't sleep. Don't sleep. Stay up.
>> Stay up until 10:00 a.m. You got to be
here. You got to be there. You got to
watch all the games. I made some good
puns as did Amy. We're great at punning.
>> I'll be really disappointed if you
don't.
>> Yeah. You got to come into Twitch chat,
type YouTube chat, type. Be like, "Oh,
that pun was amazing."
>> Retrospectively.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz I look back at it as well. That's
what we're doing tonight. We're having a
a group cast to watch party and we're
all going to be watching the games.
>> I have my You brought your pajamas, I
think. Yeah. We all have our our snoods
and our onesies and our cool pajamas and
we're going to guess some flavor text
before we get into the next round. Oh
yeah. Yeah. I saw this really cool
onesie actually. You're It's like a You
know those full cover obviously it's a
onesie, right? But it closes like a
blanket and then you get your feet in
and it's got a heating pad. So it's
amazing.
>> Oh wow. Okay. Right.
>> Anyway, fluff is where you make it.
>> Porro, I'm assuming could be forge of
the fluffed.
>> I think it might be because I don't
think any of the porros have that text
cuz I read the porros. They're cute.
What other po? There's the ah the orange
po. The big one
>> that has weapon master.
>> No,
>> I can't remember what po that is. It's
one of the spirit forge ones. Um we
could Do you want to just go forge of
the fluffed?
>> Yeah, I think forge of the fluff.
>> We'll go forge of the fluffed as our
guess for the flavor text.
>> Do you think we've just been debated cuz
it says in it? Yeah, it's poer.
>> It's poer. Fluffed is a group of pros.
We should have known. We should have
known.
>> Poer, not the porros themselves. Yes,
the gentleman that combines all of the
pros into one.
>> Scoops.
>> Um, there's a a magic content creator
who also creates Riftbound content
called Ben. Uh, I can't remember his
name. Never can. Ben Ben. He's on Loing
Ready Run. Ben Engineering is is his
handle. And he thinks Bum is going to be
a pro combiner. So, if you play Bum as
your legend, you can play any pro from
any color.
>> That would be incredible together.
>> I think it would be really cool. And
next flavor text. I've been hiding my
light long enough. Come on. Come on.
This is This is such an obvious one.
Come on. You've got it.
>> My life.
>> Do you want me to do a voice?
>> No. Don't do a voice. Let me think. Let
me think for like 5 seconds.
>> Um
>> I don't know why my my brain wants to go
to like Lux.
>> I mean, because that's a very smart
place for your brain to go.
>> Is it? Is it?
>> I feel this is Lux. I've been hiding my
light long enough. Damasia.
>> That's what I was thinking.
>> It's got to be Lux. There we go. Yeah,
>> I'm really proud of myself for that one.
We haven't seen a Lux full day. So like
>> yeah I
>> not in the forefront of my brain.
>> I love Lux partly because her ultimate
in League used to be called uh finalis
fun which is German for final spark and
it was just such a fun word to say
finalis.
>> Oh that's delicious. That's delicious.
>> Oh this one we do know. Ever looked up
to a yord?
>> Do I know that one?
>> So I can give you hints.
>> I like a hint. Mech.
>> Oh, it's rumble.
>> Is it rumble?
>> No.
>> I see. I I have two in my mind now. And
I think I think it might be rumble, but
it Yeah, it is rumble. Scrapper. Yeah,
there we are.
>> But we read this flavor takes off
yesterday when we were playing the
free-for-all game.
>> We did.
>> Ever looked up to a yolo? It's rumble
scrapper.
>> We did. It was good. I like that deck.
It was fun.
>> Rumbles bot does have a name. I believe
it's birther or something along those
lines. I can't remember exactly now, but
it does have a name. And someone out
there, if you write that name on a
Twitter post, send it to Pumpki.
Spirit forge pack coming your way. If
it's correct, Spirit forge pack. She'll
send one out to you.
>> All right, we got one more.
>> It's always best to have a dog in the
fight.
>> We had the hound in the previous round.
I was thinking trusty man,
>> but but I'm thinking like would the like
it's a it's
>> there are other dogs.
>> It's flavor test. It's not a quote. So,
it's not like the dogs saying it cuz
that would be inappropriate. But
>> yes, cuz that would be
>> Yes, that was really good. I hope no
dogs were listening and got the wrong
idea.
>> Yeah, I may have said something very
inappropriate to dogs. I'm feeling
ramhound cuz it's like it's a big dog
that you have in the fight and it's
always
>> we spoke about the dog with the sword.
We liked the combo and I think I'm I'm
happy to lock that in.
>> Yeah. before. When we've said it
correctly though, they have kind of
already started moving across to it.
What other rat what other dogs do we
have? Always best to have a dog in the
fight. I mean, you could go for Kindred,
but I know she's not in in Spirit
Forged, but you have you have Lamb and
Wolf in Kindred.
>> I get that.
>> Um,
>> I'm not really feeling it though.
>> Nasus and Renekton would be my other
answers if we were League of Legend.
Warwick. Warwick.
>> Warwick.
>> Maybe.
>> Maybe
>> kind of Wolfie.
>> No, it was trusty. WHY DIDN'T YOU CHANGE
IT EARLIER PRODUCTION?
>> You didn't tell us
>> what is this?
>> Do you reckon the chat was also like,
"No, it's it must be something else."
And they maybe had some way better ideas
than us.
>> That's true. I mean, they probably
didn't have better ideas than us cuz we
were correct. And being correct is the
best idea. The best idea is to be
correct. Can you tell I was one of those
students when I was younger? Anyway, we
are getting into round eight, the final
round of the day. Looking for those
winningins. Six wins gets you into our
day two competition where we finish out
Swiss and then cut to our top eight here
in Bologna.
>> Honestly, I'm already buzzing for
tomorrow and we're not even done with
today yet. We've got another banger of a
match coming forward. Quite frankly,
there are two exceptionally strong decks
coming our way once again. And this is
where we really get into the
nitty-gritty of it. This is the the bit
where anyone could go all the way. the
people that we are featuring could get
all the way to top eight or even the
best of their deck cuz remember whoever
does come first place tomorrow. Whoever
is crowned our champion is also going to
be the best of
>> Yes, that's true.
>> That's a cool thing to think about. You
get your cool medal card and you get the
ruin king special card and you get the
playmat and you get 6,000 uh
>> US dollars, right? It's a win-win
win-win-win situation.
>> That is win win win. And that's exactly
what you need to do to get there. You
can have countered that. I don't think
it was enough wins. You might need a few
more. Let's get into the game, though.
We're going to be casting some Urelia
versus Draven to round out the day as we
go to center stage in our feature match
area. Players have been here since about
9:00 a.m. this morning, over 12 hours so
far. Alongside that, our production
staff and the judges have been here for
a huge amount of time. Huge credit to
them for the amazing show that they have
managed to put on.
>> Great username. I'm just going to say
it. I'm just going to put that out there
really quickly.
>> Jesus Rice
>> coming in with a glorious executioner.
>> Fabulous. Love to see it. A lot of it
today, but I'm not sick of him yet. You
know, I love the play style of the deck.
It's really strong. It was pointed to be
one of the strongest decks coming into
today. Uh however we do have of course
Aurelia stepping up to the benchmark to
>> you know put that put that to the test a
little bit.
>> Interesting choices here. Yasuo Wind
Rider is going to get you that point if
you move three times in a turn. No
Draven audacious which is something we
have seen in a few lists. So looking for
that Yasuo to perhaps blow out the game
from nowhere if you're able to move him
around effectively. the usual package of
your Stellicorns, your ride the winds,
gas, uh, and things like not so fast
just to avoid some of that interaction
coming out from the Draven. We'll jump
straight on into game one though, see
who got the honor of going first and
what battlefields we will be fighting
on.
>> Yeah, it's quite advantageous for
Aurelia decks to be going first. So,
that's always what you want as the
Aurelia player. Uh don't give uh Draven
too much to kind of jump off the mark
with. But it is going to be Draven
first. So let's see how we do. See if we
can get some cheap units down early just
to keep get the ball rolling.
Overzealous fan really couldn't ask for
better.
>> Yeah, always really nice to get the
overzealous fan out early. Gives you a
lot more power when you are looking for
those attacks. Revers as well does mean
that when you're defending you can just
retreat one of those units pretty
easily. the dreaming tree there for the
extra card draw as well coming out from
G boy here on the Aurelia G early no
first turn unit here things like the
lonely porrow you do sometimes look for
selicon her obviously costing four so
unless you have an obelisk down you
cannot quite get enough runes on that
turn one there is going to be a response
to the overzealous fan gust it back to
hand and this is something that Aurelia
does need to do into these mid-rangy
Dravens and even
decks that are playing a lot of units
early is try to avoid getting too far
behind in terms of score tempo.
>> Yeah, you've got to you got if you don't
get the initial cast of the sneaky deck
hand and being able to kind of take some
points there or go early with the
Stellicorn Herders so that you can draw
more cards. You really need to stop your
opponent from doing that instead.
>> Interesting to see the Ulia just play it
out here without too much protection.
The Guardian Angel not equipped to her
either. This could be a bit of a bait.
If you have a second Aurelia in hand,
you can play around. Well, maybe the
Draven goes for it. Maybe the Draven
tries to find a way to take it down.
Although Draven doesn't have too many
tools to do that, you're looking at a
piercing light perhaps with no units on
a battlefield. It's pretty tricky to
actually get that down.
>> Here's a stack deck. Once again,
improving our card draw. Both sides of
the field are going to be wanting to do
that. Of course, Dreaming Tree is going
to help a little bit with that as well.
Um, so just contemplating what to take
here. I think ultimately Draven is just
such an aggressive deck in this matchup
and you do just want to keep kind of
barreling your way in
>> that Oh, this is a bit of a tough one.
Going with the spinning axe to the
bottom is a bit of a concern.
>> It is. Uh, taking the rebuke though is
quite nice. Allows you to when that
Aelia has been really buffed up. It's
one deflect. You do have to pay the
extra power to get it away, but when
it's been really buffed up, just
bouncing it straight back to hand does
allow you a little bit more freedom in
thinking about how you want to deal with
it. Can also base a two for one, a three
for one in certain situations. Aelia are
very strong as the game goes on. Cly
going in for the conquer. We'll get that
card draw. Darius coming in as the
second card for turn immediately
readied. We'll see if it decides to go
to the dreaming tree.
>> Not yet. I think you're just gonna leave
it in base. Even if it were to be ready,
if you want to leave it in base,
>> that's perfectly fine at this stage of
the game. You kind of want to build up
units because you know that Aurelia is
going to be doing the same.
>> Oh, 100%. I entirely get it. What have
we got? We've got Swifties. We've got
the Wind Rider, Defiant Dancer,
Discipline, and a not so fast in this
Aurelia's hand right now. Wind Rider
works really well when you have Ride the
Wind, unsurprisingly, for the Yasuo. It
gives you that ability to get extra
points on a turn. You need to move it
three times in a turn to get that extra
point, but you can use that to go from
seven to eight, which is really
powerful.
>> Yeah, that's the thing. You can use it
to kind of score that extra point and
that just to be your win condition at
that point. So, bringing that together
at the end of the game is a beautiful
combination and something that really
makes Aurelia shine in this matchup
specifically.
>> We're just going to see the going on to
Dreaming Tree here. It does have that
plus one might from being readed at the
start of the turn. Guardian Angel going
to target it here which will give it
another plus one might. We can use our
blade dancer to ready it if we so
desire. Swifties on for the ganking.
>> Not readying, not going over to the
Kaiser's battlefield instead. Just
trying to hold here. Keeping those runes
up for a little bit of protection.
>> Yeah, she got the boots with the fern
and the whole club is looking at her.
over there keeping a really strong
making sure that we've got not only
ganking can move around now but also
that protection which is really key to
this match up as we saw earlier today
with the guardian angel.
>> Yeah, guardian angel can do a lot of
work here. Double fight or flight. We've
got the mind splitter and a brin here.
Looks like we're just going to go and
have a peek at G boy's hand. Jesus rice
omnipotent in this situation does make
sense. Not quite omnipresent yet.
>> Not yet. But could be. I mean, if any
deck's going to achieve it for Jesus
Rice. We're going to have Draven.
>> Has the omniscience, has the
omnipotence, doesn't have the
omnipresent.
>> Yeah,
>> it's only a matter of time for Draven to
come through with that. But mind
blittering this kind of It feels early.
It feels early in the game, right? And I
feel like that can be so impactful.
>> It really can. Interestingly, looking
for the extra cards here. Good boy.
trying to
pad out the hand to give more options to
Jesus Rice. Also, if you have a
discipline in hand, that's a a double
card draw when you're on the Dreaming
Tree with the Curelia. So, getting those
extra cards so the discipline can't be
discarded from your hand by the mind
splitter does make sense. We drew a
sneaky deck hand and a fight or flight.
It's a difficult choice here. I think
the Defiant Dance is obviously something
you often look towards. Wind Rider as
well. Very powerful for those late game
turns. We'll see if that is exactly
where Jesus rice wants to go with a
pick, but it is going to be in the end
the Defiant Dance.
>> I think it's a really solid pick. I
think I was thinking exactly the same,
too. It's either hm powerful unit that's
also great late game or Defiant Dance,
which I just know counters what I'm
trying to do. That's like my whole jam.
And I really don't want you to play
that. It's a really strong card. It is
one of the best cards in this deck in my
opinion. And honestly,
I completely respect the choice to take
that early. And I think the early mind
splitter was a great choice. It's not
too often that you see that like kind of
this early in a Draven match up. You
usually kind of have more units on the
board going more aggressive, but I like
the early mind splitter. We have the
potential to do it. Why not at this
stage? But I think that does put Aurelia
in a bit of a sticky situation.
>> Yeah, I think if the ride the wind had
been in hand, then the wind rider makes
a lot more sense cuz you have the combo.
have the ability to get those extra
points on a turn. But for now, we just
have ganking across here onto Reaver's
row. Still very powerful. Can like sit
in this sort of position if you want,
but you are staring down at least 16
might on the next turn. And with
Draven's ability to play multiple cards
in a turn with the cheap spells that you
have, it makes sense that you want to
either get this Aelia off this
battlefield or have enough tools to
bolster up to defend into a Darius
Kaiser mind spitter push.
>> Yes, which we might well see. Luckily,
we've got Guardian Angel to protect us a
little bit.
>> True.
>> But it's not going to stick around for
long. And we're going to have a little
bit of a time when it comes to actually
managing to get more units down on the
board, especially now that Jesus Rice
knows there aren't any more meaningful
units in their opponent's hands.
>> That's true. That's true. Jesus Rice has
that perfect information. Got a fan of
Brin here. Hard bargain. You know, too
impactful right now. In fact, it's
double fight and flight. It can be used
to to bump that Aurelia back, but the
Urela is going to get retreated if you
go in for the attack anyway, assuming
that we don't have enough in our hand on
the G boy side. Looks like we're just
going to send the Kaiser in to make sure
we get that early card draw. As you've
been saying a few times today, draw
early, draw often, get as many of those
cards as possible before expending your
resources on your turn. maximizing the
dreaming tree triggers and having that
extra where you can honestly will make a
big difference in how this plays out for
both players.
>> We are going to ride the win though. The
Aurelia over to the Kaiser taking this
battle.
>> Ooh, over to the dreaming tree.
>> Yeah, and we It's fight or flight or
nothing really for Chees Rice. Didn't
want to use the hard bargain because
there's enough energy up for Good Boy to
pay for it anyway, even if you repeated
it. So, does look like it's going to be
a fight or fighting the deflect cost.
Yeah, absolutely.
>> Yeah, there we are. Going to have to pay
that deflect. Puts it back. Still has a
ton of runes to work with. Now, we do
have a not so fast SC boy. Do we want to
invest that singular counter spell in
our hand at this moment to kill a
Kaiser?
>> You know what? I think we have to. I
think when you look at the other units
on the board and our lone Aurelia and
knowing that we only have one other unit
in hand right now, what else do you do?
We're not so fast.
>> Yeah, we are not so fast. Jesus Rice
does have another fight or flight, but
it's going to be two power recycled this
turn just to deal with this singular
Ireelia have to do it. You feel if
you've already invested one into it, a
second doesn't really go too much
further. So there we are. Good boy now
has nothing in hand to deal with this as
far as I remember. I think maybe they do
have a fight or flight of their own, but
pushing the back doesn't actually matter
too much. You end up getting rid of two
runes from Cheeses Rice. He will get a
draw
from the conquer. Take himself two three
points. Also got a draw from the
dreaming tree trigger which was the
first draw that we saw there. In hand we
add
>> a switcheroo which can be big
>> or can be small. That's kind of thing
with switcheroo.
>> Either way around is quite helpful. Up
to four points there by popping Darius
into the other battlefield. And now just
yeah doing what Draven does really and
getting a lot of units onto the board so
that we can make those buffs, meaningful
plays and really impactful assaults on
battlefields. And of course a hidden
card there goes in with Kaiser just to
make Aurelia sweat a little.
>> The odds on is that it's a switcheroo
>> cuz what are your options? Fight or
flight you've already used two of them.
>> You have.
>> So statistically much more likely to be
a switcheroo than something else.
However, too often people are caught out
by the statistics. Sometimes you got to
play with your gut and we see if that's
what G Boy does here.
>> Could go into the Darius battlefield to
kick things off. This Aelia still very
big. Has the boots of swiftness. Has
that guardian angel on her.
>> She's got protection.
>> Yes,
>> but it isn't going to last forever. And
I think that's my concern with this is
that actually
>> that is one unit. And the other only
other unit in hand is Yasawo, right? and
Yasawo not doing a whole lot right now.
And so unfortunately it it kind of does
feel bad. So we go okay trying for the
fight or flight on the Kaiser
>> which I don't think they have a response
to. So I think that I think that works.
>> You can not respond with the switcheroo,
right? Cuz it's the same battlefield I
believe that you have to play it on.
>> Yeah. So the switcheroo goes away
because the Kaiser was knocked back to
base.
>> Yeah. I was just wondering if you could
switch through the Kaiser with the
Darius or something, but no, you can't
do it. Has to be the same Battlefield.
Darius is going to die or get retreated
with the Reaver's ro trigger here as
well. So, in the end, switch another
power loss, but not too consequential in
the grand scheme of things. Losing a
hidden card obviously isn't the best,
but you haven't invested a lot of
resources into placing it there.
>> Well, when you think about how this is
forming together, right, we're at four
points aside. one battle well one
>> I say battlefield but it's a base uh one
base absolutely flush with units and
then one single Aurelia dancing around
this stage making a beautiful display
enough that we are scoring points to
keep up with it. How stunning is that?
>> She's a she's a blade dancer. She's a
ballet dancer. She's a figure skater.
That's exactly what Aurelia does so
well. Her ability to avoid taking too
much damage or be buffed up high enough
that she can deal with her threats is
very impactful. So
>> we got another switch.
>> Another switch coming out is big here.
But without the units of the battlefield
becomes a little bit tricky. I could
move in with the Kaiser then use that
switcheroo. But if you're using it
>> oh natural like this instead of having
it as a hidden card that is two power
that you need to invest into it. here
comes down,
meaning no more spells can be cast and
more cards can be played by G Boy this
turn. Going to lose that sneaky deck
into the Kaiser. That's a draw.
>> Kaiser straight into that dreaming tree.
>> Yeah, it's a double draw with the combat
win and with the Kaiser conquer trigger
moves to five a piece. And now the
Aurelia sitting at what are we at? 67.
Oh, I did not mean that. If you did any
hand motions at home, you should feel
ashamed about yourself.
>> Darius goes in.
And alongside it, I can't remember what
card that was underneath it.
>> Uh, was it an Noxus hopeful?
>> It quite possibly hopeful. I think that
makes
>> that was something else that was on the
battlefield. I was like, where's it
gone?
>> Going to lose the G.
>> It's gone.
>> Gets recalled to base. Six points now
for Jesus Rice. just two away from
>> an 80 sweep in day one.
>> Well, he they will need to win another
game in this series.
>> Oh, that is true.
>> It will be the second coming of Jesus
Rice and of G Boy in that game.
>> It really will. And honestly,
>> I'm excited to see it. I want to see all
of the games. I could I could watch this
dance be played
>> every day of the week. And honestly,
>> it's great. I'm a bit concerned about
Aurelia right now, though. I got to say
I'm concerned. She's lost some of that
protection. She's running low on
resources. No other friends in base or
any battlefields. It's starting to look
a little bad.
>> It's starting to look very hairy for the
Aurelia. Sometimes you do need a little
bit of support and her support systems
have collapsed around her. Another
hidden card going down onto Rever's row
here.
>> What could it be?
>> Who knows? Well, it's not a switcheroo.
There's still one in hand. So, a fight
or flight or a couple of fights or
flights.
We've got more hidden cards. So, I'll
leave it up to you guys at home to think
about what on earth they could be based
on what we've seen over the course of
the day. Remembering the switch room is
still in hand.
>> Remembering two fights or flights have
been used.
>> Mhm. We can only have three of a card in
deck in a riftbound as your play set of
cards is three.
>> That is true. That is true.
>> There's a lot of hidden cards in Ka in
this deck right now that's helping
Kaiser to be able to stay on this fight
and survive.
They haven't seen the Darius come
through yet, which is the Draven come
through right now, which is really
interesting from the champion zone as
well. So, we still have that option
later as well. So, we still got really
ferocious units kind of ready to go.
Whereas Aurelia, obviously, they always
want to get that Aurelia out early and
then push for more units later.
>> We're going to go and have a battle at
the Dreaming Tree. Reaction seem to be
coming out with that hidden card. The
Aelia in and of itself stronger than
this Kaiser when it comes to 1 v one
combat. We saw the TI turner in hand.
Final flight onto the Kaiser will knock
her back. That's the third used for
Cheeses Rice, at least as far as I
recall.
>> Yeah, I think it very well will be.
>> Yeah. So, what are we doing with this
Titer then? Can Titer base bring the
Aurelia back? Use the fact it was chosen
with your blade dancer to exhaust it.
Pay a power, ready it, then take it over
to the reaver's road to clear out both
the battlefields if we so desire.
However, you and I know that that's
probably a switcheroo being hidden
towards the top side. Could be an edge
of knight. We do sometimes see that.
>> But the third switcheroo could have been
drawn
>> if I had the exact deck list. Some some
decks only run two of them.
>> That's true.
>> Maybe there's another hidden card that
uh
>> I mean tieer itself.
>> Tieer itself could be hidden there.
Okay, going with another boots. Um,
>> it's going to ready though. And cuz you
have the boots of swiftness, you have
ganking anyway.
>> So, we can
>> move across to that other battlefield
now with two boots of swiftness
attached. It's really pumping out the
extra might there total, I think.
>> So, is it even if it's a tie turner,
mind spplitter swaps with the hopeful,
you still lose that battle. Do you just
let the hopeful die? react.
It was a tie turner.
>> It was that it was that it was the tides
were turned
>> and we just Yeah. brought that back to
the base. Let Tie Turner go and just
said, "Okay, this isn't my battle right
now." And that's okay. That's kind of
what Aurelia does.
>> Yeah.
>> She's strong in her own right. She's a
strong independent woman. She doesn't
need no anyone else on any battlefield
ever.
>> It's very true. It's very true. Seven
now for G Boy. But with these two cards
in hand, you do not have Ireelia
protection.
>> No. Do you go all out and just chuck
everything on this battlefield to try
and hold? I feel that's what's going to
happen.
>> You've got to. You've got to you've got
to protect her at this point. You just
got to keep yourself in the game and
then Jesus is going to try and come
forward and challenge that to take over
cuz whoever manages to take both
battlefields at this stage is the winner
of our first game of this round eight.
In totality, it will be 14 might
defending when the TI turner flips over.
Titoner doesn't have a target to swap
with. Irat the Cartek says at a
location, it's now another location. So,
because there's no units anywhere else,
Titoner can't switch. Kaiser going into
the dreaming tree will be a singular
draw from that because there was no
combat. So, Glorious Executioner
spinning blade off that I think.
>> Okay, spinning axes.
We have 9 + 7 is quite a lot. In fact,
that's enough in and of itself. That's
16.
>> I guess the argument that Jesus Rice has
to think through here is what is that
hidden card? We know it's a tide turner.
If it's a fight or flight, you do lose
the battle.
>> Yeah,
>> but they're taking that chance.
>> they're considering
playing another card here.
I think there is a contemplation.
>> Good boy scoops.
>> And that's it. The first game goes to
Jesus Rice.
>> What a performance.
>> I don't think we need to say much more.
That was it was fantastic.
>> It was one of those weird ones where
>> Good boy had to invest quite a lot to
keep their Aurelia alive through the mid
and early game. And then because of
that, you ended up in a position where
you hadn't drawn many cards. We didn't
see a Stellicorn herder. We didn't see a
lonely po. We didn't see any of this
card draw. And so because of that, you
were sitting in a spot where it's like I
well I I have two units and no defense,
no protection from Aurelia at all.
>> And that's what we saw Aurelia do to
great success earlier today was actually
having that protection, having that card
draw, fight off lighting, using ong
guard and charm. We saw none of that.
>> Yeah, it's a struggle overall. Jesus
rice is only running two switcheroos. We
should remember that.
>> We shall
>> for the ch uh for the chucher for the
future. So it's been a long day. You
you've been saying cheese is rice too
much and now
>> everything is chut now for me. Only two
switches single a stellicorn herder in
the sideboard. Draven audacious there as
well.
>> We do have the audacious. That's good.
We might bring the stellicorn in just
>> to try and mitigate that lack of draw
that we had that previous game with the
really lackluster kind of kickoff for
Aurelia after the initial kind of what
you'd expect to see from Aurelia really
in the early game and then there was
just no card draw to back it Yeah, it's
a bit of a struggle overall. Only
running we are running two irrelia
fervents. I'm not 100% sure. I'm
assuming the champion and the one in the
deck list are two separate instances,
but it could just be the one fervent in
totality. Only running one Stellacicorn.
What would we take out for it? You need
to sneak your deck out for the early
points. Defy is okay, but doesn't do too
much into things like Switcheroo or
Falling Star. So perhaps not the optimal
in this matchup. could be used on
something like a stack deck or ride the
wind I guess.
>> Yeah, I would say so. I mean, it's a
difficult decision regardless of
anything. I think that is one of the key
core mechanics of Riftbound is that in a
best of three, this can be a really
tricky situation and we need to make
sure that you're side decking the
correct cards in the correct matchups,
taking things out and in. It's not a one
assided affair. We need to make sure
that you're kind of
>> making those correct decisions and that
is those are decisions I'm personally
really bad at.
>> Have you ever seen a turn one four
runes?
>> Turn one Stellacicorn would be a vibe
here for good boy instead.
>> Oh, we've got
>> GA. I mean, it's not ideal, but it's
okay.
>> I don't hate it. I don't hate it. And it
is not ideal. The Stellorn would have
been so nice getting that extra early
res. Oh my gosh.
>> Five for Draven.
>> That feels punishing.
>> It really does.
>> You don't want to give Draven five on
their first turn.
>> Yeah, double Obisk of power and it's a
tight turn and not as hopeful.
>> I know which side of that trade I would
take.
>> Luckily, the one doesn't matter too much
in this instance. Kind of the four is
all you can really spend, so that's
fine. But just for the ramp for later,
just having those extra runes out so
early kind of feels bad. But hopefully
Good Boy will be able to pull through
and use their advantage of having those
extra runes as well. And hopefully that
will get us into some more card draw
this time. We'll see some actual uh some
pop off for from Aelia.
>> I agree. I agree. We don't have much
card draw in hand though. I saw a sneaky
deck hand for those early points, but
then you you really risk just losing the
combat immediately to the noxious
hopeful.
>> Unfortunately,
>> I think it was two not so fast, which is
also sub ideal. The Aelia coming out
though once again will be stuck with
that one pesky rune remaining.
>> Not really too much direct kill threat
in base from Jesus, right? So we I think
we when we relooked at their deck list,
they weren't running the piercing light.
So not too much threat there for a
repeated piercing light for the uh full
of four might, but so many runes
available now.
>> That's a lot for a Draven deck. That's a
lot. And we've got
>> we've Oh my goodness.
>> We have what
>> what are we going to go for?
>> I mean, I think falling star here is an
absolute vibe.
>> Yeah,
>> the guardian angel is not equipped. The
Aurelia is there and ready for the
taking. Oh, it's happening.
>> Punished, punished, punished. Good boy.
Thought without protection they could
put their Aellia Fervent out, but this
is heartbreaking here for our Blade
Dancer Compatriot.
>> Oh, needing to really attach that
equipment beforehand would have been
essential
into a hard
should have waited for the targets, but
a massive play for Jesus Rice. GK boy.
Well,
>> oh that it was those extra runes. It was
those extra runes. All of those just
came together to mean that the back and
forth could happen. And now Aurelia is
just out of play. Is there going to be
able to be a comeback from that? I don't
think so. I think Jesus has just said,
"Look, I'm taking these battlefields.
I'm putting a strong stance. This is the
League of Draven and I am taking these
by force."
>> And if you go for it, you're kicking
yourself cuz the GA's there,
>> right? You had the runes. You could you
could have equipped it. You decided
against it. Have to remember these
players have been here since 9:00 this
morning. We are over 12 hours into the
day. 7 and0 so far. Small miss players
are likely to be made. But what a
devastating moment for Good Boy after
bringing the Aurelia out early doors.
Jesus Rice now in prime position. It is
only a noises hopeful and a tie turner.
But you're going to hold unless Good Boy
decides to trade a tie turner into
another just to get rid of one of those
points.
>> It's just a heartbreaking scenario. I
can't see a way out of this right now.
We need card draw.
>> Yeah.
>> And we just don't have it because to be
able to kind of come back from that
situation,
>> it's just devastating. I can't see a
world where right now we're making
particularly meaningful actions. We can
trade with a dis. So there is a
discipline ride the wind line here.
>> Okay.
>> Where you win the trade into the tide
turner. Get that plus two might. I can't
remember exactly what was in Jesus
rice's hand. Get the draw.
>> It is a fight of flight.
>> Maybe just bounce your own tide.
>> So you might just bounce just to protect
yourself.
>> I'm going to do so. Going to Oh, but no,
you bounce the enemy Titan back, right?
Try and hold. Now there is a ride the
wind which was the angle I was thinking
maybe you ride the wind the uh titan
over to the noxious hopeful just to
clear the board. Jesus Rice has expended
a lot of runes. Not so fast. Okay,
>> he's going to be cast here to stop that
fight or flight. Getting the knock back
>> kills the tide turner. Moses has parted
the Red Sea and Cheeses Rice can only
watch
>> as it all unfolds. And I mean, if the
comeback is coming, here it is. We
managed to get a tie turner down. Okay,
>> ready swaperoo.
>> Love that.
>> Nice. ready can go into the Nox as
hopeful
>> go at five.
>> I think we're counting to make sure that
we paid the cost for the blade dancer. I
thought we had but I did also look away
for a moment. I made that great joke
about the red sea so I was slightly
distracted.
Okay, going to ready with the blade
dancer. Equip the G. Go into the Nox.
Wipe the board. Good turn around here
for good boy.
>> Fantastic. Literally turning the tides
using these I know. Perfection.
>> Perfection.
>> Now the question is these two tide
turners in Noah's arc. Can they survive
the flooding? A Kaiser and a Brin here.
Thundersong in hand.
>> I don't know if there's enough runes to
be able to kind of accelerate that
Kaiser into play and kind of make a
knock back now. I think it might just be
a simple play to base.
>> I think we have five. So you could
>> recycle one. It that you have tapped
five there. There's the accelerate. Go
into the tide turn. Now the question is
do we take the one with the GA
>> or do we take the other? I feel like you
go to the top.
>> I think we go for the other. We leave
the GA alone. The GA like it's kind of
stuck.
>> Yes,
>> it's stuck on that Titan. We don't want
it on there ideally. It's actually kind
of a bad unit to have it on. We kind of
don't want that right now. So if
anything, it's kind of, oh, I can deal
with that later. I just want a point.
Whereas if you go for the one with the
G. Nah. Exactly. Double draw.
>> Double Brin here and a spinning axe in
hand for G Boy. A really good play to
get out of a little bit of a hairy
situation, but still no Aurelia in hand.
I'm not even sure if we have units in
hand. We'll get the hold from the Tide
Turner.
>> But now it's whether we can catch back
up. Jesus Rice, of course, got the
trigger off the Draven Glorious
Executioner ability there. So, they've
got more cards in hand even than before.
And Guck boy just kind of hanging on by
a thread here. Maybe it's just the
thread he needs because we we saw that
come back. It was very impressive.
>> Deckand.
>> Okay. And then coming back protecting
our assets. I like it.
>> Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Retreat the tie turner
>> and just to pass over. So we get the
whole point on the Kaiser.
>> And we're up to four.
>> And the reason you retreat here is you
don't want to allow Draven combats. No.
>> You know what you have in your hand.
It's like, okay, I can retreat. I have
six might next turn that I can use to
threaten a battlefield
>> and a stacked deck. We're just going to
keep digging.
>> This is great for Draven wanting to look
at the top three cards for one in your
hand. Recycle the others. Do we go for
the Darius to keep the pressure on?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> I like that.
>> Powerful units are exactly that. And
when you're facing into a tight turn or
a sneaky deck and seven might is a huge
hurdle to overcome. Grab the Darius.
could play it this I can't see exactly
how many runes there are. I feel like
there should be five. Yeah, could play
the Darius this turn. Instead, go for
the Draven. Hold the Darius back
>> and just like it.
>> Yeah,
>> D says, "Man, I'm good." And comes on
in. Is there like I'm already here,
mate. Been doing so much work.
>> The dream team's been working. Dream
team has been working. Um I do like
using known information over using
unknown information. Yeah, you playing
things that are on the field rather than
in your hand
>> does leave enough to the imagination for
your opponent and makes them sweat a
little bit more. We've talked about that
earlier. We've seen a lot of plays today
which have left our competitors with
zero cards in hand and it just leaves
you very very
>> kind of open to to anything your
opponent can throw at you, which is
really scary place to be.
>> Credit to G Boy though getting up to
five, not hiding the fight or flight. I
did wonder if we'd see a fight or flight
hidden. And I think the reason you don't
do it here is now you have the option to
play it on either battlefield. If you
hide it with the sneaky deck and or with
the tie turner, you don't have as many
options. So we could get into a
discipline war into a fight or flight.
Uh Brin here, treasure hunter here in
hand. Briner is going to come out. And
now the problem is, oh my goodness, I
can't play the cards. Do I discipline
straight away to get that first card
draw? Then do I fight or flight one of
my units just to get away from one of
those combats? because every combat well
the first combat one is that drawn card,
right?
>> Yeah, God point knows that their whole
game plan for this turn was to do the
fight back. Like that is exactly what
all those runes are saying to me. And
Jesus Rice knows that. So they're just
kind of like, okay, I'm just going to
have to just go with the flow here and
see what happens when I do go in with
these and see how much Gut Boy can push
back.
>> And it is every combat uh not just the
first. So, the first uh
time we'll see it coming into effect is
this Draven Vanquisher moving to the
bottom battlefield. That will get a gold
for Jesus Rice and a singular card draw
from the Glorious Executioner.
>> And of course, our Titer does survive
the ordeal due to the Guardian Angel
being in play. So, that now does go to
the discard bar, which is such a shame.
>> Such a shame. But again, uh, good boy,
they fought valiantly back from being in
a position where their Urelia was just
dead. Now they're going to lose two
combats this turn. The conquer trigger
for the Kaiser is one draw. The glorious
execution of trigger is another draw.
And you see how big the hand of Jesus
Rice has become. Noxious hopeful, a mind
spplitter, a Brin here, a spinning ax.
The hopeful comes down just really
adding to the might that is on this side
of the board. Cookboy, a lonely tide
turner, but the waves have begun to wash
over him.
>> Let's see if they can turn everything
back around, sail this ship home, and
grab some more points,
>> but I'm not sure there's enough going on
in that hand, but I could very well be
wrong. I was last turn. I'd love to be
again.
>> Disciplining just for the card draw does
get the Titan up to four, which equals
with the Kaiser.
>> We can get a bit of removal there if we
have to, but not ideal to be able to
lose a unit at this stage. Yeah, not the
best at all.
>> We need to stay in it.
>> You need to get more of these coming
forward. Yeah, you need to get one of
these battlefields. You only have one
unit to do. So,
>> we're running out of time. The clock is
set.
>> Cheese rice is on six to G boys five
points.
>> I just don't see how you do it from this
position. You have one unit. You can
take one fight. Going to go into Draven
Vanquisher. We'll see how many fury
runes on the Draven trigger. Just the
one puts the Draven up to six might.
>> Response from G Boy. First action of the
turn on guard. Six on the tie turner
two.
>> That this is a beefy tie turner,
>> but it needs to be bigger, does it not?
Cuz you have to try and hold. And
there's a hopeful and a thunders song
coming in next turn.
>> Another on guard.
>> Ong guard.
>> And now even beefier tie turn. I think
it's the beefiest we've seen today. does
take out the Draven, but I just don't
know if it's enough.
>> Well, because you need the resources for
next turn.
>> Yep.
>> Good boy is going to have a two might
tie turner against a Noxious Hopeful and
a Brin here, Thundersong in hand as
well. We know there is a Darius and a
spinning axe. So, you can spinning axe
for the extra might. Then play the
Darius. Come in with a readied seven
might unit. What is a tie turner to do?
This is a tsunami, not a tide. You
cannot turn this one around. We'll gank
across with the right ride the wind.
>> But even so,
>> you cleared a couple.
>> Yeah,
>> you don't gain a Well, yeah. I mean, you
gain a point. You go up to seven, but
then
>> the only thing standing between Jesus
Rice and this win is one tight turner.
>> So,
how do you optimally sequence this? Go
in with Brin here and the Noxious
Hopeful. Then play the spinning axis.
You also have a ride the wind it seems.
Okay, just play your own Brin here.
>> Make it so that good boy has to invest
everything.
>> And there it is. There's the fist bump
and Jesus Rice takes takes Draven to the
top spot showing that they truly are the
glorious executioner
>> that they are 8 and0 on the day for
Jesus Rice. Guck boy unfortunately
taking their first loss. fought
valiantly after losing that Aurelia so
early on. Was able to get up to seven
points in the end, but wasn't quite able
to close it out. Well played all around
by Chooses Rice.
>> Absolutely. Honestly, I was really
impressed with the comebacks that we
were able to make there with Aurelia
with such a low unit count in both
games. It was just a shame we didn't get
to see kind of go the go the long run
with it being able to buff units in the
way that we typically know Aurelia to
do. And then it was just a bit all over
when we ran out of steam.
>> Yeah, it was just difficult for Kapo in
that position. But sometimes that
happens. It's one of the the weaknesses
of Aurelia is if you lose your Aurelia,
it becomes quite difficult to play that
deck. And she may be fervent, but she is
not
>> omnipresent. No. Unlike Jesus Rice.
>> Unlike Jesus Rice in that sticking with
us in this tournament towards the
>> melted Jesus rice.
>> Exactly. So, hey, here we go. We're
still going. There's going to be a lot
more where that came from cuz my
goodness, we had a blast so far today.
We have so much more action. And
honestly, I've loved every single moment
of our games today.
>> It's been amazing. I've had such a good
time here for day one of the regional
qualifier here in Bologna. I know our
caster colleagues are ready to close out
the day. So, we're going to hand it over
to them. Thank you very much for joining
us. We'll see you all tomorrow.
Medic and Amy uh really enjoyed the
Jesus rice cast. There are going to be
plenty more puns where that came from
tomorrow in our games. James and Leonard
here to get you just to the end of the
day. It's been an action-packed day of
Riftband. I've enjoyed every second of
it. Have you Leo? It was absolutely
amazing. Those games, almost all of them
came down to the wire really. We've seen
so many comebacks just like in this last
game. Almost a tight turner comeback.
Not quite. But there were so many games
that have been turned around when we
thought all hope was lost. There was
still some last trick up the player
sleeve. And I feel like we've we've seen
a really diverse set of games today. Um
we cast a Rumble game and I was not
expecting a Rumble to end round seven,
six, and one. Uh I was walking by the
the the top tables earlier. I know you
were too. I saw a Lux performing
incredibly well. I know that one of your
friends has performed quite well today
on a on a deck that we weren't really
expecting so much from. We have a Teemo
on 71 7-1 right now. That is absolutely
insane. Also a very prominent figure in
trading card games. So very sure that
we're going to see something of them
tomorrow. Yeah, some really interesting
champion selections for the day. And I
mean, we've got hopefully more to show
you tomorrow with a wide array of uh
champions. And you know, we came into
the event, we were predicting who do we
think was going to be good. Um I always
like to check in at the end of the day
and see, okay, our predictions, how did
they play out? Um, even though I didn't
cast any of the Draven games, uh, I will
still, you know, take the easy win on
Draven converting quite well today from
what we've seen. We will, of course,
when we have them when when round eight
is completed, we'll end up getting
standings uh for you uh online and as we
start tomorrow's broadcast, but I have a
I have a gut feeling that Draven did
pretty well today.
>> Yeah, I think so, too. Draven is I mean,
just the standout deck. We've seen this
in the last round. I mean, Jesus Christ
just uh he just
>> Rice. Yeah.
>> Whoops.
>> He got you. He got you. He got you.
>> Yeah, he got me good. Jesus. Rice ending
on 80 with Draven. Phenomenal
performance as well. Just very cleanly
played out those measures and you could
see what the deck does right when it
gets going. It was a really difficult
grind game. In the beginning, the Titer
comebacks from Aurelia were really
strong, but then in the end, you get
into some combats because it's
unavoidable at some point versus Draven.
Sometimes they get the card draws and
then they just Oh, I I can't whistle.
They just run away.
>> Yeah, they just run away and run away
with the game. Um, I know Medic picked
Civet. I do know there is a miracle
Civiver that I think went six and two
and made it to day two. I know they at
least crossed the threshold getting in
to the next round. So, lots going on in
the action here at Bolognia. But that
isn't the only place where you can
experience some competitive Rift Band.
If you are wondering where can I get all
the action for myself, you can check out
Nexus Knights and also the Summoner
Skirmish at stores near you. Scan the QR
codes on screen, use the event finder,
find out where you can potentially get a
a buy from a Summoner Skirmish in
potentially your next round. If that's
in Le, come and join us. Yeah, there's
probably some events this very weekend
around your place. So, just go there and
then tell the owner of the store that
they should have the stream on display.
>> Make sure you got the stream. I actually
have there's some streams going on in in
some local game stores doing a watch
party. So, hey, if you're still there
hanging on, I I bet now you've cracked
open packs and you're playing games cuz
we finished eight rounds of action. But
nevertheless, love having you with us on
the broadcast today. Um, so we've talked
about how you can get involved for
yourself. And for those of you that are
here in the stream watching, you're
wondering when do we come back? When do
we get the action going? Uh, of course
we played eight rounds today of Swiss.
We're not done with the Swiss portion.
We still have five rounds of Swiss for
everybody that qualified into day two.
And then we go to that all important top
eight bracket.
>> Look at him smiling. He just already
knows he's going to be in that top eight
bracket, right? I would assume that
we're going to see at least some Draven
making that far into the tournament. But
yeah, tomorrow five rounds of Swiss and
then Top A to finish it off and see who
can become the regional qualifier
champion of Bolognia.
>> Yeah, and that all starts at 11:00 a.m.
C tomorrow. So, be sure to join us
whether it's on the channel you're on
right now, whether it's YouTube or
Twitch on the official Riftband
channels. We will be back in the
morning. For now, um Leo and I are
actually just going to crack these
packs. So, uh, we're going to see if we
can pull a signed card in the meantime,
and we'll see you tomorrow morning,
bright and early, 11:00 for more
Riftbound action.
Do we fight to hold our heads up high
and beat the drum to what we love.
Risk the fall. We have felt it all come
crashing down from far above.
Stars are rising, countless worlds
colliding. Only one will take it all.
Can we bring to fall the giants? Can we
make the final call?
We are the ones to ignite the darkest
skies.
The champion
of the world that we define
a soul
of the frise of high. And we all
at the last
Join the madness when the curtain falls.
Risk it all. Hold back.
We must attack.
Stars are countless.
Only one will take it all. Can we bring
the giants? Can we make the Final call.
We are the ones to ignite the darken
skies.
The champions
of the world that we divide.
A s
of the horizon.
And we all
fight at the last.
Can we bring to fall the giants?
Can we bring to All the
can.
We are the ones to ignite the darkenes.
The The end of the world that we define
a soul
of the few rise up high as we all
fight at the